[Music]
Hallelujah.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat.
Welcome back everybody. I am once again
Bar Bryant joined by Aaron Bareric and I
really enjoyed what we just saw and it
just continues to grow. It just
continues to go because this tournament
is underway. We are now officially over
halfway done with the tournament and we
have a sixth round that we're eventually
going to start here, but I'm starting to
feel h unsure on what to expect for
tomorrow. So, I want to ask you,
I think we all could have made some
predictions, but I'm seeing some very
highlevel gameplay, obviously, from
these incredible players in this room,
but the legends on who I might see
tomorrow, I have no clue anymore. Do
you?
>> You know, I I'm confident we will still
be seeing some Kaiser, right? We're
still going to be seeing some of those
decks we know people are playing at the
top tables. Some, you know, we just saw
a great game with Master Yi, really well
played by Quint, and I think we're going
to see more of that.
But also, this is about the time when
stories are starting to get told. You're
about round six. You're doing well.
You're 4150. You're looking like you
have a day two birth.
What is your legend? What is your story?
Are you going to win the best of prize
or you going to do even farther? Are you
going to make that top cut? Are you
going to make a top eight? Are you going
to be the winner? And anyone here still
can. I think that's the craziest part is
that we're going to find out to some
degree after today. Some of these
players are going to go home with their
metallic uh best of prize already. You
know, these legends that are not as
represented and won't end up in day two
necessarily cuz I I mean they could all
make it. They really could, but I don't
know if they will. And then tomorrow you
have 64 players that are still fighting
for metallic cards. And I think that's
so exciting, not just for the main
prize, but this incredible piece. And I
I know we keep talking about it. We
really do keep bringing it up, but then
now I have this question of like, well,
I have no idea which of those metallic
prizes will still be sought after, and I
don't know what to expect.
>> Yeah. I mean, I think one of the really
great things about them is we're going
to see some really cool decks do make it
to that day two cut. People that were
fighting for that placement, you know,
they they want just the metallic card,
but that doesn't mean you don't have a
top 64 in you. And we maybe get to see
something really cool. maybe something
like an break into that day too and have
a really great performance.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And I think with that,
I think our player or most of the people
that are watching are looking for some
fun information that we have about the
tournament itself because we had a lot
of players here today and all of these
players that are here going into it. We
want to talk about necessarily like
what's going on in the room. And so with
those, I'm excited to see like what our
total character distribution is going to
look like. And we do currently have
standings for our third 64 currently top
place players. So these are of course
their summoner names. So for everybody
at home, you can keep track of who is
currently 5 and 0 coming out of this
round five.
>> Yeah, there's a couple names here. I
recognize Allen ZQ, uh former Run Terra,
legendary terra world champion. You have
Oric MTG, that's a Magic player who's
one of the best players uh to ever play
the game. You have Ali Aldrazi, we saw
him on camera earlier today playing
Misfortune, dazzling Aurora, still 5-0.
Uh really great players really vying for
something.
>> Wow. I mean the fact and again we're
only five rounds in so there's going to
be a bunch of these players that these
are all 5-0 and only a couple of them
will continue their path on going
undefeated including these other 16
players that are still involved. You
know there's a Barrett up there. I'm in
the running. Aaron, you know I hope you
yourself win a special card. Uh other
great name is Carmen Diego. Uh Carmen we
know is doing really great. uh did well
with the 10ks previously. Uh really
excited. There's Quint. We just watched
5-0. Really great with Mastery. Excited
to see more from them this weekend.
>> Gale wins is here also 24th or you know
tied for that 5-0. Um very known player
as well. So Gwin's doing well in getting
and moving continuing on into this
tournament. And this is only half of
what we have. We have the rest of our
current top 64 standings. Moving on to
the next 33rd through 48th. And of
course, you know, even more people that
we might recognize and for you at home
to keep track of your players. And I
think I want to pay attention
specifically in that 40 and1 section
39th through 46th because when you are
already have again still not a single
loss in the tournament, that draw can go
a long way when we start figuring out
what which players are already locked in
for top 64.
>> Yeah, the cut you're looking for today
very likely is 71 and one. That means
that the first draw isn't that bad. It
means the second draw pretty much a
loss, but it does mean you still have
that one loss to give throughout the
rest of the event.
>> Absolutely. And then of course after 48,
we've got the rest of the players that
are very much in contention of making 64
for day two. But a lot of this might
shift around of course moving on through
49th through 64th and again even more
names for people to keep an eye out and
who is doing well. So, I mean, at the
end of the day, like this is obviously
not every player that is currently 4 in
one. So, there are a bunch that are here
below it. Tiebreers get into, you know,
I I love tournament bracket math because
I think it really shows how late game
decisions in the tournament or maybe
unfortunate things that happen earlier
on, a lot of those consequences start
showing up as well.
>> Yeah, I mean, there are stories to be
told that are not on those screens. They
are legends team some people playing for
those best of prizes some people still
within that day two birth and who knows
what's going to happen anyone X and one
still alive if you are in that situation
you know you don't have another loss to
give it's back to the wall you're
anxious you're nervous every game but if
you keep it tight and you play well and
you don't let it get to you might be on
the stage the next day
>> you said 71 and1 is what we're looking
for there might be some players out
there that are x1 and1 and And if they
win out, they have an excellent story to
go through. So really looking for what
is going to be exciting going into day
two, but that is a story for tomorrow.
We still have things going on today. We
still have more rounds of Riftbound to
get through. Like I said, these players,
I do not envy them. Nine rounds in a day
is a lot of work, not just on executing
and making perfect plays, but like, you
know, you got to make sure you're still
eating food, drinking water, staying
hydrated, and that's one of the biggest
things I recommend to people at these
tournaments. It's kind of a cliche how
much people recommend that stuff, but
it's also really true. You get stuck in
these rounds, you're so in your own
head, and you just kind of forget to
take care of yourself and then you make
a stupid play and it's all over and you
look back and what could I have done
differently? Eating a granola bar. But
not for our players because we've got
our round six matchup coming up here and
I'm excited to see what's going on
because these are now the players as we
just saw from the top 64 breakdown. I is
the pressure maybe getting to them.
Aaron, you don't want to start losing
rounds now in round six because you're
so close to being at a point in the
tournament where you could potentially
ID your way out.
>> Yeah. I mean, there's two types of
mindsets. Some people say, "Oh, I am
undefeated.
I feel like the games don't even matter.
I still have a loss to give." And there
are some people that are like, "Oh, I'm
undefeated. It'll be so bad if I lose.
What if I win the whole event without
ever losing? Wouldn't that be so cool?"
and you could picture yourself with that
trophy and got not got to not let that
get to you.
>> Yeah. I mean, I think that is the
hardest thing to I can't even imag I
can't remember the time I played in a
tournament and I won without dropping a
like a match, right? I think that is so
hard to do and that's not even thinking
about, of course, not dropping a game.
That's near impossible, of course. So,
but we've got our round six coming up
for us and I'm excited to continue to
dive in for more Riftbound. And we've
got Snake who we saw obviously on our
leaderboard piloting now Misfortune that
we're aware of. And you mentioned
already Q.
>> Yeah, Alens Q again a legends of terror
world champion. One of the players I
watched a lot back in the day of that
game really having its competitive
scene. Awesome to see him here playing
Riftbound, playing Kai'Sa, a deck that
competitive players really tend to like.
Gives you lots of choices. Not surprised
to see him playing that here today. Uh I
am just thrilled enough to get to see
him again. Can I get your thoughts on
the misfortune deck? I think ganking is
the most fun interaction in this entire
game. I love movement is my favorite
thing. Obviously, I play showstoppers. I
play or you know legends like set, but
the fact that your legend can give any
one of your units the ability to move
from a battlefield to a battlefield, I
think that is awesome.
>> Yeah, I mean it's really powerful. One
of the key tenants of the game is that,
you know, you can only commit to one
place or another at a time. And
Misfortune as a legend says, "Ah, that's
not for me. I'm just going to play my
own game the way I want."
>> Yeah, absolutely. As we're already kind
of seeing because uh based off of the
cards that you see in a lot of
Misfortune decks that have popular play,
uh we are of course probably playing a
Dazzling Aurora variant, which is the
most popular deck for Misfortune of
course. And that's why we are leading
with our Battlefield 4 Experience Climb,
which says we must be playing to 9ine.
I'm excited to play with nine points
with you, Aaron, because we've only seen
some eight-point games and Reaver's Row
here on the side for Kai'Sa.
>> Yeah, these are interesting set of
battlefields. Aspen's Climb, you know,
you're setting your stake in the ground.
You're saying, I will win the long game.
Let me win the long game. My units are
the best. We can duke it out however you
want past that. Reaver's Row from Allen
pretty great against some of the ways
that the Misfortune deck kind of bullies
and kills your units. things like
misfortune having accelerate or dead
bloom predators just don't play as well
into that reverse row.
>> Yeah, I mean pretty standard early turns
here for both of these decks and you
know both of these players I think
acknowledging that you know we had the
two drop that came in for uh for Allen
and then we now have the stack deck then
followed up by immobilize which maybe we
found off of the stack deck but it's the
great starting point you want to start
ramping with this deck.
>> Certainly didn't have the mobilize in
our hand to start. We played a pack of
wonders on our first turn. a bit of a
weird card that, you know, not a lot of
decks really play, but you will see it
in these uh Dazzling Aurora decks to
reby some your gear and just draw more
cards and get a little bit of an engine
going during the early turns when, you
know, your deck full of giant monsters
isn't up to snuff yet.
>> Yeah, very quickly as well, you know,
going immediately into that Kaiser
Survivor from the champion zone, getting
the conquer, drawing a card, and it's on
the Reaver's Row, so we can also keep it
a little safe eventually when some units
start coming down for Snake. Yeah, this
is Alon's understanding the matchup,
right? We knows the game will be lost in
the long run. A lot of Kaiso players
don't accelerate the Kaiso on their
second turn, but we're doing it here. I
need to get the points as quick as
possible cuz I'm really only going to
get so big of a window to be able to
close this game.
>> Another stack deck coming in here for,
you know, more decisions. A lot of these
dazzling decks we know are all about
setup and then getting to the turns
where you eventually start playing units
or the dazzling itself. Uh uh real
quick, Aaron, uh these are two of the
most beautiful decks I've ever seen. Uh
just the amount of these runes and you
know the alternate that it's beautiful.
Of course, we've got our overnumbered
from both of our players here. What a
beautiful looking game state.
>> Love of the game.
>> Yeah,
>> you got to you got to appreciate a love
of the game.
>> The second pack of wonders not very good
compared to the first pack of wonders.
>> No, not at all. And of course, you know,
again, as we are setting oursel for
these dazzlings, you know, you are
conceding the point game 100% until we
get to that point.
>> Six runes for Allen. And I think a lot
of this too is what's your mindset when
you go against Dazzling? Obviously, I
think the easiest thing to do is like
you don't want to overcommit everything,
but when you're specifically playing
against the ma the misfortune version,
it has that chaos domain, which is
different than what you see like I don't
the VA decks or even Master Yi when they
do it because they have access to
different domains. And I think the hand
disruption that comes with this specific
duo of body and chaos, you don't
necessarily want to play all of your
resources because you need to hold them
for the dazzling plays or the units that
come after. But if you hold on to your
cards,
>> your opponent might know.
>> Yeah, sometimes they get taken. Well,
you're put into this weird squeeze
sometimes against Aurora. And I think
Allan felt that here, which is like,
well, I've scored both battlefields
already. I have maybe have a Darius or
some Accelerate unit in my hand, but I
can't I can't score anymore. I guess I'm
just going to play some units to the
base, and that's the best I can do. It
is one of the things with Riftbounders,
it's really really hard to get more than
two points at any given turn. And when
your opponent's not playing ball and not
fighting for these battlefields, it
sometimes feels like your cards are just
there.
And that's just what they are there in
in Allen's base. But they're safe. You
know, they feel safe at least,
especially when dead bloom predator
being the first card that's off the top
from the first ability of the dazzling
that can only be played at contested
battlefields. There aren't any.
>> This game is going really poorly found
really quickly. We had the dazzling aura
from Snake as quick as possible. This is
the game plan. The difference in this
deck between the games where you play
the quick Aurora and you don't are night
and day. Allen still needs to get four
more points even after this Kai'Sa
conquer. And this battlefield's about to
get really congested really quick from
Snake.
>> And we might even finally see the
ability from the Reaver's Row get used,
right? Because now there are units on
both sides of the table to allow things
to come back safely. And if it's a
Kaiser Survivor, that's exactly what you
want.
Yeah, Allan here pretty happy just to
trade any unit for a point. Whatever I
can take. I need to be able to get into
a situation where I can have a really
big thousand tailed watcher turn, shrink
all your stuff and be able to take both
those battlefields or set up a situation
where maybe a time warp is able to steal
depending on if Allen is playing many
copies of that. Uh knows the pressure is
on time is not on his side with Aurora
in play.
time not being wasted either as our
Darius being played from hand and just
going to send it back with the Darius.
Just again creating more units in our
base to use for later. And Darius of
course still has that trick of gaining
the two might whenever you do play your
second card for the turn. And that can
of course be later. It doesn't have to
just be played and used on the turn that
you're going for it. But this dead bloom
predator as we go back into Snake's turn
is going to easily take out this Pyro
for the first point for Snake. And now
you have all these runes to mess with
where we have to start thinking, do
units come from hand or do we play more
dazzlings?
>> A second dazzling aurora is about the
worst thing Allen can see. Uh I'm sure
Snake is elated. This is about as
perfect as things can go. We played some
pack of wonders that haven't really done
anything. But that doesn't matter a ton
when you are roaring out an eight drop
every single turn.
>> Absolutely. I can't wait to see what
comes off the top of these cuz I think
the units and a hidden card also coming
here. Can only imagine a fight orflight.
typically one of the only ones played in
this deck. But then, oh my gosh, the 12
cased Volivar, the body domain champion
unit for Volibar coming in, which means
even though we might not get a unit
played onto the Reaver's Row on the
second one, it' have to only be a dead
bloom.
There is
we are going to contest it and so the
Reaver's Row idea will come into play.
But I mean, a lot has happened. We we
have a bunch of units with a bunch of
might now hitting the table. And this
Volibar, I really want to dive in while
they go through cards and get some
information done. This Volair is one of
the best cards in set one, period,
strictly on its cost alone.
>> You love big monsters, huh? That's the
deal. I mean, this is the biggest one we
have, which is why these Dazzling Aurora
decks do play it. It is the biggest
thing you can hit when you get into some
of these Dazzling Aurora mirrors and you
need really large numbers. I mean, 10
might, lots of shield, draw some cards
if your opponent tries to ignore it. And
uh I mean Allan's at a spot I don't
think ignoring all this is a
possibility. you're going to have to try
and fight through and it's not looking
good for that
>> in the world where Allen might depending
on what it's saying might be forced to
ignore it because there's so much might
already built up on that experience
climb but you're ahead by four points
is giving away that amount of card
advantage because of the ability on
Volibar Imposing when an opponent moves
to a battlefield other than this one
draw one you can give away a lot of
cards but it might be the only way Allen
can find a way to gain points still
every turn.
>> Yeah, I mean this is a situation where
Allen just has to make the best of that
situation. We know that Snake is going
to be able to draw more cards, but Snake
already has the cards that they want.
These dazzling auroras are in play.
We're hiding fighter flights to make
sure we don't get uh blown out. And
Allan is at six, but we're playing to 9.
We need to go in and get to that magical
seven so that we can set up that really
big thousand tail watch return and make
a move there later.
Falling Star, the premier card for the
Kai'Sa deck and having a bunch of
success. Uh, is going to looks like it's
going to go for the double ping onto the
Voli Bear, which is going to deal six to
it, which means we're looking for four
more. That is void seeker range. Void
seeker, another falling star. One of the
things about Volo Bear in this matchup
is it is a big unit that's pretty weak
to the damage spells. Uh, smokec screen.
Another thing, minus four, no deflect on
that compared to these dead blue
predators that are much more punishing
to have to play these removal spells on.
Yeah, and as we saw Alan posture there,
we've now played some more spells for
the Raven Bloom to go up to four might.
And it was also our second card for the
turn. So the Darius has also gained two
might, which is really going to help us
contest these two dead blooms depending
on how much we want to invest.
>> Right. So your Allen sitting here,
you're like, "Okay, well there's a fight
or flight. My Darius, if I go in there,
probably getting kicked out. What's the
best case if that is what happens?"
Well, thinking about sending in a four
might Raven Bloom and a seven might
Darius. If that goes into the aspirin's
climb battlefield and you get fight or
fight it out, you definitely need a
second trick or you can send it into the
reavers row. But then you know snake's
just going to back the dead blue
mountain and be able to fight back and
keep pushing and maybe pile on that
other battlefield. Um, a really tough
situation between what can I do and what
Allen has in his hand, whether it's
smoke screens or void seekers or
whatever kind of trick really dictates
how he's allowed to split up this
damage.
That was a That was perfect. That was a
perfect assessment. And that's exactly
what Allan's thinking about. And I don't
envy his position because I think this
decides the game. Maybe.
>> Well, if he can't accomplish scoring the
battlefields this turn, he definitely
needs to score one of them. If if he
can't threaten that win, then there is
not really going to be another window to
do it. Um, Snake two points. Probably
going to get to four points next turn.
if not not like the points really matter
from Snakeside. You see this big
difference in point total, but also the
Aurora deck doesn't really win in that
way. It is the biggest deck. It will
clog both of these battlefields and use
Misfortune to gank back and forth to
make sure the opponent can never hold
and they can never score both
battlefields in the same turn and they
can never get that final point rule
really accomplishing. So this situation
Alan is trying to run through, you know,
okay, can I take both of these? Can I
set up where Snake has to kick me out of
both somehow? We've already used two
deadlin predators. That makes it hard.
If I can't do that, what is my plan to
take both of them later and score one
now? And then also, what units does
Snake have left? You know, we've seen
Volibear, we've seen these dead bloom
predators, we haven't seen anything
else. Are we going to see the third dead
bloom predator? What's the other big
monsters? Is there a chance snake
doesn't have any?
>> Maybe. Yeah, I mean, you know, I think
of the big ones that are typically
played in this deck, which are, you
know, mind spplitter. Uh, we see soul
gorgers sometimes seeing play in these,
at least when looking at like the chaos
units and like the soul gorgers, I think
sometimes spell disaster for the for,
you know, Allen situation because you
did all this work to get the ball bear
off of the board to get these dead bloom
predators off the board and soul gorge
says, "Hey, actually, instead of
grabbing them off the top of my deck,
I'll grab one from my trash." But a hex
tech ray coming in to deal three more
damage or sorry three damage to this
dead bloom which is going to make this
math at least a little easier for him.
And then also a falling stars. Two of
these triggers going to go on and we're
going to pick where they go.
>> Yeah, no runes left. This is a big turn
of just running into the deflect is
definitely leaning into all right this
is the turn that matters. What we are
doing here is we're losing so many of
our runes that it kind of takes out that
thousand tail watcher big play later
because we're just down to one rune.
Even if we retreat once and go up to
two, four, six, it's just going to take
way too long and definitely Snake will
have taken over the game at that point.
>> Yeah. And the correct read on that
fighter flight, but because we did it
all in spell damage, we're not going to
a showdown. And regardless if you move
that unit back to your base with the
fight or flight at reaction speed, it's
still going to take the damage from that
falling star. We would have had to have
preemptively read the play on the hex
tech ray to avoid that damage. But then
you can see the battlefield.
>> You know, if you're snake here, maybe
you think about doing that, but also,
>> oh, is Allen going to lose all of his
runes? Okay, fine. Yeah, I'll sign up
for that. That seems okay. Now, the
ability for Allen to make a comeback if
Snake has a pretty impressive turn this
turn. play a big thing from hand, hit
two more from the Auroras. It it it
closes the door really rapidly.
>> Absolutely it does. And we even have a
floating uh we we had to pay all that
deflect cost, right? We recycled all
those,
>> but instead the reaver's row ability is
going to come through and just take our
dead bloom back home.
>> Really, really interesting thing there
that Darius didn't beat that dead bloom
in combat. No,
>> that is a I believe you have cleave or
have stupify and I should run away,
which is the type of thing I don't know
if Allen has it, but certainly needs
Snake to believe that he does.
>> Yeah, I mean I I think it is the ad.
This is exactly I think Allen's key to
success for trying to figure out how to
win this game because with all of the
everything that entailed in this entire
turn, we are going to go up to eight. We
are one point away from winning the
game. And so now I think saving that
dead bloom was the play that Snake had
to make because we need to take
advantage of the fact that Allan got rid
of all of his runes like you said. And
that's easier to do when you're back on
your turn when you have access to your
runes.
>> Allan has committed to this being the
turn. Got to his eight points. Has these
battlefields.
Lot of pressure on Snake to find a way
to get rid of the second one. Allen
piling some units in. If he does have a
trick, maybe the seven might in the
reaver's row plus a trick is enough to
keep the dead bloom off. If it is, then
that really puts snake eating two more
cards, two more tricks, cuz looks like
we're going to end up with eight might
in this aspirin climb.
What types of tricks are available to
this deck? Things like confront, make
your units in ready, another big unit.
There is the captain fortune in the
champion zone which does allow you to
ready your unit. So you can go in with
the dead bloom predator, use the Captain
fortune to ready it, give it ganking and
move it from battlefield to battlefield.
So a lot of room to make some plays. You
don't need that many numbers to get over
the line here. Allen can't even bluff
two spells with this Darius.
>> No, not not at all. I mean, we only have
one rune and now you know we we only
have the one to play with. It's really
stupify or nothing, right? We don't even
have a we don't have a fury rune. We
can't even hex tech if that was one of
the options. Of course,
>> you can hex tech through daughter of the
void, but it's been used already.
Normally, that's a thing you're able to
do here. And I know when I play against
the the Kaiso deck, I sometimes forget.
We're just going to cleave for plus one
on our Raven Blue.
>> Yeah, I mean, that is all it's going to
do cuz assault not working when you're
defending, of course, but it means that
it is going to be enough. And that is
enough to even
Oh, we're going to just play from our
hand. It is the third one. It's the
third dead bloom predator. actually did
end up having it in our hand to contest
trade with the other battlefield from
that play and now it is up to Allen to
have to still recover
and that looks like he's going to give
it away with a mines soul gorge bringing
another unit back and he said that's it
that's enough to get over I'm out of
resources
>> yeah I mean I blew up all my runes I did
everything I could I set up a
battlefield that I hope you can't break
maybe you don't have the dead bloom
predator maybe your auroras hit other
things I you
Sometimes you have to play to your out
and that out's not real. But Allan I
thought did play that game well. He took
his lines. He knew he needed to do. He
got in the pressure and tried to get
those points. But also Snake did what he
needed to do. He played those stack
decks. He set up his hand. He found the
ramp and he ended up having two dazzling
auroras. The card in the deck that
matters the most. So both players did
their game plans as much as possible.
But ultimately one of them has to win.
>> Yeah. And at the end of the day that is
currently the misfortune up one game and
at least the spirits climb is out of the
way, right? But that means we still have
to deal with something like an obelisk
power, right? Because the same idea of
what you said of that is climb gave us
actually exactly the amount of time we
needed to fully unlock our deck's
capabilities. Obelisk power can do the
same story, but we have to find all
those same pieces like we did in game
game one for for the dazzling right
deck. So, we have game two that we still
have to go into, of course, and I'm
excited to check it out because I think
Allen did play that game very well, and
I think that means we can go to a game
three as well. But here we go, going in
on turn one. And our battlefields
workers, Arena's greatest is going to
help uh speed that up. And then we have
Sigil of the Storm being the battlefield
of choice here for Snake.
>> Choosing Sigil of the Storm when you're
on the draw. I'm used to a lot of the
misfortune players when they're going
second. You want to take that obliska
power so you can have that four energy
and have that really powerful start with
like a catalyst of aons. It seems like
snakes not going that route. Maybe
saying, you know, I want to save that
for when I'm on the play and then I'll
have three and I I'll be able to
maximize that being a head deal. Arena's
greatest from Allen totally to be
expected. Leaning into I'm a more
aggressive Kaiso deck. I want to be able
to steal points in a game where I'm on
the play.
>> Treasure treasure trove coming down. uh
different than the pack of wonders of
course than what we saw, but this is the
kind of combo that you were talking
about and alluding to in game one that
we didn't really see unlocked, right? Um
but the idea here, I agree with you. I
mean, I'm going to learn a lot I think
in this game and if we go to a game
three and the Obeliska power does come
up because I guess it it's just not the
decision that I've seen a lot of players
take. But Snake is playing better than I
am in the tournament, of course. So, I
do trust his judgment on what's going
on. And you're right, Sigil of the Storm
will slow down a lot of what's going on
for what Allan did in game one.
>> This game is really funny to me. I I I
like Pack of Wonders a lot. These
Misfortune Dowsing Raw decks played a
reasonable amount, but it is kind of a
twocard combo. You need it plus things
uh like this treasure trove or some
people have played cards like Scrap Peep
and you can keep bouncing them and keep
drawing cards, but when you get just one
half of them, it feels pretty mopey. The
other side to that is Snake played two
pack of wonders last game and that did
not stop him at all.
>> Yeah, absolutely. As we're back on
Allen's turn, uh we did have that
watchful sentry that we moved in. We
played a KISSA before, didn't accelerate
it. We just wanted it on the board. We
did just stupify our own unit here and
then recycling for a power cost. Here
we are. Oh, cuz that makes sense. Of
course, we paid the one. We got the
stupify for the draw, but we have to
sigil the storm. Recycle that unit or
that card. Going to use a second stupify
on our watchful sentry. And remember it
does say minimum one. So you're not
actually doing anything to your watchful
sentry. And then of course a pouty porro
coming down as well with a second pouty
por. Drew a ton of cards and played some
more units.
>> Yeah, this is a really similar situation
to game one where Allen is all right.
I've scored both battlefields. What else
is there for me to do? I guess I'll spin
my wheels and play some stupifies and
put some patty poros into play cuz I
mean I can't score faster. I just need
to build up a battlefield for when you
are finally starting to play a
battlefield.
>> Yeah. And like we see again the score
discrepancy really happening here. And
this this is the most awkward turn in my
opinion for the dazzling deck, right?
When you're at six and it just feels
like there's not a lot to do and and
that's exactly what we see happen. We
just end up having to pass turn. Well,
>> there's an interesting decision that
Sink is doing. You can cycle that
treasure trove. You can choose to pay
that power and it'll give you a rune
back and you just draw a card. really
valuing the potential later to turn that
into more cards. I think I see multiple
Dazzling Auroras in Snake's hand,
though, which is kind of a thing you
could expect from not popping that trow.
I don't need to draw more cards. I have
all the cards I need already. Same path
of success that we saw Allan do in game
one. We conquered both those
battlefields. We got the double hold
triggers cuz we weren't contested at
all. Bring them back home, play to
Darius, and pass turn. We literally saw
that exact same turn unfold in game one.
But now we're in a situation, like you
said, Dazzling's not on the table and we
can't play it.
>> I think we do have nine. We could play
Dazzling.
>> And it looks like
>> we have a broken sleeve.
>> Yeah. Oh,
>> are we?
>> No, that's it. He goes, even if I play
the Dazzling, there's not a single card
off the top. I think that can save me in
this situation. There's not a contested
battlefield.
>> Yep. Game's just over. Game's just over.
That arena's greatest. giving that one
extra point. It's the opposite of the
aspirin climb game. Aspirin's climb
giving you that extra turn. Arena's
greatest removing a tearing.
>> Well, that was so fast that I want to
talk about it, but at the same time, I
think there's just a decision being made
here and I'm excited to see as we go
into our game three, of course. But that
was so clearcut on showing the strengths
of the Kaisalis when you don't do
progressive interaction against it,
right? And that is why I think people
still have so much faith in the deck to
go against these dazzling Aurora decks
because when they don't find what they
found like we saw in game one for Snake,
the game is runs away from you.
>> Yeah. I mean, Snake just didn't make a
play on turn two. Played the treasure
trove, did nothing, and Kaiser scored
points. You can't just do nothing unless
you have access to something like that,
like that aspirin's climb or some tools,
something like a fight or flight to
maybe save you that one point on their
turn. And that is part of the reason why
the misfortune deck is not something
that has crushed a tournament yet or
people are playing all of the time
despite being popular cuz it does have
that fail rate. It's one of the decks
that is really strong when it does its
thing. But sometimes you're just going
to have games like that. high variance
gameplay, but we have a game three to
figure out who's going to end up being
the winner of this match because at the
end of the day, because that game was so
fast, I feel like we have so much time
for this third one, right? That's one of
the benefits.
>> Yeah. And I mean, part of being a high
variance deck is you can lose the coin
flip once a match. It's okay. If you
think you're flipping a weighted coin,
well, that means you're in a pretty good
position.
>> Real quick, that Oblap Power is going to
be coming out here with Snake going
first. Um, which again I think I'm going
to learn a lot here on why this decision
was made going across the two things.
But maybe that's a saving grace here for
us because game two was almost a
non-game for us. So this obelisk is
going to help us get around that. And
with the mobilize coming through, we are
on course to get an early Dazzling out
than we want to.
>> Yeah, turn one mobilize putting us up to
four runes going to be at six runes. Can
catalyst of Agon or another mobilize
into that Aurora uh really really early.
Allen, you know, doesn't have a board
yet, but can play this Kai'Sa. That's
not a very fast way of scoring this
game. It's not two two drops.
>> Missing. Yeah, missing two two drops on
the four. I You nailed it. And here
comes the catalyst. It's already all of
a sudden not looking great because I
don't know how we're going to do a
double conquer for Allen next turn
unless it's like Darius plus Cleave
strictly to get a unit onto that
battlefield. And I don't know what else
you do. And of course, we picked Candle
at Sanctum as our battlefield for this
game. We want to start taking advantage
and looking at the top two cards of our
deck to figure out what we need to win
this match. And with the catalyst coming
through, Dazzling's coming down next
turn if we have it.
>> Yeah, Allen's got to be over there
chanting. I said, "No Aurora, no, no
Aurora, no Aurora." That's a bit of a
tongue twister there. You know, it's one
of those things where you also, if you
go in with this Kaiser, are afraid of
even a dead bloom predator. It's not
like the previous game where you were
ahead and you're able to hide your units
at your base. this game you got to start
storing and you're gonna make that dead
bloom predator really good against you.
>> Drawing two cards here off the top
though. One from the leing yord, a
second one from conquering on the
Kai'Sa. And of course we do also have
the candle sanctum to synergize with it
very well.
>> Allan choosing to keep both cards on
top. That is a good sign for his
chances. Means he's got a game plan and
that's part of it.
>> Yeah, here's finally an extra drop.
though we do have the Raven Bloom Raven
Bloon student as we need to get some
more units on the board if we want to
keep up in scoring points in the game.
But here is the big turn if we find out
real fast if Snake has the Dazzling or
at least even has like a dead bloom to
contest this Kaiser right away. There is
a chance that even if we have a Dazzling
Roar on Snake side, Allen could possibly
have some type of gear removal, but this
is going to make sure that's definitely
not true. There is a time warp to take.
A cleaave a stupify two Darius's. That
is uh not a hand that's going to be
beating a dazzling aurora very easily.
>> No, not at all. And there comes the
dazzling immediately following up.
Scouts out not having something like a
thermo beam, which we see a lot of
Kai'Sa decks play in their sideboard.
The fact that means that I'm going to
get a proc of this and unless you start
drawing that thermo beam right now, I'm
going to get away with at least another
activation of this ability. So, here we
go. Off the top. This is a fun game. I
love the dazzling Aurora game.
There it is. Dead Bloom Predator
attempting that we can play two contests
against this Kai'Sa. That I think was
the perfect hit we were looking for
right there.
>> Yeah. I mean game one we saw this Aurora
situation but Allen was at like three or
four points already.
>> This game Allen's at one point only has
four might of units in play and we know
Allen's hand. I think Snake is sitting
there feeling pretty good about
everything. had a really great curve out
with mobilize into catalyst into Aurora
plus sabotage just in case you had a
trick. And uh Allen's going to need to
peel pretty Oh my goodness, Aaron. I
didn't just see that happen. I was just
about to say, you know what? I'm not
going to sell Allen out of this game
quite yet. We saw how masterfully he
tried to solve the puzzle in game one on
playing each of these spells, removing
these units on the board. But um when
your opponent scouts your hand and
doesn't see your answer to dazzling
Aurora, and then you um
draw it, I want to I want to point out a
really important thing. Yeah,
>> Allan knew that was there. He candled
it, saying to him two cards to the top,
drew one with the Kai'Sa, knew to leave
that second, so it couldn't get sabotage
and got to have it to beat this. He
played around the Aurora plus sabotage
here. Really top level stuff, thinking
about all of the angles are what's going
to go on.
>> I wish I was that good at this game, but
that's why they're sitting there and
that's why I'm sitting here. And we did
get a spell off, of course, for the
Raven Blue, but the Dazzling Aurora is
off the board. And now there's a real
question about like, okay, if you're
Allen, I answered one of them. There's
still a world where another one comes
out, right? But
>> yeah, I mean, if there's another, we
have this cleave. We knew about this
from the sabotage. Chose not to take it.
And now we're going to go pressure this
dead predator. If there's not another
Aurora, we know Allen has two Dariuses
and a Thousand Tail Watcher. A bunch of
massive units that would be able to beat
through if we end up seeing Snake just
play big units and not have that engine
that Aurora really applies to the game.
Wow,
that was great. That that turn was
fantastic. The sideboarding in these
thermo beams and playing them and
finding them and putting them where you
need them exactly to avoid cards like
sabotage. Uh I with some crazy intense
highlevel gameplay like you said and the
fact that you know man I do you read a
lot into player posture?
>> There's definitely some of it. I I I'm a
big proponent of if you posture well,
whether they think about it or not, they
will play into your posture. And I think
some of that is natural to them, too.
And uh you know, Snake's posture, I feel
like that means he's got something
pretty good.
>> Yeah. Not out of this game yet at all,
especially because, you know, even at
the end of the day, if it takes a couple
of turns even to find something like a
dazzling um as we are picking them all
up. So 36
>> just the misfortune. I mean that's going
to get to be in there and beat up that
raven bloom student ready a rune but not
the power play we're really looking for
but Allen's candle lit Sanctum really
good for snake here knows exactly what
he's digging for and gives him a strong
opportunity. Yeah, and again because you
were saying you did scout out that
knowledge with the sabotage getting
advantage of here. I what I was trying
to allude to was even if you find the
dazzling next turn because of this being
very different than game one of all
those points not going to Allen earlier
on. You're not out of this game yet. We
can find a dazzling and play it one turn
later after the thermo beam and still
find a way back.
>> Yeah, this has been a a bit of a roller
coaster. Snake having the best possible
start. Allen having the answers to the
best possible start. And now it
definitely is anyone's game. Snake
keeping one of the cards. I got to
imagine that's a dazzling or a big
monster or something he's really excited
to uh just slam down next turn.
>> Yeah, getting out that pack of wonders,
which as we know from game one didn't
really do a whole lot for us there. But
yeah, having the misfortune out, no
units in play, but you know what's
coming as we know. Um it's just a
question on what resource Allen wants to
use right now.
I can see if I'm snake and I have this
pack of wonders. I keep something like
that treasure trove on top so I can
start getting the engine going. Allen's
low on points. Allen's only going to get
like one point a turn here. And maybe
you have enough time to get a card draw
engine really turning and find enough
big stuff to win that way. Even if you
don't get an Aurora. Yeah, we still have
the option that if we don't draw the
dazzling, if we draw a dead bloom, we
can play them. And you're only if you're
only recycling the two runes a turn like
we did with this misfortune on the
accelerate cost. You're still on pace to
play a dazzling when you find it. But if
you also turn through all those units,
is there even the point to play the
dazzling anymore until you run out?
>> Well, it depends how many you're
playing. It looks like we saw three dead
blooms, a soul gorge, and the big volley
bear. So, those are all pretty nice. I
do think one of the situations is
because we have this big volley in our
deck. If we ever do end up drawing that
one, it is really hard to play and that
would be a pretty rough draw. We do know
this is a good draw cuz we put it on top
with that candle lit sanctum
>> and it was a dead bloom or we had it
ready to go to contest against one of
these Dariuses. And there it goes
keeping us still up in some points. And
then once again we'll get this candle
in.
>> Yeah, candlelet doing a lot of work for
Snake. did a ton of work for Allen
earlier letting him find that thermo and
hide it from the sabotage. But Snake is
the one who needs to find stuff now.
Allan we know has another Darius and a
Thousand Tail Watcher which he might use
either of those especially in
combination with the hopeful to take out
this dead bloom predator this turn. So
Snake's kind of on the back foot of like
okay I need another thing and I am
running low on good things.
I feel that way at least um when we look
at these as we put one on the bottom and
leave one on top. So at least one of
them's a good thing passing back for
Allen. And I I'm I'm excited. I'm kind
of actually shaking because I think we
had such this great exchange of Snake
and his deck was playing and firing at
all cylinders and then Allen played
perfectly and found the answer that he
needed when he needed it. And so it
feels like we're almost in a neutral
game state currently.
>> Definitely. I mean, this is this is
really has been a bit of a roller
coaster. And you know, this is the play
I thought was going likely to have from
the thousand tail watcher. Taking out
this dead bloom predator getting that
point putting Allen up to four here.
Putting him into position going to
probably go up to five from this Nox is
hopeful and then really be threatening
like you have two turns. What do you you
kept something on top? Is it an Aurora?
Volibear is maybe not good enough to put
in anymore. or it has to go to your base
and that's a really tough place to be.
>> Yeah, it it was fine when Allen was
generating one point a turn, but this
one is because of the accelerated unit
and now also the backup unit like you
said, this one is posturing two runes or
two points a turn and that very quickly
gets you to that seven point. But
instead, we're going to see the bullet
time, the signature spell for Misfortune
seeing some play, and we're going to
recycle a full seven to kill the
Thousand Tail Watcher and keep our Dead
Bloom alive. I really wonder if Snake
was knowing this was a play that was
going to happen. Cuz if you're aware of
that, then you want to keep something
like a Mobilize on top. I'm curious if
he wasn't sure and we're gonna see a big
monster and it it's kind of he's decided
he won't be able to play it, but that
was a big decision just passing here.
So, it probably wasn't that cheap uh
spell of any kind. And this is now a
really tough situation for Snake.
>> Did successfully clear the board though.
So, again, at least when it comes down
to that point race, we did slow down
Allen and although we lost all of our
runes, literally all of our runes. You
said, I think you said runes are for
losers. Yeah, you know, we have a
fighter flight, so that's something.
Yeah,
>> that's a big deal. We're not letting
Allan get to that four point threshold,
>> which is the important one. That means
we gain we gained a turn by having that
fighter flight.
>> Really valuable cuz we need that time to
regain these runes so we can make
another big play potentially a big unit
plus a bullet time in the same turn
again.
>> Yeah, I mean two consecutive turns of
passing. I mean I half right because of
the fighter flight like you said, but
now we are posturing even more. Second
fighter flight coming through going to
bring this Darius back. But if we find a
way to play two cards, the Darius will
ready itself.
>> Allen also already has two units. Having
a gust here from Snake makes sense.
Otherwise, the fight or flight wouldn't
have really done anything. Still would
have let Allen score twice. So, this
makes that make more sense. But yeah, if
Allen just has two units, we're still
scoring twice.
>> Yeah, the Darius will just be able to
ready itself because the first thing we
did was just swing with the Darius. And
now a thousand tail watcher coming down.
And yeah, not even going to pay the
accelerate cost just as a second card
for the turn. Here comes Darius once
again into the candle lit. No answer for
that one of course going to get the
candle trigger and up to four points and
potentially five with the Noxes
hopefully like you said.
What do we do now?
>> This is one of those games where you're
Snake and you
had everything go right in your plan.
>> Yeah. You had the ramp spells, you had
the Aurora, you had the sabotage, and
now you look at this board and you're
like, "Oh my god, I'm trying to top deck
the dead bloom predators. I can't even
play right now. Allen's going to get to
score and run away." It really feels
like the answers are maybe something
like a bullet time plus a soul gorgger
bringing back a second thing. Yeah,
>> but getting those into the battlefield
here, maybe soul gorgger bring back
misfortune lets you accelerate and move
both and really contest a location.
Yeah, I think we're going to see the
kind of opposite situation. Instead of
moving your stuff back for something
like a dead bloom to be played, we're
just going to split our resources
because we're at seven points. And
there's the fist bump. The game, the
match going to Allen's EQ coming all the
way back from a game one loss, taking
the match in the end on Kai'Sa.
>> Yeah, I mean that was an awesome game
three. So, we we kind of got the whole
spread of the Misfortune experience.
Game one, play a Dazzling Aurora, play a
second Dazzling Aurora, take over the
game board right before Allen's about to
steal the game, right? Just take it all
over, win the game.
>> Yeah.
>> Game two kind of don't do a lot and just
get run over. That happens sometimes.
Game three, do your perfect thing,
but Allan did have the hate card. The
thermo beam hidden from the candle lit
Sanctum, dodging that sabotage. Really
heads up play. was able to capitalize on
having those big units in his hand to
fight through multiple dead blooms even
past the Aurora. Really great stuff.
That's how you become a real champion in
some kind games.
>> And it's also why you pick Kai'Sa,
right? I mean that we saw game two be be
completely nullified because of it go
slightly wrong. And that's the
explosivity of the Kai'Sa deck on
playing well all the way through. And
again, remember with the Obisk power in
play, Allen skipped the potentially play
two two drops play and that didn't
happen. It just ended up being Kaiser
Survivor. We thought it was going to go
bad very quickly with the ramp spell
follow through like you said, but
perfect answers at perfect times
>> go a long way.
>> You know, the misfortune deck does a
really clear plan
>> and sometimes what the Kaisa deck gets
to do. Why Kaisa is so strong is it is
adaptable. Some games you get to be the
aggressor. Some games you're stealing
points. Some days you're the control
deck. You're answering with removal
spells using Darius and Thousand Tail
Watcher to get rid of their units. And
in a matchup like that one, your ability
to play both those roles all in one game
being really aggressive, the next game
being the control, answering the
auroras, beating those monsters in
combat, fighting through two dead bloom
predators like they were nothing. You
know, that's why people love Kai'Sa and
it's really powerful and people want to
be doing more and more of that.
>> Absolutely. And I man, I don't actually
know how we're going to top that match
cuz I had so much fun watching it and
watching both of these players play
incredibly well,
>> but we're going to try and top it. Of
course, we have another one coming up
that we're going to go over. And I'm
very excited to jump into this one as
well because we've got uh Mo or Mo
playing Master Yi going X and one
currently versus Oz Villito on Darius,
which I don't think we've seen all day
at all.
>> Yeah, I mean, I love Darius. I think
he's one of my favorite set one legends.
The legends that give you access to more
resources for free. We have a battle of
those here. Mastery E, free stats and
play. Darius, free energy to play more
cards. Darius typically being like a
baited hook deck trying to cheat out
extra units and acrew value. That's the
type of thing that is pretty strong
against Master E, but also Master E has
some big old monsters in there.
So Matt Darius does a very similar thing
similar than Kai'Sa.
But why do less people play Darius do
you think? Is it because power is so
strong? But I also feel like just extra
resources when other decks don't
necessarily have access to him is just
strong as well. Well, so why do you
think the discrepancy specifically
there?
>> Yeah, I mean I think some of the answers
are the Darius deck tends to be weaker
to big holding decks. You know, you
don't have access to thousand tail
watcher. That is a really powerful mine
card that the Kais decks get to play.
Darius doesn't have that. You have to
break through those more with some raw
might. You have access to things like
hidden blade. But against something like
Master E, that can get defied.
>> So if Master E is able to build that
board and create a big hold at one of
these locations, Darius can struggle
breaking through that once you really
get set up.
>> Absolutely makes sense to me. And so
catching up a little bit, we've got the
hollowed tomb coming through for uh
Miko's battlefield as then the trifarian
war camp coming on the side as on for
Ovalito on Darius and very early turns
of course we played a two drop for
Masteru going first makes sense going
into that hollow tomb on turn two and on
turn one for Ovalito we played that
faithful manufacturer giving us two
units for the price of one.
>> Yeah I mean Darius that's really good at
playing two units when being second. I
think Faithful Manufactur is a fine play
going second, but you're really much
happier to play two of the good two
drops. You know, a daring porro and
something like a pouty porro or uh you
know the legion units that really really
speak to what Darius is doing. A Noxis
hopeful plus any drop. But you got to
take what you can get and we're still
able to score a point here even with the
faithful manufacturer. Yeah, still being
able to keep up. And I think that what's
what we're going to set the pace very
quickly on when both or either of these
players decide to contest the other
battlefield, right? Because that's when
the point discrepancies start to change.
But instead, why not more units? More
units to go around. Second faithful
manufacturer. This is a big commitment
from Osalito here saying, I want this
battlefield.
>> Mhm.
>> I'm behind on points. It's usually tough
to be the person really trying to hold
when you're behind on points because
you're going to lose that race. But four
bodies in the Triferian War Camp, that's
a total of 10 might there already, which
is a big number for the Eck to try and
break through. That's an eight plus a
pump spell, and that's still not enough.
Uh War Camp makes it 11. Any more bodies
in there? Really tight.
>> Yeah, it's really the tale of two decks
then, right? because you like you just
said earlier, Darius struggles into the
decks that want to hold, but we're kind
of trying to do our own little mini set
impersonation that we saw earlier today
of like, well, if I just put a bunch of
might onto somewhere, maybe you can't
get through it, but we've seen that you
can in the in the master y deck.
>> Yeah. I mean, Mo has the ability as the
game goes on to build up that hand of
cards, do some really powerful stuff.
Dead bloom plus on guard plus uh
discipline and and and make a big fight.
Osalito though has his own source of
long game longevity. If he is playing
something like baited hooks in his deck,
that is a level of card acrewing and
power putting into play that it can be
really hard for MSG to keep up with if
you didn't get a strong enough start.
>> Yeah, especially when some of those
units recur other units, right? They
bring things back to continue and push
that advantage while also still
increasing your total might on the
board. But I think the biggest thing
that I love about when I play Darius is
having access to that Darius Trifarian
champion unit whenever you want. And the
fact that your legend then also helps
you play a second card every single
turn. It's just like it's the match made
in heaven.
>> Yeah. I mean, you're seeing that right
here, right? We have this Darius. We're
going to play a second card. It's going
to be a seven. Pit rookie is going to be
a four because of the Wu Blade Master,
but you would need two ong guards to be
able to win that combat. possible, but
if this works really strong for Osalo.
>> Yeah. And here it comes. Yes, we've
completely tapped out. Um, we spent all
of our runes for it. And again, not even
having to use our legend ability at all
for it. But the Kiana back in the back
in the base for Mo. I mean it's it's
going to be very hard to get that on
conquer effect even when you take out
the daring porro here because we have to
then start spending some of those
resources that we typically use on
defensive tricks offensively instead.
>> I mean they are offensive tricks right
you need to get that hold you need to
get that started and K is one of those
units that's really worth it. Oelito
there did attack with a daring porro
alongside the Darius was a little bit
worried about the double ong guard said
I really don't want to get blown out
here. I think I'm far enough ahead that
I'm willing to just put my daring poru
in the garbage just to make sure the
worst possible case doesn't happen.
>> Good play. Smart. It's safe. It's game
one, right? You have to make the safe
play game one typically.
>> Well, I think you can be pretty
confident with the Max G decks are going
to be playing. You've seen Kiana. You've
seen Pit Rookie. You're like, I know
this isn't a dazzling Aurora build.
We're playing a normal game where
they're going to play the big monsters
later. And if you believe that you just
are going to be favored there, you don't
want to take those risks.
>> Buff coming in here though from the pit
rookie I think is going to make this
exchange feel way better instead of, you
know, having to feel like you're using
extra resources. Giving this the buff to
immediately match and then one card
makes the trade easily go into your
favor. Even if there could have
potentially been a trick, but there
wasn't. We're going to easily get this
on conquer. And like you said, one on
guard and still playing a unit that
you're going to play anyway gets full
value.
Yeah, on guard. I I imagine Aso sees the
first on guard and it's like, "Okay,
maybe I made a good play last turn. I
knew you had one. What are the odds you
have of the second?" But I get to feel
some relief that I played around at
least knew I had won. Right.
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. And and that
always feels good, right? When
especially in a game like Riftbound,
it is always thinking about what your
opponent could have. What am I supposed
to do? Playing around for the future
turns. And you're right, it made the
right call.
Maybe. How's Felito coming back? We're
at eight to play with here and then
awkward kind of maybe nine because of
the way that Darius works.
>> Definitely nine. Darius isn't a deck
really playing cards that cost more than
five. So you can play any five drop and
any four drop and that's just how this
is going to go. But moving into the war
camp again a statement. We are blocking
this battlefield. This is mine. And now
Osto kind of gets to do that. Last turn
he took that point lead got into four.
And so if we do a hold battle that Mo
can never break, Oelito is gonna win.
>> Yeah. And we still haven't even again
used any of our resources. We're just
moving units up that we had already
played prior. And again, when you're
delaying the you know, the Kiana just
moved up, we there's going to be a world
where Miko makes that decision to bring
them the Kiana back home. But unless you
find a way to completely clear off this
Trifarian war camp, you're not going to
get another unconquer effect. You're not
giving away a ton of resources right
now.
Wow.
No play there. Pass his turn. Back to
Mo.
>> That is really interesting. The Darius
deck is not really known for having a
lot of actions and reactions in the
opponent's turn. Quite a few cards in
hand for Fleto. Possibly things like
hidden blades available. Not entirely
sure what the plan is here. Getting a
total mic calculation. Ask man, you're
right. I'm trying to think the big I
mean, we're playing out of units, right?
You can you can play you can play grand
strategm defensively.
>> That would be pretty powerful here. If
you think this is the turn Miko's going
to go for a dead bloom predator, then
that grand strategim is going to be a
huge blowout. Or you have a certain
philosophy. Your philosophy being
>> as long as I hold up grand strategim, I
can't lose.
>> If we fight these battlefields one for
one back and forth, I will win this
game.
>> Similar story here maybe with the white
flame, right? going on the the pit
rookie as this is going to be 10 might
11 with the trifarian of course and now
this is going to answer the question he
has froze focus passes focused over do
what do we have
>> this has got to be against strumm or
hidden blade
>> either I think are great right one of
them more expensive than the other and
also one of them can be defied and
there's still that one ready rune but
instead we're going to lose everything
>> well you'll get to keep one recruit but
wow that is a massive deal I am shocked
I'm So curious what Oscelito's hand is.
Maybe there is a grand strategim, but
you just don't want to spend it on the
pit rookie. And we're thinking, okay, I
need these runes. I can play these big
monsters. I see a Draven in his hand,
and he's at five points. That's an eight
might Draven. And I think I did see a
splash that Grand Strategium just wasn't
ready to pull the trigger yet. Thinks he
can get a little bit more from it.
>> That's such it it is it's such an
interesting decision to make there
because when you're going to get I guess
the said the biggest value for the Grand
Strategium right then and there, it
makes sense. But are we ever going to
get that many units back? Well, this is
one way to get those units back onto the
table because we can easily grab our
faithful manufacturers again as we play
and go and get another recruit. So, all
of a sudden, you got all these units
back.
>> Yeah, this grand strategium's back to
being good again. We still have six
runes up. Are you going to go again? You
going to run in with this white flame
protector? Maybe this time it's time to
grand strategim. Take that thing out. Uh
even prepared against, you know, white
flame protector on a white flame
protector isn't enough to break through.
>> Yeah. as we pass things back and we are
once again holding up the six. Yeah,
it's going to be uh very interesting
because yeah, the white flame base eight
going to be able to move in and have
nine might total. But now instead of you
know Miko playing his hand, showing the
white flame, hey, this is what I'm doing
for the turn, we get to keep all of our
runes ready for potential tricks that
might come in reciprocation now when
this white flame moves up.
Yeah, the white flame going in here. It
does look like we're going to play
there's the grand strateg
thing instead of use this to, you know,
your pit rookie was already dying last
turn. Who cares? Uh, now that means Osto
maybe gets to use all their runes every
turn and play some things like this big
old uh Draven hiding out in the hand.
>> Yeah. And the whole point will help us
make the Draven even stronger because
we've successfully played a very
powerful defensive trick as most of
these units if not almost all are going
to stay alive of course. But now yeah I
mean we could still see things like the
tasty faith folk but the grand strategy
does last for the turn. So we are off
limits on this battlefield.
>> Yeah I mean there's a lot of the power
of grand strategy. Not only can you use
it when you need to take their
battlefields it really just says you
will not take my battlefields this turn.
The amount of might it puts out in a
single spell is pretty unparalleled in
the game right now. And it's just what
can Mo do? Well, you just have plus 15
more might in that battlefield this
turn. I guess you get to hold. Yeah, and
remember we had to recycle three of our
order runes to pay for that. It is
actually impossible to do that again on
the next turn, especially with our
channel for the turn being only one more
order rune. But we did end up trading.
We played a tasty faith folk at the
hollowed tomb that we already had
control of and we moved Kiana back. You
know, getting a better unit out there,
keeping Kiana alive a little bit longer
and safer. Yeah, moving the Kiana back.
Interesting choice. It's a little bit
smaller than the tasty fay folk. You
saying that you believe that the one
might from the fa folk won't matter as
much for conquering that battlefield or
you believe you need the six might at
the haunted tomb to protect from some
type of accelerate units. But if you're
expecting things like Draven or Vain,
neither of those really conquer through
I'm sorry, not Draven, Darius or Vain,
the Kiana or the Fay Folk anyway.
>> Yeah. And if we take this turn for Ozelo
to just set up things like the Draven
getting it on the board or something
like of the sort, it it doesn't
necessarily give you the win now, but
continuing to overload the Trifarian war
camp. We're at six points of course
because of that hold that we had
earlier. Draven approaching nine might
now 10 with the battlefield. That all on
its own is enough to trade with one of
Mo's gigantic units.
Yeah, Mo looking for some type of
combination of a big unit, maybe
playing, you know, a dead bloom predator
to the base so that you can get it with
a white flame protector on the next turn
with a couple pump spells and really
causing one huge fight.
likely going to be stronger here, but
at six points, you don't have a lot of
time to set that type of thing up.
>> I I almost for a second thought, Miko,
past turn, but we were just getting a
might calculation on what's going on at
the Trifarian War camp. Of course, we
still have access to my favorite part
about the Y deck is when you decide to
play the honed Yi champion unit because
again, it comes in ready. it it it very
much functions as an extra attacker, but
it does cost a lot to get onto the
board. So, there's not a lot of followup
necessarily for it. Or you just play it
early and set up like you said, we could
just maybe concede the seventh point to
over to Oz Falito and maybe you just
hope there's not a trick to get this
faolk off the board.
>> Well, one of the great things about
master is it does have ganking. Yeah. So
you have the opportunity to move this
faith folk back to your base, play your
master to that battlefield and still be
able to threaten all of your might
moving into the war camp in the same
turn, which I think is what Nico is
going to need to do to break through
this. You assume Osfeldo on the next
turn going to play some more stuff to
this war camp, try and really pile this
on. Um, and so this is a situation of I
really don't want to keep any of my
units locked in this haunted tomb. I
need every bit of power I can have. I
saw Miko had like a dead bloom predator
and ong guard little bit of numbers
there really calculating all the things
going on but you know we have a Draven
that is plus six from the points so
that's a nine one from the war camps a
10 five from the spectrumation two from
each of these recruits that's a clean 19
points in there right now and that's a
hard number to get through
>> but we've seen it before
>> we have seen it before I mean we watched
Master E last round I think just break
through this type of thing and I would
not be shocked if we saw it again.
>> Here it is. The first step. Mastery
Ehone has entered the base and we do
have a few extra runes. We're going to
play a stalwart porro as well. This will
help us do that same game plan of
posturing all of our might the next
turn, even including giving a buff to
this master yi. Going to be spending
almost all of our runes. Only one left.
Still able to use something like an ong
guard or a defy if we need. So, but
instead of that, it's just going to be
holding it back and keeping the tasty
faith hook there. choosing to leave the
faith hook there. They the master E is
larger. It's better at defending through
Darius or uh you know accelerated demons
and I think missing out on that six.
Maybe Miko's done the math and knows
there's enough but it feels to me like
this could come back to bite them. We'll
find out very quickly as a Darius
Trifarian hits the board once again for
five and we have three and also we have
four basically to essentially go and
figure out what we're going to do with
it.
>> A cleave here would be really good. Puts
you up to 10. That's what we have here.
The Folk's only an eight. If we have an
Ong Guard, that's a trade. Or if we have
a Defy, maybe we have to do that to this
Cleave so we don't just get killed by
the Darius.
>> Looks like you're right. Here comes
Defy. It does still count as playing the
card though. So, we will still get the
plus two in the ready.
>> Yeah, this is way better for you than
getting to use the ong guard because you
really need to save that on guard for
this next big combat.
>> No, it doesn't count as played. Played
is when cards are finished resolving,
but it's not that hard for Darius to
play another thing here. Ready it now.
>> Yeah, as we load up once again. And the
Legion still is live, of course, so he's
going to get a buff when it comes in.
>> But now we only have one energy left. If
we had another cleave, it'd be good
enough, but we can't run into this FA
folk.
>> So, just move it up to reinforce, I
suppose. I guess is the once again
presenting just more might. And that
seems to be the play because the five
was good enough to stop that cleave
through like you said.
>> Yeah, this is the only thing we can do.
Make this big pile. If Mo can't break
through this, it's going to be it's
really close. I think there's a dead
balloon predator that gets to do nine
damage, which gets to cut through a
couple of the things, but not all of
them. And then you have to hope the rest
of your board can make it. The Draven
got another point. Now it's an 11.
Massive.
>> This is it. This is it. We've all We've
led to this moment on figuring out how
to answer the puzzle. Is the Tasty Faith
Folk not bringing it back and leaving up
the ganking unit instead? What was the
correct decision? And we're going to
find out right here as we are
calculating all the might across the
board. I'll leave it to the players of
course. Don't know. There's two
recruits.
We have two recruits. This Legion uh
unit that has the buff on it. So that's
a four. Both recruits are twos. That's
eight. Darius is an 11. That's a 19.
Matrons five more. 24 30 exactly with
the Darius. That's good for easy math
for Mo's side. Nice round numbers.
>> It is. Yeah. I did it alongside you, but
I was not as quick. I'm glad you said it
out loud for me. But yeah, so 30 we have
to get through. White Flames of course
help us do that, but it does cost eight
of our 12 runes that we have to do. So,
>> so on this board we have the Kiana.
That's a five plus one cuz war camp. So
everything's going to be plus one in
this fight. So we have a six.
>> Mastery is a seven plus one eight 14.
Three from the Porro 17. Three from the
pit rookie 20.
>> So we need 10.
>> We need 10 more.
>> 11 to beat it.
>> 11 to beat it. So we're making this type
of play. We have the dead bloom predator
in our hand. That's nine. a single plus
two if the numbers work out here. The
main thing is does this fight allow you
to kill exactly the things you want? We
think this is 20 so you can kill
everything but the Draven.
>> Draven is at 11. So
yeah,
right. 3 plus 7 plus the one from
Trifarion.
Yeah, it looks like that might be the
case, but Draven is the one we need to
kill, right? because but the more units
that are also at the battlefield means
there's more might coming from
Trifarian. So it it really it really is
kind of boiling down to where this
damage assignment and this is up to the
players like the these are choices you
actively make in the game and you must
feel like you have to make the correct
choices.
>> Yeah, we chose to kill the D and we left
the spectrum and the two recruits that
leaves nine might of the battlefield.
That's a better spread, which means a
dead bloom predator
>> ties.
>> Ties a single on guard, which I see in
Nico's hand is going to be enough here.
>> Yeah,
>> look at that movement. That is someone
who knows they've won the game.
>> Yeah, that is a game-winning. Slam it on
the table. Show our opponent. But like
you said, cuz this is eight runes. We
still have four to play with, which
means all of these tricks that this deck
does play to get things around. It's
easily showing a game one going over for
Mo on Master Yi. And it ended up in the
same result that we kind of saw earlier
today.
>> We keep seeing this play out in the same
way master decks against set against
Darius
>> hold fights. Yeah,
>> Master E gets one, opponent gets one.
Opponent plays a bunch of stuff to the
one battlefield. They think they can
steal ahead and get one point and win
the hold race. But the Master E deck
does just have so large of units and
combat tricks. They get to make a big
fight happen at the end at their terms.
So Aaron, help me help me understand
then what do I need to do as a set
player and what does Osalito need to do
in a diff in game two to change that
story that we've seen happen so many
times now.
>> So one of the things that happened in
that game Oelito went second was not
able to conquer both the battlefields
early played a faithful manufacturer
instead of two of the stronger units let
that pit rookie get in lost the game by
that point. Similarly, didn't have any
spells other than that grand strategium.
Maybe could have saved that a little
longer. Would have lost the battlefield.
That's a tough call to make. Something
may be thinking about again, but also
bring in more stuff like hidden blades,
more of that removal, answers to these
big things. That's what you need to do
because you'll always boil down to the
same big fight if you don't win the
really aggressive games. You have two
lines of choice. Am I going to try and
really quickly blitz them down? never
let you take control of the
battlefields, never get a lot of value
out of that Wuju Blademaster legend, or
am I setting up to be bit of the control
deck, play that hold game, and have the
removal spell at the perfect time.
Either path works.
>> Yeah,
>> if you have the right cards,
splitting battles, losing one fight, and
trying to do both is the type of thing
that may end you up in trouble.
>> I don't know what their credit is. I'm
glad you know and I'm glad the insight
here because I I'm watching these and I
go I'm going to go home and I'm not
going to I'm not going to be able to do
it right. And with all the Master Y that
we're showcasing so far making a good
stretch to potentially end up in our day
two on our top 64 because we've seen two
excellent Master Y deck so far and this
match isn't even over. We have more to
see of course but it makes me want to go
home and figure out what I'm going to do
because I feel like more people might be
playing E after this event as well.
>> Yeah, there's I mean there are a lot of
options you can do. One more thing, did
not see a beta hook that game. I don't
know if that means there are none in the
Darius deck or we just didn't happen to
find it. We did see Spectral Matron.
That's a unit that almost certainly says
we're going to be playing Beta Hook.
It's such a powerful hit off of that.
>> So, that's another card, a factor that
we didn't see in the first game that we
might get to see out of OSTO this game.
>> Well, speaking of the next game, we've
got game two coming up right here for
y'all. So, don't go anywhere. I'm
really, again, I'm all about just mass
amounts of gameplay. I love this game so
much. So I want to see more and more of
it. So I want to see Ovalito take us to
a game three when he's going first and
we've got Arena's greatest speed up that
game by one more point that you were
talking about. That's a pass to victory
and then Vioma layer coming out on the
side for Mo which I mean if we see the
same game plan that Oilito went for in
game one. Vi maybe not really going to
do anything.
>> Yeah, I mean we we had a similar
situation with a Victor player earlier
today where yeah I have a bunch of
random recruits. I don't need them to
sit in the viol. I don't care. You can
kill them. Uh definitely looks like the
type of game where Oswgg
didn't play a card on the first turn. No
two drop has hidden blade in hand
though. Looks like maybe leaning into
more of that little bit of a controlling
game.
>> But on the other side we went or going
second for Miko. We did play a unit.
We're going to be able to get the first
point actually the second point because
of Arena's greatest and that's huge at
least when you're going second and a
master y deck.
>> This is really painful for us. though
played a three drop on turn two as
Darius didn't play a two on turn one and
didn't get to use the Darius or the
ready order rune wasted four energy by
turn two in a matchup where you getting
those early points and not letting your
opponent hold the battlefield is pretty
important
>> and then it makes these find your
centers feel even more devastating
because your opponent already started
the game with the extra room because of
the game of course getting a second one
and still replacing itself. So all of a
sudden it feels like the energy spent
discrepancy is only going to grow.
>> Of does have an opportunity here. No
units in the base for Mo. Dead Bloom
Predator looks geared up to come in or a
tasty faith folk, but Oto could go ahead
and play this Darius and maybe play a a
cheap thing and get into this
battlefield with the Porro and kick Mo
out. But you got to be assuming you
didn't do you just found your center.
You probably got a big play coming up.
six essentially to play with because of
our legend. Um it helps you know even
when you go first or I'm sorry six on
the board plus our we have seven to play
with which means it makes these Darius
plays and not necessarily needing cleave
but can be followed up by like a Nox's
hopeful feel a little bit better in this
legend of course and then still get
access to the Darius just like you said
and I'm wondering if that might be the
play here. My my interesting too because
I do like this interaction and I want to
ask you about it is when it comes
because we saw the hidden blade when it
comes to hiding cards versus the legion
interaction, right? Because hiding them
is not playing the card,
>> right?
>> So it doesn't count as playing something
first, but when you do flip it over and
you use it at reaction speed, it is
playing the card,
>> right? I think that mostly matters on
the opponent's turns for Darius. Helps
you play those two spells when you're
needing to defend. That's one of those
things that when you get into that big
fight at the end of the game, you can
actually kind of trick the Darius into
being plus two.
>> Talking about Knox is hopeful here. It's
I would really doubt Oslo has it. If he
did, he would have played it last turn.
He had that two energy and played a
thing which is maybe even making, you
know, maybe has a great five drop this
turn, but even if you do that, you're
burning those two runes again. I see a
Draven in hand there. Maybe not a
followup. Not really strong. You only
have two points. Maybe you play Darius,
but you don't have another spell. You're
really trying to scrap through the next
couple turns. If you can't play two
cards this turn, how do you make sure
you're playing two cards every other
turn because you're going to need it.
This is a good one. Uh, one of the
advantages of Darius the legend is that
uh he has the fury domain and falling
stars we know is a very popular card and
very powerful against, you know, Master
Yi who only gets that bonus power when
you're in combat like you said. And so
great removal, but it is pretty
expensive for this deck,
>> right? Falling start a single stalwart
porro. Yeah,
>> that can't be why we have falling star
in our deck. We were hoping for way
better, but it looks like we had a
vanguard captain. We needed to trigger
Legion. And also, we took both these
battlefields. We're trying to get these
points. We're trying to make these
plays. And I can believe Oelito is just
like, I'm willing to go up the runes
now. I need to get stuff going cuz I
certainly haven't gotten anything going
yet.
I obviously don't know the rune layout
and uh for this deck, but now I just
think we're in a scary position because
if we don't channel another fury rune,
we can't play Darius if we want to.
>> Yeah, that's scary.
>> That is scary. You only need one. There
is this master E that you knew was
probably going to come in. Makes Darius
have a lot more work. You really be
happy to do that. I imagine we're
playing quite a few order rooms because
we're playing Grand Strategy.
>> Yeah. Yeah, and even when I see the
Vanguard captain, right, when for these
units that require these tower costs, we
did get at least the one. So, I'm not
really worried anymore. But it was just
a scary thought for a moment that I at
least wanted to bring up. But now the
master e-hone, of course, it moves in
immediately on the vile mas layer. And
it's not necessarily stuck there because
vile mausair still lets you use ganking,
just can't bring it home to base. But we
have to deal with this eight might in
total basically to deal with, but still
one ready rune on the other side.
>> Yeah. So, that can be an ong guard. That
can be a defy. I think we have a cleave
and we're going to Darius and try and
cleave. If this doesn't get defied, I
think we have a really good combat here
for Oz Fleto. If it does get defied,
Miko's going to get to keep this vile
M's layer. But that Master Yi is trapped
there. Once again, it feels like we're
watching a game where the Vile Maul's
Lair has been worse for the Master Yi
player than for the opponent. Had that
happen in a match earlier today with a
Kiana getting stuck.
>> The cleave does resolve. So we have this
massive 10 might Darius as long as that
was the chosen target which I imagine it
was. And so now it being able to trade
at least with this master even if it
isn't on guard because it obviously
wasn't the defy if that was the play.
>> Yeah. So even if you have the on guard
here it's not that bad. You send in a
recruit you get the point. And once
again Mikos without a board
>> and the point adding up for Ozalito. And
this is the path to victory again.
Remember not necessarily loading it all
up on one. Instead, it is about
spreading it out, getting his point many
points as possible. And of course, the
arena's greatest helped us get there.
This might be that game of margins that
we thought it was going to be in game
one, but that one extra point being the
reason why Osfield could take this game
to victory.
>> This is going to be a big turn for me.
Really important to have one of those
big haste units. I think I see a dead
bloom predator there. really important
to have that because you can't just
leave the Darius there or leave these
battlefields cuz once Oelito is able to
get to that seven the next turn. That
would be a really tough place to come
back from.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And so I think the
decision that Miko is going to make and
we're going to find out very quickly is
is that what we're going to do with our
turn cuz that's essentially all we're
going to do with our turn. But it's a
very powerful play and it's why Dead
Bloom is in almost all of these body
decks that we see.
>> If you're Oz Felo, you also know you
know Dead Bloom prior cost eight. We're
only going to leave up one rune from Mo
and last turn didn't have it to fire and
on guard. What are the odds there's one
this turn
>> or held it very patiently?
>> Kiana coming down though instead. Pit
rookie going to send it a buff as well.
This of course is not using the dead
bloom turn. But we are going to be able
to keep some of these runes up unless we
play more cards. But just reestablishing
a board state to figure out what we're
going to do with it. Three more to play
with. It might just be used for defense,
but there's nothing to defend.
>> A first mate here would be pretty
decent. And it would at least allow you
to trade the Kiana for the Darius. That
doesn't stop you from scoring. So maybe
you would just move Kiana to the other
battlefield.
>> Clockwork keeper coming in for two. And
it looks like no additional cost paid
here. Don't want to draw a card. We just
want units.
>> This is a really interesting decision
cuz I I really confident I see this
deadl Predator in Mo's hand. Did not
want to put that in the battlefield
despite having the two might runes to
play it. Saying, "Hey, I need bodies in
play this turn. So next turn I can
really respond to whatever you do. Of I
expect just to run a little recruit in
and back up and build up that base.
Can't run away. That's a vile mall
there.
>> True. Hey, we figured it out. Oh, right.
Can't do that. So, it is stuck there.
And that means a lot, right? Because
that is the highest might unit that
Ovalito basically plays right here. And
it also has the ability to gain even
more might. And I think that means we
are going to have to go for this. not
just going up to seven points here for
Osalito, but we can't I don't think we
can do the load up one battlefield
again. I think we have to figure out how
we're going to distribute this, get
resources out of Mo, and then do a
double conquer play.
>> Yeah. Well, we know Oscel has grand
strategists.
So, if Oo has one of those in the hand,
obviously has the order runes, has quite
a few bodies in play, gets to deploy
more this turn. pretty big Draven there.
Grand Strategia might be a card Nico
can't beat unless boarding in something
like Wind Wall, but I'm not sure that's
a card you can reasonably board in
against a deck like Darius. Do if you
that's how you play Windwall on the
board. Do you bring it in if the only
real spell that you're trying to use
without defy because it doesn't work? Is
Grand Strategy? Is that one worth the
windwall?
>> I can believe it's something you're
maybe interested in when you're on the
play, but when you're going second, you
get that extra rune, you're under the
gun really quick. If your opening hand
has this wind wall, you won't be able to
play it for a long time. It costs too
power to play. You really just need to
play your things. And it's really hard
to both play a large unit and hold up
the wind wall in the same turn when
you're already having the forced
maneuvers of being playing those into
these battlefields. I could see having
some in the third game if we get there.
>> That sounds perfectly reasonable to me.
Kiana's going to come in here. I like
the idea. obviously send this in, get
rid of this recruit, and we have the on
conquer effect that I'm going to assume
is draw a card. We need to figure out
what our answers is because our opponent
is at seven. Now is when we need to
figure out what does the game look like
in this current stand.
>> Yeah. So, if we do dead bloom prior to
this Darius, there's a lot of might at
that base. We don't have a lot of runes
left. Even with some tricks, I'm not
sure this is enough on the board.
>> Yeah, not if it's a grand strategy like
you said. And so this could be the this
was a path to success for Osalito if
that ends up being the case. But I'm not
going to sell it out yet. Keeping the
two up, discipline is enough for maybe
something. But when I'm staring at that
Draven on the other side at its most
might it can have at least in 1 v one.
That's a lot to mess with.
>> Yeah, you have a really great option
here as Felita. You you're in the spot
of okay, I can try and win both or even
if I can't win both. Well, this one
definitely wins both. Uh you don't have
to think about all the fancy things. But
what I was saying is you were going to
be able to choose to fight the Kiana
with the Draven and then just pile in
one and force the beat to the hold or
you can just win the game.
>> And that was exactly it. I'm so glad we
got to it. Osalito pulling it out for
game two. The grand strategm double
conquer was available if we needed it.
But at the end of the day, we played our
resources a little bit better. We didn't
load everything up to one battlefield.
And I really think that was the key
here.
>> I really want to go back to the early
turns of that game. Of did not make a
play on turn one. Yeah,
>> turn two play with four runes and the
Darius was a faithful manufactur wasting
two more energy in the first two turns
wasted four energy. A lot of games
that's like a death sentence.
>> Yeah, when you're playing Darius, you're
really aggressive. really want to get
these things out, but able to find the
path that game to beat up on Mo kind of
not really playing to the board super
quickly, not having a Kiana early, not
having the resources to play all of
those cards in hand. I saw Mo lose with
a bunch of white flame protectors still
in the wings, never got a chance to be
deployed.
>> I mean, that means we've got a real
series here, right? We've got a real
match where game three is going to
decide all of it. And we've seen a path
for Osalito to win. It's going to still
be difficult.
>> Yep.
>> We're going to see Mo be able to go
first. We're on our third battlefield.
The Vile Moss could have just been a
throwaway battlefield for Mo. And we're
really going to see a lot more of this
potential of this deck come through. We
know that the Y deck can do it. It is, I
think, entirely dependent on how the
Darius deck approaches the game, what
the trick is in game three perhaps, or
do we maybe follow the same path this
game even with a bad curve like you said
that we did and we waste or not wasted,
that's the wrong way to say it, but like
we didn't necessarily use all of our
energy efficiently,
>> right? Instead of being able to play
those cheap cards, you had really
powerful cards in your hand. Yeah.
>> You had grand strategim, you had Draven,
you had all these things that ended up
being
>> more important and you were able to
capitalize that.
>> Absolutely. Well, game three is on our
way and I'm diving in ready to go for
it. I hope you all are at home and I'm
excited to see these battlefields once
again and see how this game is going to
shift for this final bout here in round
six. We've got the Grove of the God
Willow, which is going to be a very
contested battlefield this game, I can
imagine. And a Z Warren for the Darius
deck. Going to be able to hopefully find
some more of those powerful cards when
we do need them.
>> Yeah, I mean if your plan is about
things like Grand Strategm, Zon Warren
really good at helping you find them.
Darius normally not too good at drawing
cards.
>> Yeah, definitely not. So, but if it can,
Man, it's I was just about to say if we
load up a bunch of units to the God
Willow and we hold it forever, we maybe
find a path, but we know that's how we
lost game one. So, maybe that's Mo kind
of laying the trap. Mo wants the scilla.
Maybe this clockwork keeper, buffing it
with the pick rookie, having two energy
up to play a pump spell of some kind.
It'd be really hard for Oswita to take
that battlefield here in a reasonable
way. Does have six energy because of
Darius. Could play a Draven. Could play
a cleave. That's a really good way to
break through.
>> That means Mo must have the Defy
basically to answer it.
>> I think I see the cleave right there in
Oita's hand. A lot to think about here.
>> Yeah, I mean that that to me very much
sums up to what did these players hold
for their mulligans? Because if you make
a play like this and you proceed the
game in this current capacity, what is
the decision that you made during the
mulligan phase? Did Mo just hold the
hold the defy? Did Ovalito go, hey, this
is what my deck is really good at doing
when going on the second turn going
second because we have exactly this to
this powerful 10 might swing play
>> gets the rookie in. A simple choice to
kind of do early. You get a lot of
information here. Pitching a spectral
matron really sets you up to like now I
know what's going on. I have as much
information as possible now. Do I want
to do this Darius? Do I want to do this
cleave?
No. Setting up.
>> Yeah. Not going to fall for the I think
I get blown out by a defy not being able
to take over. We're going to give away
one hold of course for this God Willow
which means we're going to get the draw
away as well. And of course on the play
here for Miko, we are up on the points
and you're just trying to play a little
bit of catchup for Ovalito. And that
recruit is going to easily die here even
from this pit rookie. So Mo easily going
to three points I think this turn.
>> Mo in a situation where you know you
have this clockwork keeper and you are
defending that battlefield pretty well
even against the stuff in play. it is
how much do the points matter to you
versus playing the long game and really
blocking off these locations in in
getting this find your center putting up
to seven means in the following turn you
can play a big eight with an on guard or
with a defy and that's really important
>> and that's I think we've seen Mo do for
the bread and butter and obviously what
the educk does in general right you
don't have to keep up too much because
you know things like on guard don't cost
a lot and even discipline for only two
but we saw two different turns right we
saw one turn from Ofelito I need to
build up more units not just commit to
this full all-in Darius decision. But on
the other side from Miko, I'm going to
play a little bit more setup
specifically in the rune advantage and
hand drawing less on the units in play.
>> Looks like a little conversation maybe
about missed Zod Warren's triggers, but
that's a thing you can miss if you
forget about it. No harm, no foul.
>> I think sometimes I like the cards in my
hand and I don't want to use it.
>> Okay. Well, if you do that, we would
like you to be out of the tournament.
Please. Oh, that's fair. Yeah, you're
right. All right. So, yeah, we're going
to have to figure out what's going on
and give them some more time to figure
that out. But we still got Is this
currently the correct trajectory for
Osalito to maybe potentially win this
game three or do you think it is going
to purely come down to
these players playing around each other
like perfectly? Cuz like if we held on
to the grad strategy, we are setting
ourselves up. We need all these units to
really get full value out of it. And
currently on the state of Miko, as we
are in the setup phase still of this
game, when do the big units hit the
board and which ones are going to be the
reason Miko wins versus Osalito taking
over? I mean, Mo is up by two points
here. I think there's a lot of important
value in can Ofalito
take both of those away this turn, get
up to three. Not the magic number. You
really want those even numbers. So, you
definitely need to take one of them. You
have a pretty good battlefield. You have
nine might of your own. You can
definitely force your way in somewhere.
And if you're doing that, it seems like
Oscalito's plan, probably similar to
game two, get ahead, set up, and uh have
a grand strategm and be ready to conquer
and take those last two things.
>> We did end up getting the Zan Warren
prog. We ended up pitching a first mate
from our hand. So, Miko is going to end
up drawing a card. They rolled a dieice
for it. Don't know what that means, but
um ends up and that's going to be the
turn for Miko as we pass back to
Ospalito.
It's very interesting because a first
mate might have been a card Miko really
wanted to play there. Three runes left
over some units at battlefields that you
maybe wanted to back out. Not entirely
sure. I could see a world where you
first mate into the zon and then take
the pit rookie out to just have a
slightly larger body there.
>> Yeah, I think that's a Yeah, I think
that's 100% I think even how the Yi deck
plays in general, right? You start with
the little guys, eventually they'll come
home or they'll won't survive and
they're going to be replaced by the big
ones.
Knox is hopeful though being able to
come in here
>> and here's the discipline to get it over
the amount of might we need it for it to
survive with the discipline in hand the
odds of wanting to play that first mate
definitely much lower way better to
protect through this getting you know
Noxus hopeful for a discipline really
big on this board that was the best
thing that Osp had going face up other
than this Darius uh maybe that gets
played here and has to jam
Yeah, and we have to find a way to, you
know, obviously play a second card. And
of course, we know that we still have
that cleave that we spotted earlier. But
if the defy comes through, unless you
have a backup cleave, what there what
else are we going to do with the turn?
>> This is definitely the type of situation
where if you're afraid of something like
a defy, you can just play a unit like
the staring puo. Can't stop that when
the Darius gets to ready, gets to go
into combat. If you have the cleave, you
still have your Darius available to you
to play it whenever you need. Yeah, even
respecting the leftover might that the
discipline still gives the pit rookie
for the turn. Um, it was at seven, but
instead now we have an on guard coming
from the other rune being paid here for
Mo, but then there's a rebuttal. Now
that Mo has tapped out, we have the
ability to give assault three to the
Darius with the cleave we already had.
>> Yeah, that's a really big turn. Now you
have this Darius this battlefield.
You're putting pressure back on Mo.
If there's not one of those big haste
units, which we've talked about a bunch
of times, big accelerate bodies, things
that go in there, could be a lot of
problems, and you get to hold this grove
of the godwillow. A lot of pressure if
Mo, I expect, will feel forced to play
one of those in here.
>> Yeah, and it's still in that sweet spot
where Mo likes to sit, right, where it's
still keep the one up. And we've had it
every game, almost every turn, as much
as we try to. There's the dead bloom
coming down. And goodbye, Darius. So, no
hold trigger going to happen here. And
now it's on the other side of the
question where Oscelito has to deny that
on the other side now having to deal
with an eight might unit 10 when in
combat.
>> Yeah, I mean we did use an ong guard
last turn.
>> Yep.
>> Our odds of having something really good
to use with the one or tighter but we
are hiding a card which I'm going to
assume is a Za's hourglass. This most
common hidden card from these uh mastery
E decks. And I assume Of Felito is going
to know that's what it is.
>> Yeah. And so then I think the game plan
that Osto needs to unlock is well how do
I kill this pit rookie first?
Well, you can't force Miko to flip the
hourglass, right? So that's why it's
hidden at the dead bloom predator zone,
but you know, go in, do some fighting,
do some scoring over here.
>> Mo does have a lot of points on Ocelita.
>> Yeah, a lot.
>> Can't just leave the dead bloom predator
hourglass sitting there. You're going to
have to kick it out at least once. You
can try and win that points race, but
then it's just going to be coming back
in. So, you need a backup plan for that.
If you have a hidden blade once, that's
good. you're going to need a second.
>> Yeah, I that's where I immediately went,
right, was like, okay, well, what can we
do for like removal? I I also wonder,
and I know we haven't seen it all game,
and I know most Darius don't play it,
but like this is like a prime
opportunity where it's like, man, I
really want like a cold of the week.
>> I think we're going to see the namesake
card here.
>> Ooh, there it is.
>> Old baited hooks. We had it hasn't shown
up in any of the other games, and this
is a game where we have the seal, but
our board isn't the most impressive.
We're only going to get a three might
off of this and that's not the biggest
hits unless you hit a Draven.
>> Yeah, Draven of course has that three
base might and then is going to get the
extra might based off of how many points
we have. So, we're going to find out
real quick. And it looks like we did get
it.
>> Thing pretty hard. The only other card I
would consider possibly taking here is
like a Vanguard Captain giving you two
more bodies and being something you can
hook away itself cuz once you get this
Draven in play, you really don't want to
hook it. And if you're out of units,
your hook might be sitting there a
little while.
>> Yeah, if this recruit ends up dying in
any capacity, we are out of units as we
play them from hand and then immediately
get rid of them using the beta hook or,
you know, we've got a pouty porro, so we
have another backup unit to get rid of.
>> Oelo empty-handed though. No tricks the
grand strategm currently. No hidden
blade. That dead bloom predator looking
tough to get through. Draven plus the
porro is only eight. That's a not enough
to get through the 10. definitely gonna
need some pretty good hook hits or a
nice top deck into some uh strategy.
>> I've never felt so vulnerable in
Riftbound when my hand is empty. And
obviously that's any card game, but like
>> Riftbound is a game that is a lot about
bluffing. You and your opponent both are
taking these battlefields back and forth
and you really want to posture in such a
way where they are afraid to try and
catch up on that difference of serve
that you've created by getting ahead.
Oh, that is uh that is a tough thing for
Oz FTO there. That charm.
>> Yeah, I was going to say if there was
any way for Oz FTO to stay into this
game, it was fighting and keeping that
Draven alive for offensive pressure, but
getting Charmed up, functioning
essentially as a removal spell. That is
going to be the match going to Mo on
Master Yi.
>> Master Yi doing it again. Powerful
cards, big monsters, combat tricks. It's
not fancy, but it sure does work.
>> But I'm glad we still got to look at
Darius. So, with that being said, that
was a very long round. And with that as
well, Aaron, I'm officially done with
you today. Um, I'm going to be on for
one more, but I had so much fun with you
today. And this was a blast watching all
of this highintensity riftbound gameplay
and I'm excited to work with you
tomorrow as well.
>> Yeah, awesome games. I really loved
watching all the e games. Those are
really cool. a lot of games where really
creating these big epic moments holding
battling points back and forth creating
something really surprising whether it's
a grand strategim or a big turn with
dead bloom predators and a lot of pump
spells fighting into a battlefield worth
30 points. I mean you don't always get
games like that. Those are super sick
and I'm excited to see more of those
through the rest of the weekend.
>> Absolutely. So don't go anywhere. We are
going to show and look at some cool
interviews that we took so far this
weekend. So don't go anywhere. We'll be
back with round seven.
All right, I'm on the floor with Crim.
Crim, I you've always had a great
infectious energy, so I'm excited to get
a chance to talk to you. How has the
event been for you so far?
>> Uh, well, it's it was I was so excited
to be in this event and just compete
again, you know, like get real sweaty
again that I actually slept for an hour.
>> Um, I was I was like pacing back and
forth in my hotel room and so far I've
just hit the floor and it's been a lot
of fun, right? Like this is a wonderful
first event. I I think the coolest thing
that I've seen here is seeing so many
like competitive players from other
other scenes coming here playing and all
for the the the best of rewards. The
best of card, the metallic card from
that is so sweet. It's such a cool
incentive that I hadn't seen done before
in like another another card game. And I
just really like that personally. And it
it kind of gives everyone incentive to
pull the off meta decks. I I think
Frodan's on like uh uh Leon, right? And
then and then I'm seeing like Jim Davis
on Jinx and all of that. So like this is
just really cool to see everyone from
other spaces come together and like just
trying to brew, just try to cook. And
it's been a blast to watch and just
compete in this event. And uh Oh yeah.
Also, you should always read your
opponent's cards so you don't ever
>> No, that makes sense. Well, so you
mentioned the best ofs. We do we still
have an undefeated Bully Bear as we're
talking right now, which is insanity.
I'm I'm curious. You're talking about
the bests. How cool it is. What deck did
you play? Uh, I brought I brought set. I
brought set for this one.
>> Kaisa and I was gonna get I was gonna do
a whole bit. No, we're okay. We're we're
cool. We're in the clear.
>> I just wanted to get buff. I you know
I'm missing I'm missing a gym day by
being in Houston. So I had to get buffed
through other means and that's why I
brought set. And I also kind of hedged
my deck today to beat Kai'Sa. But
unfortunately I am not doing too hot
against Yi. So Ye is kind of good. Uh
but other than that it's just been a
blast to play anyways. to finally sit
across and just like a hall with a bunch
of people just to play.
>> All right. Well, thank you so much for
taking the time to talk with me, Crim.
We're going to send it back to the desk
and have even more ripbound action
coming your way.
All right, I'm here with Togg. You know,
we had that unfortunate match on
feature. Couldn't quite get there in the
end, but we're a couple rounds deeper.
How's the tournament been going
afterwards?
>> Oh, the rest of it's going splendid.
Alma wins. So far 2. So I got really
good breakers even if I X2 after that
loss. I think I'm still making top cuts.
So pretty happy. Oh, that feature match.
You didn't have to remind me of that,
buddy. No, no, I did actually. I have.
Do you want me to go deeper into the
future match or not?
>> Good mental for next round. Good mental.
>> All right. Okay. But instead, you came
all the way here from Australia to
compete for this qualifier. How has it
been? Are you still jetlagged at all or
are all good?
>> You know what? Maybe I should talk about
the feature match instead cuz that's
Yeah. Uh my flight was 30 hours. I
almost missed my plane on my layover. I
was begging like the people at that gate
like please let me in. I had to run
there. My glasses broke. I have tape on
my glasses.
>> They they broke and so like my bag broke
as well. I'm sweating on the plane like
and then ah at least it's all gone. I'm
here. I get to play some refound instead
though.
>> All right. Well, thank you so much
Chong. Good luck in the rest of the
event. We'll send it back to you.
[Music]
What about people?
Welcome back everybody. I'm Bear Bryant
and joined for the first time this
weekend with Patrick Sullivan. Patrick,
it's so good to see you. Welcome to the
desk.
>> Really excited to be here. Uh, I'll be
calling the next three rounds today to
to round out the day. Uh, been here all
weekend watching matches, talking to
players and judges. An incredible event
so far. We're kind of getting down the
line here where we're going to see
people playing for their opportunity to
make the second day and get to that
single elimination portion. So, I'm very
excited for the rounds we have coming
up. I mean, there's not much else to say
cuz we've got some exciting
highintensity rounds coming up with
that. Round seven is coming in right
now. I want to go ahead and dive into
these things because we have so much
action and so many players that are
really competing for these last spots
and for the first time this weekend. Le
versus Kaisa. Leon has not been seen at
all, but Xen one is still in the
running. Well, I I think something that
we're seeing over the course of this
tournament, we have a couple of
champions like Le where if you just look
at the total number of people playing,
we're looking at 1 2 3% of the metag
game. But these champions that maybe you
don't see as much play, there is still
room for people to master them and you
do have an advantage. You know, there's
probably some 50th percentile players in
the room who have not played a match
against this archetype coming into the
tournament and so that surprise factor
is worth a lot too.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Not not much to be
said here at least in the beginning
turns, but the Kaisa dreaming tree for
game one pretty standard what we see a
lot right now for these decks. But you
talk about the archetype and the buff
kind of synergies. Monastery of Herana
makes a lot of sense when you can get
some extra cards in your hand and
instead of a unit coming down on the
first turn instead we got a zonia's
hourglass.
>> Yeah, just sets up shop here a little
bit. You know the the Kais deck's pretty
good at getting out to an early
advantage there and winning in combat
favorable exchanges with cards like
cleave. It isn't the worst strategy to
try to set up shop a little bit and
create some dominating units on your
turn that it can then attack to avoid
the effect of assault oriented pump
spells. Do you think it's also pretty
telling here that we went to the
monastery first to hopefully try and
deny that ability to take over that
battlefield instead of our own dreaming
tree? Do you think it just kind of tells
you that like, hey, I don't have any
retreats in my hand? Well, I I do think
that there's an argument that you kind
of want to have your uh least valuable
unit here in the Porro kind of long term
set up on the uh battlefield that you
care the least about because your
opponent is going to probably send their
first attack there to clean it up and
then you have a better window to play
something a bit more sturdy maybe with
more backup into the battlefield you
really care about.
>> Yeah, still in some of these early setup
turns. Of course, the Kaiso was the play
over here for Helpful Miner. Of course,
uh should shout him out here playing the
Kai'Sa deck versus on the other side, LM
Jeff Jones. Um very, very prolific
Yu-Gi-Oh player and I think even the one
of the designers for Argent Saga as
well, but plays a Kiana for turn and
then uses the Leon Legend ability to
buff it up. As we are now going back
now, taking over the conquer for the
dreaming tree and then targeting our own
retreat or retreat to draw the dreaming
tree, draw on the conquer and then still
get away with a bunch of resources. This
is not that bad of a setup or turn
rather for Jones though. Uh using a a
retreat in that fashion where you're not
winning an exchange against a removal
spell or protecting something in combat.
Just sort of spinning some material
around. Still not a bad setup there for
helpful minor, but uh you know Jones
definitely got kind of the soft end of
that one.
>> You're right. I mean I can only imagine
even if we use some resources to deal
with this Kiana the deflect is going to
make us pay a little bit more and we
know right away it's going to be coming
right back because of the zony's
hourglass spending our buff on the
monastery of harana getting some extra
draw of our own and we still have le
available to buff up the Kiana if we so
wish to but six runes to play with
and you know calm decks in particular
once they get into this spot they have a
unit with some substance on one of the
battlefields you have so many tricks
different stun effects, different pump
spells where when you pass with a lot of
uh energy still available. The
permutations of tricks that you can have
in that spot, your opponent's ability to
play around different cards, different
combinations of cards. It's very
complicated.
Challenge coming in here targeting the
Kiana after buffing it once again for
five might targeting one of these Noxis
hopeful. And that's very good here
getting one of these inc. We played two
Noxis hopefuls here on the side of
helpful minor. So getting one of them
off of the board, they fight each other
and I assume another showdown's not even
going to happen. But unless a trick
occurs, this Kiana will just heal up as
we pass turn.
>> And I I think something you're going to
see with the more skilled players as the
tournament goes on is uh a lot of
texture and context to your actions and
are you waiting to play them inside of
combat or do you just do it kind of when
the coast is clear? I think in
particular against Kai'Sa when you're
looking at cards like cleave that can be
played inside of combat but not
necessarily uh tricks that can work
outside of it. Sometimes it's best not
to try to get too fancy with your
removal spell there. Just cash it in
when you know it's going to be resolving
cleanly.
>> Could not agree more. As we are passing
back to Miner, I think we are now
entering these key turns of what could
end up making or breaking these games as
we get clo closer and closer to the
points. Minor on three now. I can only
assume potentially going to four with
the open dreaming tree and how many
resources we have to spend to deal with
this Kiana just for it to come back off
of the zona's hourglass and as we took a
quick read of course with the le
centered as a possible play for Jeff
Jones next turn but we need a body rune
if we want to accelerate it.
>> Yep.
pretty likely here with with six comms.
But yes, still got to find something.
>> Moving that poro in, getting the point.
And then again, a stupify for the
self-target to draw a card. And then the
minus might not really meaning anything
here for the extra bonus draw.
>> And these exchanges that helpful monitor
is doing here, they are in some ways
card advantage. You are converting one
card into two. But because at the end of
the day, Helful Minder is bottlenecked
by their ability to get into a maximum
of two battlefields and currently only
in the one. Uh these exchanges are
actually not the most efficient. Uh you
would prefer to be using these cards to
be favorable inside of combat, not just
trying to spend your energy and your
resources drawing additional cards and
not making any progress on the table.
>> Yeah, exactly. And we kind of see that
even right there, right? We instead of
using a stupify as a defensive trick on
here in that combat, we're just going to
be end up trading with the Noxis hopeful
plus the cleave here as the ong guard
comes through for Jeff Jones. But the
Kiana is just or the zony's hourglass is
going to keep that Kiana. And the way
that recalling works, we also get to
keep the buff.
>> Yeah, beautiful turn here.
>> Very slow, steady. And you know, we're
getting to the spot where Jones is going
to be able to engage in Battlefields on
his own turn, maybe use some of his
energy, play another unit to advance it,
and again passing with a lot up, putting
the burden on helpful binder to try to,
you know, plow through these very strong
defensive units and a kind of unknown
array of tricks.
>> Kathy and Rain coming down very quickly
now that Hourglass is gone. But for each
of these reflexive triggers that we
target on this Kiana, we have to pay
that deflect cost
up to six times. Having to deal with
seven mites worth because it keeps the
extra two.
>> Yep.
>> And now that we've put this up, we have
to target something as we see the
posturing here from Helpful Miner. Uh
we're about to lose all of our runes
here.
>> Yeah. And this is this is very painful.
Obviously, just in absolute terms, the
fact that Helful Miner has spent so much
of time and energy here just kind of
drawing extra cards and moving material
around means that they only have the
poutor show for it on the on the uh
table. If his board was a little bit
more advanced, maybe this would be
worthwhile. But as it stands, he's at
the mercy of Jones coming back here very
quickly if he's able to just deploy some
large units.
>> Yeah, not now the Patty Porro not
sporting a big enough advantage. only
going to be at three runes next turn
because of how many we lost in paying
the deflect cost and having an
accelerated unit like this Le centered
coming in going to completely remove the
board help that point discrepancy going
now into the favor for Jeffer catching
back up and of course we get to buff our
unit as well
so from Jones's side here with an
opponent who's only on three runes here
can you find something to get over to
the other battlefield because once
you're there you your feet are set
you're scoring two points a turn and
more importantly now when it gets back
to your turn. You can pass with all your
energy up and all those tricks again.
The burden is on helpful miner to fire
in. And again, particularly in calm, you
have so many tricks that are very good
at winning exchanges inside of combat
that involve drawing cards. They're
super efficient on the stats level. So,
the quest now for Jones is just seeing
if you can get into the other
battlefield.
>> Yeah. And we see success even like Le of
course sharing those same two domains as
Le. We know that cards like Tasty
Faithful exist and we can accelerate
them. Not just our own champion unit
that we're using here in Leen, but we
know that we can find these obviously
not the dead bloom play coming in here,
but because they cost that sweet spot of
about eight when you accelerate them, we
still get to keep up a couple of runes
for those tricks that you're talking
about.
>> Yeah. And then this is opponent who has
very little presence on the table. We'll
be going up to five runes. You know,
that that sort of that magic number for
for Kai'Sa is obviously the accelerated
Kai'Sa. We're not close to being able to
engage in any of these units right now.
And Miner is running out of time here.
Jones has already held up to the third
point. If he's able to conquer this turn
on the other battlefield, that gets you
to four. And now you're essentially
representing a two-turn clock.
>> Yeah. And essentially that score point
buffer that Miner created for himself by
just the nature of how the Kaiser deck
plays out. We've now lost that
completely because of the actions that
have occurred during the game. And I
mean, now it's up to the onus of if
we're just filled with a bunch of
defensive tricks from Jeff, we're not
going to accelerate this lead, then
we're actually maybe going to present an
opportunity for Miner to come back with
the rune state and also the board.
>> Going to be going to be tricky. And I
mean, you got to break the the other
thing is if if Jones is able to go up to
four this turn. Now, you need to break
up both battlefields. Even if you have
enough gas in the tank to get through
one, you're still going to be kind of
behind the implied race here. And Jones
has a ton of energy to work with. Lots
of cards in hand.
>> Yeah, just setting it up. Don't want to
make any mistakes obviously. Make sure
we are constantly keeping an eye out on
what we want to spend with, what we're
planning ahead for, but it is going to
be Jeff Jones game to win on its current
path in the trajectory. And we even have
again like the le we can send back home
again. Like you said, you can only score
two points a turn really like
logistically. Is there even a world
where you actually want miner to feel
like they can come back into this game,
move their units up to these
battlefields so that you can just come
back and start removing their units by
combat?
>> I think you have to be kind of
consequentialist about it. And also
there's enough accelerate in the Kaiser
deck that you do have to worry about
getting punked out where if you kind of
let go of one of the battlefields hoping
to get a favor exchange down the line,
they have a lot of ways of being able to
kind of uh punk you out before you get
back to your turd. It obviously depends
on what's going on in Jones's hand, but
I think a powerful heristic here is try
to get your feet planted in both
battlefields. Put the onus on Miner to
come through and even if he's able to
break up one battlefield, it's going to
be hard to break up both. And you are
ahead of sort of the implied race to
eight.
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. And again, we're
at the point in the game where we're
quickly approaching, if not checkmate,
at least check. And so Jeff taking his
time obviously with his turn and
figuring out exactly what we want to do
with it. No rush here. We've got plenty
of time on the clock and both of these
players are playing with great speed.
But once you get down to these hard
intricate decisions for Riftbound, like
you do have to take your time because
one decision could be the game.
>> And keep in mind two things. One, the
the cut for this tournament to make the
top 64 to be played in day two. It's not
a lot of margin for error. One loss is
good. Plenty of the two losses will make
it. Also keep in mind these players now
have been playing for approximately 8
hours. And so you do hit a wall of of
fatigue of of cognitive exhaustion. And
so players are going to kind of take the
time that they have here because you
can't afford one mistake and you're
mentally drained and it's a stressful
environment and you just want to make
sure even decisions that seem very
straightforward. If you were playing in
a Nexus Knight, you'd make it in 10
seconds. You'd want to take a breath
here and just make sure
Speaking of taking a breath,
>> yeah,
>> that judge kept coming back and forth.
They they really wanted to figure out, I
guess, a ruling there and I think Jeff
turns was asking specific interaction.
So, but it looks like we have it
resolved and Jeff is going to figure out
what he wants to do with his turn, of
course. And I guess insight from you. I
would like to ask Patrick, what do we
what do we do at least when it comes to
the game plan when trying to figure out
the path to victory for the match, not
necessarily this game? Because I think
this is a very rough game state to come
back from. What is the plan we have to
think about going game two and game
three if you're helpful minor when it
comes down to it? And obviously the
in-game decisions are part of it.
>> I mean, I would I would start by uh not
blowing up all of your runes on the
deflect cost on a unit that maybe you
could have waited a turn to. Set that
aside for a moment. Uh the Kaiso deck is
very efficient when it's on the front
foot. When you are able to fire in with
your accelerate units, you can play your
your falling stars against opponents
where they're kind of forced to play
into it just to develop their board.
Deck's very hard to beat. There's a
reason it's the most represented
champion in the room. That said, these
are the positions that are very hard to
come back from when you're playing
against relatively large units. You
don't have clean removal. For the most
part, everything that you do is going to
be damage based. you are sensitive to
the might totals of the units that
you're squaring off against. And again,
particularly in in commir
defensive tricks are often more
efficient on an energyto energy level
once you get into the spot. Now, the
opportunity cost is well, they're only
good once you are actually at a
battlefield and forcing your opponent to
engage. Once you get there though,
they're very efficient and this is kind
of the the spot that's very hard I think
for the Kais deck to come back from.
Yeah, we did see at least on that turn
where Jeff did eventually play a tasty
fate. We accelerated it, got to those
four points you were talking about and
then as we pass back the turn, all we
are really going to see are this Kaisa
survivor coming in that we knew was
there um from the retreat that was
played on it and we have to pass only
keeping the one rune up. And now we are
very quickly approaching 12 runes going
to 10 right now at least for Jeff
recycling back going to pay the four
probably another Kiana or sorry no
instead we've got the signature spell
here coming down for Le where we get to
essentially do our best ultimate
impersonation and kick a unit into
another one.
>> And remember here now Jones holding both
battlefields threatening to go to eight.
Yeah, moving this enemy unit here,
forcing the showdown to occur. It's kind
of like charm. Um, but then you also do
some damage dealing if there were other
units there. Cleave trying to come in
through as it is the attacker as it was
moved into there. But a defy going to
put that in its tracks. Stop it right
there.
>> Yeah, and this is exactly what we were
talking about with the with the calm
cards in particular. If you're able to
establish a presence and your opponent
is compelled to attack in and use pump
spells, that's their way of kind of
winning exchanges. This is a tough road
to hoe.
>> Yeah, that's right. as we're going to
play a Kiana and then we'll even use all
of our resources to give a buff I assume
on this tasty fate folk just to make it
posture the win here on the double hold
play passing back and this is it for
minor you we have to make a decision we
have to find a way at least off of one
of these battlefields to stop the game
right here
>> yeah you need to break up one
battlefield and then also be able to win
against the attack that's available to
Jones next turn it's asking a ton
>> yeah committing Kaiso paying the six
singularity doing six to2 units
with the buffs on those units. Of
course, they are alive at one damage
remaining and we do have one instance of
the ability off of the trigger form, the
Raven Bloom. So, we just need to deal
one here
and that'll take it. So, that's one
battlefield cleared off and a hex tech
to even clean up the Tasty Faithful. Of
course, still going to give the
channelneled rune and the draw from it.
Channel two channel runes.
>> Nice. We play on. We play on and still,
you know, beat by an accelerate unit.
coming back at least to it.
>> Oh, I think maybe was it was it healed
because combat occurred?
>> That's why a showdown occurred. You're
right. I didn't think it did heal off of
it. So, you had to have played the hex
tech rate first before that would have
happened. And so, I think with that he
goes, "Oh, well then I can't get there."
So, game one going to be going to Jeff
Jones on Lee Sin. Not exactly the case
that I would be thinking of, but we are
immediately going to be jumping into
here to game two. Zan Warren for the
side of Kaisa going first and then
Obliska Power coming out for Le.
All right, sweet. So for the first early
turns, we have the Pouty Porro coming
in. Easy. Just want to get a two chop
onto the board and then immediately a
Sunlit Guardian coming out for the side
of Jeff Jones and we get to buff it
because of that Obiska power giving us
the bonus rune here on the first turn.
So I I love Sling Guardian, but a lot of
the E decks have gone and taken away for
this card, but it feels very powerful
when you play it in the Le deck cuz it
holds buffs very well. Holds buffs
really well. And I think it's also kind
of part of this general package of uh
strategy against something like Kai'Sa.
You know, it's not the easiest deck to
to out efficient. You're not going to
win these like nickel and dime exchanges
very effectively. Kai'Sa is kind of best
in class at doing that. But if you can
just put a lot of size down there,
particularly you know that magic number
of going to three to four, that really
changes the dynamic with something like
falling star. Going from six to seven
singularity. And then also the deck is
just not really equipped to play
defense. And so what you see is what you
get often when you're moving in and
attacking on your own turn.
Yeah, catching up here. We did end up
moving in that pouto for a point for
helpful miner here. We ended up playing
a Raven Blue Student which then allows
us to get the Legion ability. The Nox is
hopeful going to support the Pouty Porro
taking over that Zon Warren which we did
of course didn't use discarded a card
and draw a card. Going back to Jeff
going to start things off and move the
Sunlick Guardian over the open
battlefield to catch up in the points.
>> Yeah, ideally you would like to kind of
keep your plays back if you're in uh
helpful miners position to have just as
much optionality as possible, but the
Patty portal was just going to get eaten
up by the sunlight guardian. So, you
know, you're going to have to spend a
little bit of time moving some stuff
back and then back in to be able to
engage with the second battlefield, but
uh can't just let your uh your one unit
there get clipped off.
>> And if one southern guardian wasn't good
enough, how about two? And we buffed it
as well. But now we even still have our
two ready runes for those tricks that we
get to play in the calm domain.
>> And interestingly, not adding it to the
uh other battlefield here, keeping it
back at base, implying that one. I I do
feel some level of confidence being able
to keep this one guardian on this
battlefield. And second implying that
next turn I have ambitions of going into
the next battlefield. I'm not just
trying to hold here, but I think there's
an opportunity for me to make an attack
next turn, particularly because Miner
may want to juggle one or both of their
units back to the base here to free up
some other attacks.
But like you said earlier, playing more
conservatively here on miner to kind of
set the pace on what is going to be
spent on the resources. Instead, it's
just play my champion zone. Kaiisa
survivor nonacelerated pass after
holding that Z warren. Nothing else
really there. And holding up three runes
to mess with is that same kind of
posturing and not letting Jeff take
advantage of his two ready runes because
hey, we didn't enter a showdown at all.
>> Yeah, it's t. I mean, as long as you're
in this spot, if you're with minor where
it's like it's the game's not getting
away from you just yet, you have a
control of a battlefield, you have some
other stuff going on, uh you are uh
pretty reticent to try to expose
yourself to a ton of risk. And again, if
your opponent's got two up in this spot,
there's a lot of tricks they can have.
So, make him burn off that two energy,
it goes to waste. Nothing nothing
happening there. and uh you know try to
overwhelm him in one shot instead of
incrementally going turn to turn where
those really efficient tricks can cause
you a bunch of trouble. being at eight
runes for the turn is the prime position
for a deck like this one to play a dead
bloom predator completely tapping out
for it of course but it's easily going
to knock off the pouty porro and the
Noxis hopeful and instead of leaving the
sunlight guardian in danger up by itself
we are going to bring it back home still
keeping it with the other sun sunlight
guardian but now we've hit a card here
with the dead bloom which we can only
assume for a deck like this is probably
a zony's hourglass
>> well and I also really like the the
option there of just of pushing back uh
because of the score. Once you're up
three to two, you are actually in a
really good position to say you come in,
score a point, we go back and forth like
this. I'm holding another battlefield,
so the race is in my favor. Uh I think
that's actually just a very sort of
sensitive play that's a function of the
score, right? As long as you're holding
and maybe minor has some way to get
through that battlefield, but it's going
to come at the cost of a lot of stuff.
Jeff Jeff Jones is going to have be
playing ping pong with you on the points
race, right? Like a lot of your tricks
don't work on defense very effectively
and so you're going to implied have an
advantage if you're initiating showdowns
on your own turn and you don't really
have to worry about this spot of you
know minor kind of squeezing you out
with some accelerate units or something
like that because score is still low and
you're ahead anyway. And so Jones is
willing to say, you know, kind of on a
tactical level, if you want to go back
and forth in these battlefields with me
where I'm coming back with, you know,
seven, eight runes ready, big stuff
back, optionality on my attacks. You
want to draw a card with Kai'Sa, go
knock yourself out. That's not what the
game's really going to come down to.
>> Yeah, being at nine energy for this turn
means we can play this watchful sentry
here. And we are going to accelerate it.
paying a total of eight of course for
cycling two keeping one up giving minus
three might for all of the units here
and it doesn't target of course so we're
not going to pay the deflect cost but
this means is a very easy run into the
dead bloom and even with the zonas
although we get to keep it it will still
give that battlefield over to helpful
miner which I mean that's one of the
better case scenarios at least when
you're trying to still stay ahead in the
point exchange because like you like you
just said it's Jeff Jones kind of
setting the pace if they're the ones
continuing to hold there has to be some
sort of aggressive push back from minor
like this one.
>> Yeah, you got to actually move the game
ahead. Get to a spot where you are at
least at six and can threaten the
possibility of taking both.
And Jeff Jones has a lot of time to work
with through that lens and I think has
done a very nice job of but sort of
optimizing for profitable exchanges, not
necessarily worrying about the score so
much so long as helpful minor is at a
relatively low total overall.
>> I actually love the patience. Cuz I
think in a normal situation right there,
we could have seen Helpful Miner use the
Kaiser Survivor and swinging into the
Obliska power just for that conquer draw
effect.
>> But holding it back, he's saying, "I got
the zonas out. I played a powerful card.
Of course, I'm going to have to figure
out an exchange here, but with this one
ready, the retreat here to bring it back
is very smart to still have an answer.
But with the defy immediate reaction on
it means this watchful sentry is going
to be gone. Not watchful sentry, this
thousand tailed watcher will be gone.
And the dead bloom is back in control
for Jones. But hold I hope holding back
that resource of not going in and going
to four instead is going to be worth it.
Yeah, that that thousand tail watcher
represented a ton of investment that
Jeff Jones was able to break up on
essentially two cards and very little
investment. And it, you know, Helpful
Miners only got so many punches like
that they can throw. That's part of the
problem here is you have a handful of
cards that are capable of breaking up
these big units. Once you're through
that kind of trench of cards, you're
looking at attacking with two things.
Attacking with something and playing two
pump spells. At that point, you're at
sort of the mercy of Jeff Jones's tricks
and you risk just kind of running out of
cards even if your tricks and
multiattacks work out the way that
you're hoping for.
Maybe the I'm eating my own words a
little bit here as we see the charm come
through and it did target that Kaiser
survivor brings it up in front of this
dead bloom to kill it off anyway. So if
it was going to die maybe you should
have got advantage to that point but not
knowing necessarily and instead you
might have lost a different unit of
course as it would have had to fight a
sunl I really don't think that it's I
mean it I understand what you're saying
it it looks bad. I don't think it's
tenable for helpful miner to say attack
with this Kai'Sa draw a card and you on
board can trade just with what you have
saying nothing of the cards in your
hand. It's a low probability play I
think in either instance but there's a
possibility that helpful miner could
actually get lucky or maybe top deck the
right card holding back with the Kaisa.
I think sending in there you're just
that's just not a game you can win long
term. Yeah,
>> maybe it's a different story if you're
at five points, right? and going from
five to six now opens up this dimension
of maybe I can punk out, maybe I can
time warp and hold something like that.
You're so far away from being able to
cheat this game out that you got to play
it straight up.
>> Yeah, I 100% agree. And now as Jeff
although only going to five points, it
it is essentially pro providing like hey
I am promoting the game and the match
win in two turns.
>> Yeah,
>> especially with the current board state
here for helpful miner. You you have to
do something against me right now and a
Dr. Mundo coming in at the current
moment. I mean, this is a lot of might
on a unit, but unless we can move it
right away, which there aren't really
any tricks in this Kaiser deck to do so,
it's just going to sit here for one turn
and even lose some of its power on the
next.
>> Yeah. And now we have uh we have Jeff
Jones holding up to seven. So now the
burden's on you to break up both
battlefields.
Yeah, I think we're just counting
discard. you're going to figure out what
the my total we need to play around with
cuz I mean Jeff like you said Jeff has
already had to do very little investment
just to combat all the cards that
helpful has to play every single turn. I
think this is another low investment
commit and we just do more defensive
tricks or I wonder even if there's just
like a crazy way to remove this Mundo
right out the get- go but for these two
domains a charm play would just kind of
not be a good idea.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's just sort of you know
again if you have a way to pick it off
cleanly and safely that's fine. can go
ahead and do it, but it's not like uh
there's a a big rush and certainly no
reason to risk some sort of tempo
negative exchange where Helpful Miner
can kind of get back into it.
>> Did pull back both of the Sunlit
Guardians. So, not holding both
battlefields in its current point. But
doing some math here because we're
really trying to figure out where is
this Mundo going to land. But it's going
to be Mundo plus whatever Miner plays in
conjunction also with their turn. So
there is a world here where Minal
actually can create a board state for
himself to come back. But playing the
lease sin centered coming in here and it
does have another effect on it because
it's going to receive a buff here. But
other buff friendly units at the same
location get an additional plus two
might essentially doing kind of like a
mini master Y impersonation but with
multiple units on a battlefield.
>> Yeah, I think I think uh Jeff Jones's
setup here is really good. Um there's a
very good chance that those guardians
would not be able to hold the
battlefield. Yeah.
>> Um and you have the option to attack
back with them and probably a more
profitable spot if it gets back to your
turn and and uh minor has h been able to
conquer that battlefield. It is asking a
ton to plow through on the other
battlefield. So Jeff Jones has set up
the spot where it says if you want to go
ahead and take the other battlefield,
that doesn't matter. I hold and win on
the other side. If you're able to break
up the battlefield I'm presently
holding, one, that's going to be a huge
investment of resources. Will you even
have anything left? And then two, I have
two units back at my base, so I can just
pop in and take the other one. It's
asking just a lot to get through this
turn and then the following turn. Cleave
being played here on the Mundo actually
basically reciprocates all the might we
just lost from its own effect. That
makes you recycle cards back into your
deck so that it doesn't continuously get
bigger and bigger. Um, so that's very
nice. you know, Cle just being able to
make up for that difference, which means
the math is basically the same for minor
as it was blue going into the turn.
>> Yeah, you're plus one on the Raven Bloom
student and otherwise you you're exactly
where you started.
>> Yeah.
And it only, you know, low investment
only right one energy there so that we
can continuously use even more. Another
explosive card could be another high
costic card coming through here or it
could just start be the time where we
finally see some of these iconic spells
that we typically see in the Kisa deck.
We haven't seen a lot of them in this
game.
>> Well, it I mean, let's walk through
them, right? Singularity,
not really any spots. I don't think
there's been a spot in either game where
Falling Star would have been
particularly good
>> because of the what we talked about the
benefits for the units that Jeff Jones
is playing in conjunction with buffs.
>> Yeah, I mean there, you know, to some
extent four and seven are the magic
numbers against Kai'SaO. Once you're
talking about four, requires a falling
star to a double uh target to be able to
get something off the table. Once you're
talking about the number seven, it means
falling star can't touch it at all. In
addition, singularity can. And uh Jeff
Jones has done a very nice job of just
presenting a lot of fours and sevens
over the course of this game.
It seems like we are finding a path here
at least to get this Mundo. Not no
double cleave by the way. Uh second
cleave played here. putting more cards
also into our trash. A void seeker even
coming in to deal an extra four damage
to this le. So less has to be assigned
to it. And with Jeff completely tapped
out here and only having the zonas, it's
going to be able to knock out both of
these units here. But we're going to be
able to keep one of them back and
hopefully try and present a
reciprocation here because those cleaves
do only work offensively.
>> Yeah. And now I believe Helpful Miner is
down to one card in hand.
>> It looks like. Yeah. This is just the
one laying right there next to their
runes, but going to come in here and get
a point. The Leen is the one that is
going to survive. And I really like that
because that's the one that's going to
buff your other allied units that at the
battlefield. So taking down this Mundo
is actually going to be pretty easy
because you do have two Sunlit Guardians
if you need to full invest. But we need
a double conquer here from Jeff.
>> Yeah. Now Jeff is going to be coming
into his turn with a lot of energy and
you have to assume that even an
accelerate unit would likely be good
enough here. you can pile in to where
the Mundo is and then clean up the other
one.
So, I saw Helpful Miner Hand had another
copy of Singularity and that's really
what stuck out to me across these two
games so far. Those those Singularities,
those Falling Stars, the cards that
allow you to play catch-up when you're
at neutral, a little bit behind, and
that really cement your advantage when
you're on the front foot have
underperformed here quite a bit.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I I even wonder if we
might have sideed sideboarded out some
of those that are at least harder for us
to get into those range. The falling
stars being harder to pull off because
you know once a unit gets played by Jeff
Jones we can bump it up to four and now
the falling stars feels very bad at
least efficiency wise. Singularity you
can get away with like even a
singularity here would have removed both
sunlight guardians. At least that one's
probably a little better.
>> Yeah, I think there's probably room for
a little bit of that but also you have
to keep in mind like the burden is on
helpful miner to be aggressive. you're
opening hands that are, you know, one
unit and three removal spells. That's a
dead end. You you need a little bit, you
just need a critical mass of stuff going
on in the first or second turn. I
wouldn't be surprised if you, you know,
shaved out some of it
>> on the onus here for Jeff to win and
close out the game here. Remember, even
as we go for the double conquer, we
can't take the eighth point right away.
So, we'll be able to get a bonus draw
here just by trying to contest this
Raven Bloom student. But, if you commit
too many resources over there or not the
right resources, we might not be able to
take down this Dr. Mundo right away.
doing some might counts. Once again,
checking cards in discard pile are trash
to make sure it has the correct amount
of might and so that everything is
known. And like you said, I think you
think it's just simple as one
accelerated unit. I mean, you're only
staring across two ready runes on the
side for minor.
>> Yeah, I I mean, I'm I'm struggling to
know what would be the issue here. I
mean, you got to, you know, anything
that you can play can conceivably change
the mundo math. So, you got to be
thinking about the possibility of, you
know, what's any card here worth?
Yeah, I like the idea of smokeokesc
screen showing that one on board because
we do have it and a four might
relatively five might swing is pretty
good. But we're even going to double
commit here on the sun guardian and the
le centered and we're going to get a b
we're going to get a draw here on the
conquer instead of that. But it is also
like you said a bonus card in the trash
now. Mundo goes up by one.
>> Yeah.
>> Yep. As we move the other sunlet
guardian over we are just posturing.
Well, you have played a very powerful
unit that I can't necessarily deal with
in this current moment. Well, I'll just
go for the whole game plan because I
don't know how you're going to get that
Mundo on the other battlefield to worry
about.
>> Well, we've uh
>> added a a new dimension,
>> a new layer, the charm.
>> I was going to say I did like the idea
of just just hold the hell out of one
battlefield here because even if Miner
had a time warp the following turn,
they're only holding up to seven and so
you're still ahead on that race. But
obviously if you could just break up the
Mundo right now, that's the safest play
by far.
>> We must have drawn the that charm
literally right here on the conquer from
not going to eight because wouldn't you
have just charmed the Mundo back to the
base? Yeah, for sure. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Right. So we So we did find
necessarily an answer to deal with the
Mundo and there's an accelerated tasty
fo that we had already game two and the
match going to Jeff Jones. Now X and one
for his Lee Synind deck.
>> Uh great performance. Something that I
really appreciate about watching
Riftbound tournaments and people play
the game is you can actually become kind
of a specialist with your own archetype.
Yeah. And the metagame representation,
you know, we know about, you know, let's
say the top three decks and that's maybe
half the room, but there's still room to
have mastery over your little corner of
it. Yeah,
>> there's prizes that pay out for that.
So, there is an incentive that rewards
you for becoming something of a
specialist. And sometimes when we're
talking about, you know, Riftbound and
strategy and tactics, right, we're
talking about we're trying to have the
right sort of general game plan, we have
the cards that line up the right way,
but because the nature of the removal
being damage based and that, you know,
you playing against the same units, you
know, how much might they have.
Sometimes it just comes down to numbers.
>> Absolutely.
>> And fours and sevens are magic numbers
against Kai'Sa. are going to overperform
there relative to the rest of the room
because of Falling Star, because of
Singularity, because of Kai'Sa. And we
were able to present a ton of fours and
sevens over the course of that match.
And the Kaisa deck really never it never
felt like it was doing its thing.
>> I mean, there were some good exchanges
early on in the game, but it felt like
uphill sledding once we got past turn
three. And that Leon was able to really
just kind of establish control of at
least one battlefield and say, "Come and
get it. I've got some energy up. I got
cards in my hand." And uh if you try to
brawl with my big units, you're going to
get the wrong side of it.
>> Absolutely. But on the right side of it,
we have more riveting gameplay for you
here in round seven. One more match to
start going through. We've got Annie
versus Kai'Sa, which is a completely
different story than what we just saw.
The movement tricks from Annie,
undefeated here for Tariq Patel versus
the Sensei over here playing Kai'Sa. So,
we're going to see some more of the same
interesting gameplay obviously that we
saw from the spell slinging that Kai'Sa
has, but on a different avenue because
Annie is the deck that I think a lot of
players have shown up with this weekend.
>> Yes. Fat Dad Sensei, not a player that
I'm familiar with coming into this
tournament. Uh, Tariq Patel, someone
I've known for a long time through
various games, a twotime Canadian,
uh, flesh and blood national champion
and a very, very long and story resume
over a number of games.
Yeah, kicking things off immediately as
we jump into this one. We've got uh ZH
Warren coming over here for the Andy
side in the game one. And then of course
the Dreamy Tree like we saw from the
previous match for the Kai'Sa and a
pouty poro immediately going down and we
get those runes back of course for the
legend.
And that that Annie pattern here is try
to get something sneak something into a
battlefield maybe two quickly as
possible and then use very efficient
tricks to uh retreat yourself back if
you're at risk of maybe uh getting your
thing swallowed up inside of combat.
Just kind of a deck that's really good
at getting to eight would not be great
at getting to nine.
>> Yes,
>> you you kind of just barely get over the
finish line when you get there. And
that's why you see a lot of them play
like Arena's greatest and we might even
see it come out this match to speed up a
game even more so. But I I I think this
is why a lot of people have catered
towards this Annie deck because it has
one of the as people describe and I
would agree or I would agree in some
sense of it has one of the best Kai'Sa
matchups because when you eventually get
to six points if you get to the six the
double conquer play that can come
through with the vibe plus the ride the
winds there's nothing that really that
the Kais can do about it. Yeah, there's
a there's some decks that have outs that
involve, well, I can, you know, I have a
removal spell that doesn't care about a
unit's might. Yeah. Or maybe I have a
stun effect, I could push it out,
whatever. Kaiser deck's not set up that
way. And if the game drags on and you're
at six and you're able to set up that
combo, it's really rare they have any
sort of interaction that can break it
up.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And so we'll have to see how
that approach goes for that scent say as
we are moving on and immediately playing
up cleave here on one of our own pouty
porros to beat the pouty pora on the
other side as a kaiser survivor came
through on that last turn for Patel um
or tri sorry and then readies up the two
of course and then we are going to end
up using the two immediately with the
best things that Annie has is I always
have energy to play a card to use and
we're going to go ahead and play a ride
the wind right out the get- go to move
and ready one of our units.
And of course, we target our own unit
with the dreaming tree draw.
>> That was a really big commitment
pre-combat there from Sensei because
gave up a Dreaming Tree trigger by using
the cleave before they got into the
showdown.
>> Yeah. And then of course the I love the
sneaky tricks here where you can move it
to the other battlefield and even though
you've given up and conceded the first
battle or showdown, you then go into a
second showdown. Mhm.
Yeah, showing your hand with the cleave
to start is definitely scary when it
comes to those resources, but now that
it's still out of battlefield, a hex
tech ray coming in with the of course
power being paid through Archaiso
Legend. Still going to remove that power
off of the game.
>> Yeah, still needs to play the deflect
cost on it. Yeah,
>> but at least saved one power there
through the legend.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And then following things up
with an Ox hopeful, keeping our board
healthy even though we did have to spend
quite a few cards that turn.
>> Yeah. And and and and also recycle a
fair number of runes, too. Even though
uh Sensei was kind of able to answer
everything, I think TK is probably
pretty happy with the way that turn went
overall. They used a lot of their better
cards in the matchup and uh really kind
of only tread water that turn. Didn't
get very far ahead.
>> Yep. One of the other better parts for
the Chaos Domain stack deck. Of course,
you're going to take a look. And of
course, recycling these cards does
matter a lot in this game cuz you're
probably never going to see those two
specifically, but it is still
information on what can come.
>> Yeah. And especially when you're trying
to set up that combo with Fi, it's
really nice. First of all, you get a lot
of looks at it. And second, if you are,
you know, if suddenly if your stat deck
just goes a weird way, you have to put
two of the cards on the bottom for
whatever reason. You know, it's all
right. It's unlikely that it goes that
way this game and I could try to just
plan for other stuff.
>> Easy conquer there. Um, getting rid of
that pouty porro, taking the on draw
effect from the Kai'Sa of course. And of
course, one of the other benefits of
playing the Annie deck is you don't feel
too bad about playing these sneaky deck
hands on these open battlefields because
you're just trying to get to the points
and you still get all these on conquer
effects and you're still going to ready
two of your runes.
>> Yeah, magic number six. And again, it's,
you know, it even if uh Sensei is able
to play over the top on one combat, it
implies that you're holding on the other
battlefield. Sensei can't really let
that happen. And then even if you have
some small stuff laying around, well the
the VI combo swallows that up. Passing
back of course going to have our two
three ready actually because we didn't
use them all and drawing for turn here.
And not the stickiest of unit of course
this the the deck hand which means it's
pretty easy to go into but we are going
to try and contest with another cleave
here again having to show your hand
going for going for the offensive play
here from Sensei. We're up by three
might assault does get through there but
it's Annie. I can only expect some sort
of trick.
>> Yeah. Some way to play back. Maybe some
way to just retreat back to base.
And if Ty has something like that, then
he's also going to draw a card for his
trouble.
>> Yeah. And stack deck first. Going to
look at even more cards. Still will keep
the two. And basically all of the tricks
that this deck wants to play, especially
the ones that move your own units and
target them or keep them safe to get an
extra bonus draw from the dreaming tree,
only cost two.
When you use a stack deck, Patrick Mhm.
>> and you we talk about a combo like this
VI, ride the wind thing. Um, and you see
three of those pieces immediately.
>> Yeah.
>> Is there a world where you're like,
well, I have to take the one that's more
represented because there's no other
option here. And then what happens then?
You'd never find that second piece.
Well, I think a lot of it depends on is
my game plan 100% about this or can I
probably win straight up like and Tar
Patel's spot right here. The game is
being played at a tenor where even if
that's the combo you want in this
matchup, he could plausibly win this
game absent that. And so you aren't
necessarily banking on I have absolutely
have to set it up and I'm priced into
taking one of these pieces. Um, so you
got to start from that vantage point and
then you also have to weigh, well,
what's the card I would be taking
otherwise? If it's a card that's
incredible in the spot and I'm giving up
the combo for the game, okay, maybe
that's how it goes sometimes. If you're
talking about something a little bit
more marginal or something more
replaceable, maybe you just take the
combo piece because you value that
optionality, that possibility down the
line or you think the game's going to go
in such a way that that's going to be
the only way you can win.
>> Absolutely. No, I think that's that
makes sense. And it's easy when you know
your own Annie stubborn unit picks up
half of the combo cuz it's a spell.
Yeah,
>> when you do eventually have to set it
up. Catching up of course after that
stack deck, we did play a fight or
flight target our own Kaiso saved it and
we drew a card off the Dreaming Tree.
Darius then got played on the side for
Sensei and we swung into that Zod
killing off the deck hand passing back
and now the Kaisers being able to move
up here with a cleave of our own from of
Trick
when I'm looking at like Sensei's um
another decan of course now getting
these points really solidified here
approaching that six number very quickly
if that ends up being the game plan but
when I do look on the side for um for
Dente
We have spent a lot of our runes on
power this game like you said in general
a ton of it.
>> When I look at, you know, I get that
that's what the anti deck does as well
because it's it never really meant to
ever go to 12 runes, right? That's not
what it does. But when I think of the
Kaiser deck, the longer and longer you
delay powerful cards that are going to
help you, you know, like watchers or
thousand tail watchers, stuff like that,
but I would say necessarily those cards
aren't what's going to win you this
matchup. So maybe it is the right play
to use your power more efficiently.
>> Well, we're talking about like like we
can't get Patel, we can't let Patel get
to six, right? Once you're at six, then
there's too many ways to kind of punk
you out. Okay. Well, Sensei's aware of
that, too. And so, even if those
exchanges look a lot a little
non-intuitive, it is an understanding of
the matchup that once Patel gets to six,
you're just at the mercy of his hand.
Yeah. And so everything that you can do
to try to fend that off and maybe get
into a spot where you know your
singularities are actually able to kill
stuff. Your following star is able to
actually kill stuff and you know you can
uh keep Patel from being able to combo
you out. That's worth sacrificing some
of your resources. That's worth playing
a sort of non-intuitive game.
Speaking of six, that hold from the
sneaky deck hand that was not um killed
off is going to take Trick to six. And
we are counting cards in our discard
pile. And unless I'm off by the math,
uh, he I mean, he's counting his discard
power right at this point. So,
figuring out how big things are going to
end up being, but we basically have one
turn to set up the combo if we're
looking for it. Or you just go to seven
anyway, find a way to remove this
Darius, and there's not a lot going on
for Sensei anyway.
>> Yeah, I think, you know, Patel would
prefer not to expose any part of the
combo this turn if possible. Um, you
know, an issue with Vi if you're playing
it in a non-combo spot is, well, if they
just have a falling star, you're you're
back to square one. And so, I think
Battel's probably going to try to find a
way to be able to answer this opposing
Darius.
>> Love a play like this. Playing a Gust on
your own unit at the Dreaming Tree means
you're going to get the draw card and
get your unit back. And it's a second
card for Darius to come in and get rid
of the other Darius. Scrappy being the
discard here on the ZH Warren. One of
the benefits of it being your own
battlefield, you get full advantage when
you play cards like Scrappy.
>> Yeah. And I I I think that something
that a lot of the the KG or Annie
players do is you start with that as
your game one battlefield and you have
the scrap heap. So you're really taking
advantage of it. Post board you can cut
the scrap heaps and just bring in
whatever card you want to and you don't
have the ruins, but that's fine because
you also don't have the scrap heaps that
are kind of implied to be part of it.
>> Absolutely. We did end up playing a Vive
from our hand, showing half of it, but
it does leave it vulnerable like we just
talked about, but I mean, unless just
showing confidence of like, well, if you
spend it here, it means you're not
spending removal on the Darius, which
means I get a win for the hold, so you
have to do too many fronts on too many
avenues.
>> It's also possible that he already if
you have a backup VI, you just play it,
you know.
>> Yeah, it works when it's still
exhausted.
>> Raven Bloom move in. Stupidify targeting
itself for the double draw on the
dreaming tree. Hence why we picked this
back or this battlefield so early on.
And then the gust actually being able to
bounce it back to the hand of course
which stops the conquer but um it is
still going to get the draws through.
Mhm.
And there it is. I think we show Yeah, I
didn't draw enough for the answers. I
can't even remove the daries per se. So
game one going to be going to TK Patel.
Very clean. very uh very conventional
Annie sort of win in this match up. Got
ahead early, was able to sort of fend
off some of the exchanges in combat that
are usually profitable for Kai'Sa by
retreating things back to base. And you
know, it's a very efficient deck at
getting to eight. And Patel did a very
nice job of never really having that
much exposure to the removal. I think
where people get tripped up the most
playing against Kai'Sa is just not being
mindful enough about singularity and
falling star. And if you're always
playing like the whole point here is to
avoid getting blown out by those cards
at all costs, you're willing to absorb
some, you know, not profitable exchanges
in other places to sort of remove your
liability to those cards. Uh you're
often going to be able to find a way to
bounce your units around and get to
eight before uh the Kaiser deck has much
of a say about it.
Moving on as we dive into game two with
Sensei on the play leading things off on
the battlefield for the arena's greatest
and we see Dreaming Tree on now the side
for Annie. So two games in a row where
Annie is going to be able to take
advantage of playing with the Dreaming
Tree and in the meantime you would
almost think that Arena's greatest is a
bad idea when going against Annie. But
if we're going to go to a game three
being down a game of Sensei it's got to
come out some point. Well, also I mean
that to some extent like this deck is
really good at getting to eight. Seven's
about the same, right? If you're talking
about the combo with VI or whatever
else, it's not really that different. It
might be materially different from
Sensei's side.
>> Yeah, 100%. Um, for our two drops, of
course, we have a powdery pore on one
side that that we've already moved in to
kick off the next turn for Sensei and
just a traveling merchant on the other
side here for Patel. And now we have
four runes to play with. Is it just a
Kai'Sa unacelerated? Could end up being
that or do we feel like we need to
contest and start drawing TRS again? I
mean that's the other side. We are also
the Kai'Sa deck. We play Dreaming Tree.
So they also get us two games in a row
of benefiting from this battlefield. And
the question is, do we see a gust play?
But the deflect cost would be meaningful
at this point.
>> Yeah, I mean it I don't know. This seems
like not the type of thing worth
fighting over this early on in the game
to me.
I'm sure Patel has played this matchup
hundreds of times and has a map for how
they want the early turns to go. So,
we'll see if this is worth it. It's a
pretty big cost.
>> Yeah, already posturing the deflect by
recycling that one. And again, it only
stops the conquer. It still gives all
the draws of course,
>> right?
And you know as we pass you we still
have our the pouty Boro can come right
back of course as the gust only bounces
it back to our hand passing back to
Patel. I mean denying the point might
mean and go a long way for if that's
you're right if he has the experience in
this specific matchup when the arena's
greatest is out.
>> Yeah. I mean every every point takes on
a heightened context when that card's
involved.
>> Absolutely.
>> Move trigger from the um from the
traveling merchant and playing cards
like this. You know, it makes me wonder
did the when you still play cards like
Traveling Merchant, did we keep the
scrap peeps or did we not because Zan
Warren plus that card is value or did we
just make room for even more answers to
specific matchups when it feels like
already that the Andy deck has a pretty
good matchup into Kaiso?
>> Well, I my experience is the scrap heaps
are pretty sketchy even when you have
the Warren.
>> It's just like every time you draw it
and you don't have the thing, it's like
what am I even doing here?
>> Yeah. So I would have to assume once
you're not being subsidized by the
warrants that it's that's the first card
to go.
>> Yeah, 100%.
>> But it is a cool thought. As we pass
back of course to Sensei when the Kaiser
came out of course we passed going to
ready the two the again the offensive
showing our hand needing to play a
cleave but the dreamy tree of course
still gives us value for the drawing of
it. And there is going to be
potentially, we thought about it, we're
thinking,
>> and yeah, looks like we're going to
fight or flight our own traveling
merchant, which will give us a move
trigger, which will also give us another
discard draw.
>> Yeah.
>> And we did target our own draw,
>> draw out the tree, and then also you
have your draw and discard from the
merchant itself. When people have scrape
in their deck and no ruin, you know.
>> Mhm.
>> Like you live in a totally different
reality than me. Every time I play in
this deck, I just I've got these scrap
pieces. I'm just sitting there thinking
like, do I play them? Do I let my
opponent have the satisfaction of me
actually watching it
>> play it? Or do I just ride it out? You
know what I mean?
>> Uh, well, I'm in the same boat as you.
Every time I play scrap peep, I draw
them but don't have a way to discard
them or I have things to discard and
never draw the scrap peep. So, I'm like
you. I'm going to sign them out.
>> The second world's fine. That's where I
want to be anyway. That's just my
postboard game. Like, I'm getting ahead
of schedule.
>> You're right. You're so right. But when
I do play them, why don't I see them
then?
>> Uh there's a confirmation bias and
selection. There's like a lot of ways
your brain just kind of doesn't work
right with this sort of thing.
>> You're right. Statistically, I should
still be doing the
>> best the best thing probably for your
mental health is just get them out of
your deck and then you're not thinking
about it anymore.
>> You're right. You're right. I like that
thought because I think Annie can still
play the game as you've already said
post without them.
>> Building up some more units of course.
Raven Blooms coming down, keeping one
rune readied. And now we're going to
have a pretty hopefully successful turn
here for Patel to maybe go in for a
double conquer and one of these being
that Skisa survivor to help bring these
cards back and forth. But both of these
decks are drawing a ton of cards. And I
think that's why a lot of people have
shifted to the anti deck because it
feels like it almost draws similar
levels of resources as the Kai'Sa deck
just with a very aggressive game plan in
mind versus the versatility of Kai'Sa.
Yeah, you don't you don't have near
quite the same tools that Kai'Sa has for
just kind of winning mid-range battles.
You are very much about retreating,
trying to, you know, sneak into
battlefields and barely get there. Uh,
you also just have a lot more volatility
in your draws cuz you have just more
fidgety stuff. You know, the movement
sort of implies that you need the units
and these things have to be timed a
certain way. The Kaisa cards more or
less just work on their own, not as
sensitive to which ones you're drawing
in what order. But I mean the reason
that people have gone to Annie this
weekend is the perception that the Kaisa
matchup is really strong and we've seen
that so far through a game and a half.
>> Yeah, 100% agree. Getting that stacked
deck to resolve. Grabs one card puts the
two back of course on the bottom. And we
got a traveling merchant here to contest
against this pouty porro currently
trading with. Going to go ahead and
discard and draw a card. Two to two.
going to go ahead hold the focus and
play a cleave of our own just like we've
seen Sensei do and with the Dreaming
Tree again drawing we we're seeing the
same thing over and over again. This is
some bread and butter.
>> Yes, it's nuts and bolts.
>> Xtech Ray coming through of course with
that one rune that we left up is going
to be able to help deal with that
assault three essentially where they
will still trade.
Denying the point here could be massive
though if we don't have another way. And
I can't imagine on four runes what are
we going to do?
>> Well, it depends if we got the uh
>> beer guard
>> the the deck hand.
>> Oh, you're right. Deck hand for three
does get that job done.
>> Paying the two ride the win also gets
the play done. And I like I like it when
the Annie player uses the parts of the
combo early to still progress the game
plan as a whole. And it's also another
conqueror for the draw on the Kai'Sa
going to the other battlefield. So it
does feel like it gives you the huge
value exchange.
>> Yeah, I mean anytime you're converting
this card into a point when you're
playing on seven points, it's going to
be pretty profitable here. And I I think
that uh Tyreek is really taking a
position here of like I'm not
necessarily trying to win in combat as
such. Yeah. What I'm trying to do, sneak
around, get to seven points, sort of
limit my exposure to removal, limit my
exposure to things like cleave, Raven
Bloom, student losing in combat, and
just sort of assuming that, you know,
this is not really the type of game that
Kais is set up to play. The movement
effects, you moving back to your base,
you kicking things back to their base, a
lot of their interaction just doesn't
really work against that sort of thing.
So, as long as you can get out ahead a
little bit and just play like, we're
just racing seven. I don't really care
about presence on the table or what the
long-term uh results are of any of these
exchanges are making. It's just a race
to the finish line. Uh the ant deck in
sorry the Kaisa deck in that context has
a lot of clunkers. A lot of these cards
just don't play that sort of game very
well.
>> Even in the regards like we talked about
with the last match, right? Even as
Kai'Sa playing the Falling Stars, when
you stare across another Kai'Sa
survivor, it's in that awkward might
that you were talking about of the four
of like not wanting to have to use the
one for one. The goal of the Falling
Stars is to get the two for one.
>> Yeah,
>> but it looks like we didn't contest here
on the Kaiso Survivor moving up for the
side of Sensei. Raven Bloom going to go
in on the Arena's greatest to hopefully
take another point. But Patel will think
about it because we do have a ton of
tricks in this deck.
Gust instead to bounce it back, which at
least forces the other Raven Bloon to
come to go up if we so want the point.
Second Gust
and it looks like it's good. So, the
point's going to go for Sensei. Four for
both players, but Patel will be the
first one to go to six if that's the
current pace.
We didn't use any tricks aside from the
gust, right? Do you think that's better
or worse if you're in Patel's shoes that
your opponent didn't really put up much
of a threat, at least when it comes to
like energy use efficiency?
>> I mean, I I think that basically from
Sensei side, the units that don't have
accelerate that just enter exhausted are
pretty poor. the way the game goes.
They're basically just kind of the same
thing except as everything else except
on one turn delay. I think Patel would
have been thrilled if Sensei just
replayed Raven Bloomstone and said go.
Now you've actually got to think of
what's the you know mixture of uh spells
they could have that could possibly mess
up this attack with the Kai'Sa cuz the
one of the vulnerabilities of the Annie
deck is once you're locked out, you're
locked out. Yeah. like you don't have
really a way other than pushing things
back to the base for temporarily to
actually break up once your opponent has
established a position on the
battlefields. And so if Sensei just
plays a Raven Bloom student exhausted,
it's like, okay, fine, whatever. I now I
have all my resources to work with, all
these cards in hand, and there's a
pretty limited range of what you can do
to to mess up my conquer with the
Kai'Sa. Now it's all right. Sensei's got
a lot of cards in hand. Three energy
available. There's a lot of ways that
this attack can go badly for uh Patel if
he's not careful
>> by coming out early. Um but as we've
said before, you know, sometimes it's
okay to play the posture as we're going
to go ahead and start activating its
ability. Recycling for seems to be the
decision, saving maybe some for later,
but I mean, we have a ton of cards that
we're allowed to do so. And what's that
range of when you see the Kai'Sa player
hold three up? What is the number I need
for Hexte Ray plus smokeokesc screen?
It's you need seven extra on top and the
Raven Bloom,
>> right? It's like three copies of Stupify
or whatever. There's a there's a range
for sure. Three spells is asking quite a
lot here. Two is realistic. So, you're
sorry to sorry to break down here a
little bit what the math looks like. You
do want to save some stuff in your
trash. One is of the following tour with
VI. That might be an option that you
want. And second, remember you still
have Annie as a champion. So there's
some you want to have a selection of
spells to uh be able to get back should
it go that way. But yeah, here is the
combo that we've talked about. It's
finally happening here. Of course, not
at six points, but at four to still get
a double conquer and get some units off
the board. No contest at all. Well, if
we didn't have a contest for that one,
probably means we don't have a contest
for the other one. Even though it does
have a little bit more might on the
Kai'Sa going for the ganking on the Vi
to hopefully get Patel here to six.
>> Yeah, the Raven Bloom soon actually has
a higher ceiling as far as its might
goes because it could theoretically be
three spells which is an implied five.
If you don't play anything there, you
you're pretty certain that the attack on
Kai'Sa is also going to be good even
though Kai'Sa is ostensibly the larger
unit of the two. And yeah, if you're
tell I I can't agree more. Just pass
because now you get to use all of your
resources to try and maybe keep this V
alive. And all we have to do next turn
as we would go to seven runes. Even if
we have to pay one power cost, four
runes on the Annie to pick up the ride
the wind again means we can pay for the
combo again,
>> right?
And even if everything dies, if if
Sensei doesn't have anything at a uh a
battlefield, you can even just go Annie,
pick up a movement spell and ready Annie
and move in. You don't even need another
copy of VI.
>> Correct.
>> But the Darius is coming in here. So if
there's any sort of combat trick that
can keep this Vice safe by coming back
and of course also on a dreaming tree.
So if it targets it, I think of a flash,
think of a fight or flight. Even fighter
flight to send the Darius back is not a
bad idea.
Yeah, targeting our own VI, bringing it
back to base and the target draw. And we
still have three energy or three runes
to play with. And we essentially for
this Darius play to happen, we used
everything but two of the resources for
Sensei.
If we have it, we have it. I mean, we
can just grab it, I guess.
And from this spot, you know, your
removal is not particularly strong.
Units that you can add to your base not
particularly strong.
And so the San deck is very good about
making the game about something else.
>> Yeah.
>> When you're just playing nuts and bolts
riftbound, the Kai deck's very strong.
It's got really efficient stuff, strong
units, flexible game plan. If you want
to have time warp for sort of an endgame
combo to get you out of some spots, you
have that option. Some players aren't
even bothering with that. But the antid
is is making the game not really about
winning profitable exchanges in combat
as such. And uh, you know, the tools are
just not lined up the same way as it is
against a lot of, you know, some of the
more conventional decks in the metag
game.
So my question to you is as I'm kind of
seeing a little bit of the writing on
the wall even with you know a buy
activation here um you know playing a
second card getting this Darius to be
ready to go in with the buy with the
cleave here showing game 20 for Trick
Patel on 7 and0 basically
being very close to an autolock with a
single ID going 71 and one is that kind
of ideal record that we're looking for
basically confirming a top 64 here for
for Terry.
>> Yeah, very very nice run so far. Um and
it was really the the dreaming tree has
a lot to do with that too. I mean, if
you're looking at Patel just just
gusting a a powdery porro on turn one or
whatever and just being like how how do
you possibly have a full hand of cards
and all your resources going on lane in
the game? And both games he's drawing
three, four, five extra cards. Some of
that is the scrap heap plus the the the
warrant. Some of that is the dreaming
tree. But without that sort of level of
card flow, it would be very hard to be
able to do that over and over again. You
just kind of run out of stuff. At some
point, you either run out of the spells
or you just don't have enough units, you
have too much vision stuff. But because
the faucet was on the entire time, he
was basically drawing two cards a turn
that he was able to use some cards in
some ways that were very energy
efficient, but not necessarily card
economy efficient, shrink the length of
the game, and still won with three or
four cards left over. It wasn't like he
was completely on empty, but uh you
know, you got to factor in the
battlefield when you're talking about
these sort of games. I think that the NA
deck wouldn't be able to do nearly the
same amount without having the access to
scrap peep and the discard and draw in
game number one and then the dreaming
tree in game number two. So the
battlefields are a huge part of the deck
construction.
>> I mean, two games in a row on Dreaming
Tree, right? One of your own or sorry,
one of the Kaisers and then also one of
your own for game two. I I it just I
agree with you 100%. It seemed like the
Annie deck just actually gets to value
off of it more. Whereas the Kaiser deck
is not just using cards from that have
to remove your opponent's pieces. They
target your opponent's stuff. So there's
less cards that target your own. You get
almost less value out of it.
>> Well, drawing cards is all well and
good, but at a certain point you
actually have to convert it into
something tangible.
>> And Patel in those games is just saving
his own units or just literally scoring
points with them. Yeah. If you look over
on the other side, Sensei at the end of
the game, yeah, drawing some cards off
the dreaming tree, died in both games,
six or seven cards at hand, like but
Patel was able to just fundamentally
make the game about something else. Card
economy wasn't really it. It was just I
have energy efficient exchanges
>> and I have a lot of ways to create
leverage and threaten to score two
points a turn and you're always swimming
upstream against that. your removal is
by and large not action speed and so you
have to commit on your own turn and then
also you're not breaking up any sort of
ride to win sort of combos that I'm
doing because your removal doesn't work
at that sort of speed and it's just sort
of the the wrong tools for the job and
it's weird because when you think of
Kais it's like at it's just like kind of
a who's who of just all these like very
efficient straightforward cards but if
you could try making the game about
something else sometimes those cards are
not going to look as efficient. We got
two examples of that where you had the
le just say, "Look, this is I'm just
going to squat at these battlefields. My
combat tanks are going to be way more
efficient. Um I'm going to be buffing. I
have maybe some stun options at some
points. It's like you're just not going
to be able to push through this." And
then the antid is kind of the other
complete side of that equation. It's
like I'm just playing this weird
counting game. I have no sentimentality
towards any unit that I happen to have.
I I'm not even likely to play my
champion a lot of the games.
off the side. Maybe it comes up,
probably not. But just in both
instances, making the game about
something else where those very
efficient cards that kind of play in the
middle that are very good in these nuts
and bolts games just really didn't have
anything going on.
>> So, while I then have you this weekend,
>> yeah,
>> I want to pick your brain because if I'm
a Kai'Sa player, I have a friend of
mine. Kai'Sa is his favorite character
in the entire League of Legends lore.
What what does a Kai'Sa player have to
do now with this onslaught of Annies
into the format? Especially here in
English, a lot of players really
focusing on this and being the answer to
Kai'Sa. What do you do or do we just
have to accept the fat? In fact, for
Kai'Sa players across the world, this is
a rough one. Is there things that we can
change within the mind domain, within
the fury domain to help those players
deal with a legend like Annie?
>> I mean, you you can start looking at
maybe playing different removal spells.
something that really struck I mean you
just need I think a lot more stuff that
plays at action speed and I know that it
it cards like singularity and falling
star are pretty sacred but when your
opponents just all the damage is
happening on their own turn and you're
looking at cards you can only play on
yours there maybe something has to give
there you can also maybe just say we're
going to give the metag game a little
bit of time if you perceive the Annie
deck as something of a silver bullet for
addressing Kai'Sa and a lot of their
cards and tricks would not work in a
more generalized metag game. Okay, well
that's going to probably result in a
couple other decks being slightly more
played over time because they can say
I've got a good Annie matchup like I I
have the right tools to kind of fight
this kind of fight and if the
representation of Annie goes down over
the course of time then like maybe you
don't have to change anything at all.
Maybe this stuff kind of just shakes out
the right way for you. But that's why
it's interesting watching these
tournaments and you know we've we've
gone from a variety of tournaments in in
China. We had a 10K in Las Vegas
recently. We're here in Houston for the
first regional championship in the uh
regional qualifier rather in the uh in
the United States. And
we've seen very different metag games in
each tournament. Yeah, it maybe not even
necessarily on an archetype level, but
when you're talking about individual
cards or even just kind of the strategy
and tactics that the best players are
using in variety of matchup and it's,
you know, weekend like this, you might
have to go back and drawing board and
you might say, I can juggle some things
around. I can have a little bit play
more play on my opponent's turn and sort
of address it that way. Or you might
just say, I got to wait a few weeks
before I play this again and hope that
there's metagame adjustments, sort of
second and third order consequences
where Annie's just not as good as it
used to be because there's just less
Kai'Sa generally and is playing against
decks where it doesn't have structurally
the same kind of strong matchup. Yeah, I
mean that makes 100% sense to me because
I think the biggest thing and the
biggest discrepancy I can think of is
not just about the Annie representation,
but the chaos domain as a whole and the
chaos domain having a lot of these
answers that maybe the guys really does
struggle against. So, um, but with that
being said, that's going to be it for me
today, Pat. I know you still have quite
a few rounds to get through.
>> Pleasure. Thank you so much.
>> Absolutely a gift. But of course, we
still have plenty of more riff round to
get through as we are at the peak of day
one. So, we've got some more that we're
going to send for y'all. Don't go
anywhere. We'll be back soon.
>> I'm here with Gail Wins, one of the
admins of the community Discord. And uh
Gail, you're here to compete. I wanted
to ask you a little bit, you know, to
tell us about yourself and how you got
into Riftbound.
>> Yeah, so I'm a self-described Riot
fanboy. I have been following League's
IP for so long. My first memory of like
the Riot IP, I was like eight and my dad
was playing in the alpha and I remember
sitting on his lap and like pressing Q
with Niti spear for the first time with
my dad and that has just always stuck
with me that's like super near and dear
to my heart that like this is something
that not only have I shared with my my
my father, my family, but this has just
been like characters and a world that
I've grown up with really. So, it's
amazing to be here at an official event
and be feeling like I'm a part of the
start of something. Look, Gail, that is
amazing. And you've, you know, you've
given back to the community, being an
admin in the community Discord. I wanted
to ask you a little bit about how that
has been and and why you kind of jumped
right into that.
>> Yeah, it's been a lot. Um, the reason I
stepped into the role mainly was to make
sure that the rules of the game were
getting a bit more uh reach. Uh, cuz
back in the day with the trial meta, we
had a single piece of paper that told us
how to play the game. And all of the
rules of how to play it were like pieced
together from uh responses from some of
the riers. And so I I stepped up to try
and make sure that everyone like
understood what was happening with the
rules and how we were as a community
playing it together. Even if it wasn't
correct fully back then, we were at
least playing it together. And just that
feeling of everyone playing the game
together is what really led me to doing
more with the community.
>> Nice. Well, you are also competing and
so I want to ask you what deck you
brought, why you chose that list.
>> Yeah. Uh I brought Yasuo, the
Unforgiven. Uh this is a super
underrated legend. I think it controls
the battlefield by moving its units
wherever he wants. Basically, he has
high agency in a game cuz he can choose
how to play the game and where to play
it at at any moment. So, I like feeling
in control. So, I like playing Yasawo.
>> Do you have any shout outs you'd like to
to give?
>> Yeah. I want to talk about the Nexus
Cast, the podcast that me, Sneaky, and
Max Depro host. Uh, make sure to tune in
to us every week on Monday.
>> All right. Well, thank you so much,
Gail. We're gonna ship it back to the
desk for more Riftbound action.
>> This at the very edge of the table.
Yeah,
>> thank you.
>> Appreciate it.
>> All right, welcome back to the Houston
Regional Qualifier Bose. No warning for
us, Patrick. We don't get a warning. We
got to be ready at all times. Our
players got to be ready as we are making
it towards the last final rounds of the
day. Rounds eight and nine. And while
all Swiss wins are kind of created
equal, they all count towards qualifying
in. We are winning in territory. And
while those wins are the same, the
pressure is not.
>> It is not. And also that mental fatigue,
that mental load. I mean it we are
watching
>> game after game. Something about
riffbound is there's no squashes. I mean
every game is your opponent's playing
back at you. You're going back and
forth. It is cognitively intense.
Players have been going on for you know
we're going to be approaching 10 11
hours. And I know personally as someone
who play a lot of trading card games, me
at 25 versus me at 35 versus me at 45
when it comes to this, it's round eight.
How am I feeling? Am I ready to go? You
know, I I can look at the tape. I don't
have the analytics, but I can go back
and I know that it does this. So, even
for players who have maybe prepared a
lot for the event, like you've played a
lot of games at your local store, you
play been playing with your friends, you
know the matchup, you really haven't
been stress test like this. both the
combination of the stakes being super
high and just how long you've been going
in a high intensity matchup. So you can
you can prepare for this. You can't
really prepare for this to a certain
extent you got to experience this to to
know what it feels like.
>> All right. Well, let's see. We had fresh
face Gail in that interview yesterday
early on in the day. And now we're going
to see Gail after seven rounds of action
coming into round eight here playing
that Yasuo he was talking about in that
previous round. both of these players
live to make the top cut, but they must
win here.
>> Yes. Uh Yasua, I know that there were
friends of mine who have something of a
testing collective out in Los Angeles.
They were very big on this archetype
coming into the tournament.
Master Yi, one of the established good
stuff, been a key feature of the metag
game in China over the summer and has
transitioned very smoothly into North
America. Yeah, and while the overall
percentage of Master Y is a lot smaller
in the West than it was over in China,
when I'm walking the top tables, I'm
still seeing these Yees all around.
They're still having a lot of success.
We'll see how that breakdown shakes out
for the top 64, but there's at least a
large stack of Master Y threatening to
make it in.
>> And that Master Yi in the hands of
Villionaire. Something I've had to
adjust to in this tournament is everyone
having a Nomar.
>> Yeah. It's just you're not playing with
your birth name necessarily.
>> No, I know. And look, I feel it. I come
from the esports side and I'm sitting
here on the desk with my name Kasanova
and everybody else has got everybody
else has got their full government name
in the handle there and I'm like, well,
you know, we'll see if that has to
adjust over time for me or for y'all.
We'll figure it out. But to kick things
off, we do have Aspirin's climb for
Master Y. So, we are playing a nine this
time around and Zan Warren for the Yasu.
So, a lot of these purple decks being
able to go for that Warren scrap heap
start. And I believe Gail is also on it
trying to just get a bunch of extra card
advantage in the early stages of the
game. And with Aspirin, Scale is going
to have to get very aggressive as we see
a find your center from Villionaire to
start that round.
>> Yeah. And in game one, you know that
typically you're just you're going to be
playing against Ferrari of stuff. Your
strategy is going to be a little bit
more agnostic and so just having that
sort of generic card advantage makes a
lot of sense. Once you get to games two
and three, you're going to want more
surgical cards. you're not necessarily
going to have access to as much of your
draw and discard and so you can cut the
scrap heaps for whatever the right kind
of metagame bullets you have for your
opponent.
>> Yeah, it is that beautiful thing about
the scrap heap. A lot of players really
talk about having nice clean ins and out
for uh their their sideboard and scrap
heap is that perfect one where it's just
obviously great for game one and now
it's three slots that we could have as
easy things we know we can take out as
even more ramp from billionaire as the
catalyst goes alongside the za's
hourglass. So now those dead blooms and
the master yhoned are set up beautifully
when they hit the board to have that
second life.
>> Yeah. So uh keep in mind here that Gail
wins is just held up to four. Uh
presumably, you know, you will ideally
at least be holding one battlefield the
following turn. So Villionaire is very
well set up here in terms of the
structure of being able to start making
some very explosive plays. There's still
the issue of the race. you got to kind
of clean up both battlefields or at
least hold one so dramatically that your
opponent is kind of locked out from
getting the eighth point. So, really
nice opening here from Villionaire, but
still a lot of work to do. The game is
definitely not in the clear just yet.
And uh Gail Winds here is trying to
figure out, you know, trying to balance
threatening to hold the battlefields
while also acknowledging that's not
going to be easy to do and maybe I need
to start pulling some stuff back and
planning on attacking in the following
turn with more resources available to be
able to, you know, squeeze out a point
or two along the way.
>> Yeah, I think Gail is absolutely doing
his job for the matchup, right? Is score
as fast as possible. You're up against a
Y that's ramping. You're up to four
already. This is the the fear of
aspirants is while you do have the point
cadence for now that 2468 that you're
looking to find in riftbound this breaks
that math we go to nine instead and so
as you're talking about maybe being able
to hold one side ends up being enough to
still keep that point cadence especially
with remorseful coming to that back row
to be able to threaten whatever
Villionaire puts out with this Aurora.
>> Just going to be a tasty fo kick things
off.
>> Okay,
>> nice and easy.
I've I've seen bigger. I've seen I've
seen I've seen fatter.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Not too bad in the scheme of things.
Still get those hold up to six.
>> Yeah. This one has a bite taken out of
it already. So, you know, we definitely
It's not even a It's not even a whole
creature, right?
>> Verified to be tasty.
>> Yeah, of course. Yeah. I'm not sure who
verified it. Was it a dead bloom
predator? Was it the Tasty Fay Folk
itself? We don't actually know.
>> It's the beauty of of fantasy art. Two
people can look at the same image, draw
an entirely different conclusion.
>> We're finding Roarshack images in the
bite taken out of the Tasty Fay folk,
right? You got to see what we see in the
bite.
>> Getting an opportunity to work on the
creative on this project. I don't I I
don't have a heavy hand in it, but here
and there. It's been a real treat, you
know, because I came to this not the
most knowledgeable about the world of
League of Legends. I'm learning as I go,
>> but I see images and I tell myself a
story and then one of our creative leads
is like, "That's not how the world works
at all." But it's interesting that you
interpret it that way. That's a valuable
piece of information.
>> Yeah. They're like, "You're wrong, but
we love where your head's at."
>> Right.
>> As Gail is going to look for the draw
off of the Clockwork Keeper, that
additional cost being paid. Uh usually
this is one of those two drops that I
really like in in green and calm where
in the early game it serves its purpose.
It's just a two that you get to play on
your first turn. Look for that early
pressure uh on the game. But if you do
find it late game and you need to find a
missing piece of your deck, you can just
get that extra draw and replace itself.
>> Yeah, I mean a a lot of decks play what
amount two twos that if it does
literally anything else, you're pretty
thrilled. That's like a baseline thing.
your Patty Porto, your opponent doesn't
use a spell on it. Maybe it maybe it
messes something up, but like whatever.
We're not worried about it. This one
actually has a pretty high ceiling as
far as it goes. It's it's never going to
be any better than a two two on turn
one. Sometimes that's all that really
matters, but being having the option
later on the game to convert it into a
fresh card is very powerful. Yeah, and
as we see, I mean, the the point train
continued for Gail able to hold on as
that, you know, Aurora only finds the
Tasty Fay folk, but now pulling
everything back, recognizing, yeah, the
dead bloom's coming either from hand or
off this Aurora plus the master yhone.
So, just amassing might try and get
these last three points over the Aurora.
And second one comes down from
Villionaire. But is it too little too
late? That's kind of what I'm thinking
right now with how much might is already
on the board for Gail and he's got kind
of this full grip of cards. So, it
depends what these hits are. I think
these are really big.
>> Yeah, it's it's it's you're in the spot
at this point where you can just kind of
load up onto one battlefield and make it
impervious. That might not necessarily
be good enough. And sometimes the
Auroras, it struggles a little bit to be
able to spread out and to do
battlefields in time.
>> Yeah, I mean, Voybear imposing is
certainly a hit that helps you do the
the turbo stack on one side. become, you
know, impregnable, not allow any room
for Gail to try and push through there.
Uh, and we'll see what the the second
trigger comes through.
>> So, funny enough, when I I started
working on the project, the the first
deck that I built, we were working on uh
Spirit Forge was an Aurora deck, and
it's an interesting I I found this right
away, and this was like still learning
how to play Riftbound. Basically, you
have this duality that pops up all the
time where you do want to kind of just
plant down as hard as possible into one
battlefield, but you don't have a lot of
writing effects or ganking. And so, if
you load up too much into one
battlefield, you can get into spots
where it actually takes you too long to
get to base and then to battlefield
number two. And so you're often in the
spot where you're kind of splitting the
difference as you see Villionaire do
right here where one Aurora trigger is
going to load up and the other is giving
some optionality to maybe get into the
battlefield the following turn. Because
once you have both battlefields now your
Auroras have maximum flexibility. You go
wherever you want to. You stack up as
much as you want. Your opponent's really
going to struggle to break out of that.
But kind of in these intervening turns
where the snowball is starting to roll
downhill but you aren't all the way
there. You do need to leave some stuff
back at the base to at least be able to
contest the one battlefield your
opponent can still get into.
>> Yeah. And I just want to note now that
Gail is playing one of the tech pieces
for his Yasua deck that has been quite
different than some of the other Yasua
builds I've seen. And that is that
mindsplitter. And we've seen this in
Purple Plenty uh coming out of the
Misfortune decks with the Aurora getting
to rip that off the top and then just
kind of dismantle the hand. And Gail has
found a lot of success using this
instead of kind of the Kane shenanigans
we've seen out of a lot of other decks
where yes, Kane becomes uh impossible to
take any damage, right? He just becomes
impervious once you're able to move him
a second time. But Mindsplitter says,
"I'm going to shred your hand and know
exactly what you can do when I'm playing
a deck full of combat tricks and be able
to actually kind of have the same effect
almost as a Kane where I just have the
information. I have perfect knowledge."
>> Yeah. And and I that's a great way of
saying it. The information is so
important in a spot, especially a deck
that's a lot about you have a lot of
movement tricks, you have a lot of
optionality. Um, your opponent's hand is
going to range from it can't really
interact with what's going on all the
way to um, I know the coast is clear and
just having that information and and you
know, your opponent being down their
best situational card that of your
choice is often going to lead to now I
can start really popping off with Yua
and all my movement stuff.
>> Yeah. And I think this difference in the
build is what one of the reasons Gale is
kind of having the success where Yasuo
is a deck. I think a lot of players were
kind of middling on it. Some players
have a really high opinion. You said you
were testing some people in LA that
really like this deck, but often people
are putting it in B tier or yelling at
people putting it in Btier and saying
it's worse. Uh so for Gail to come out
and be on a win in and I think he is
probably the highest Yasua right now. Uh
really impressive that his his list is a
little bit off the beaten path for what
we've seen out of some of the other
Yasuas. Yeah, I mean I I I think it's
very reductive generally speaking in in
card games to to talk about things in
terms of tiers, but particularly here
where it's the skill cap on any
individual deck is so high that I would
rather if I had to bank on two people
>> and one is like generic playing the best
deck uh after testing everything and the
other is I've done nothing but play this
for months. I'm definitely banking on
I've I've done nothing but this for
months. I think that is completely fair
and we do see uh the the reps coming
through for Gail as we do have these
Auroras popping again and while Gail has
made it to seven and just needs to look
for that double conquer. This is a
double trigger of Auroras once again
while there are already there there's
already a massive amount of might on
this board.
>> Yeah. So just gonna probably just start
piling into one battlefield, have enough
back at base to be able to attack in if
you know if Gail wants to take that
point and draw a card.
But your opponent's got to be able to
conquer both in the same turn at the end
of the day or hold. So all you have to
kind of worry about is making both of
those dimensions impossible. piling into
one battlefield and having enough back
where even if your opponent's able to
expend a lot of resources to conquer one
of the battlefields, they're only
drawing a card, they're not scoring that
point. And then, you know, you go ahead
and clean it up. And remember, we're
talking about nine here even instead of
eight. So, this is going to be tough
sledding.
>> And I'm just trying to think what cards
in this Yasuo list can help you push
through this much might. But there's
already a lot of might on the back row
for Gale, right? got the Yasuo
Remorseful, you've got the Mindsplitter,
and already Yasuo, if you've got the
pumps in hand, you can really get over a
lot because of that attack trigger.
>> And and something that occasionally
bottlenecks these Aurora lists is they
just run out of units. It's not like
it's not like it's just on forever. You
have very little in the way of recycling
typically. And so you can actually run
into spots where you just run out of
stuff. Um, it doesn't happen all the
time, but depending on the details of
the list, uh, if you can just attrition
them out, Villionaire might actually run
out of units that can are are are
capable of sort of holding the game
here.
>> Yeah, I think what's going to be tough
about that are going to be those two
zoning hour on the back row cuz that's
just adding essentially two additional
units at these kind of the cost of the
gear. But what's happened so far in this
game is Gail has just not really cleared
anything yet. And if he looks to kind of
instead of have to clear a bunch of
different stuff, just try and end the
game with some pushes, maybe a rebuke
this fighter flight happening. Uh those
zon hourglasses are kind of looking
pitiful in the back row.
>> Yeah,
>> looks like Defy is going to answer the
fighter flight, but a Defy in response
from Gale to counteract that. Really
needs to get this push to go through
onto the Voli Bear.
>> And I like Villionaire fighting over
this here because your opponent can't do
this incrementally. If they are playing
a spell that moves something back, they
are trying to win the game this turn.
So, it's worth fighting over.
>> And and it looks like Gail might just
straight up have this cuz Villionaire
has now tapped out. This is a discipline
onto the Yasuo. That's just going to
allow the swing through uh to clear
something away with that attack trigger.
And then now, yes. Okay. Yes, Gail is
correct. Now the the uh Master Yi will
be able to give the plus two to the
Tasty Faithful, which is why they trade
at 8 and 8. But that is going to open
the door for just a porro to run in. And
now when I'm looking at the rest of this
might here, that's nine for Gale versus
an eight on the side of going to be
going up to nine.
>> Beautiful. Yeah, I I I had a lot of
experience playing Aurora against
movement ccentric stuff. And I was
really surprised early on learning the
game how flexible the, you know, the the
the chaos calm stuff could be in spots
where it's like I got I got 25 might and
a bunch of deflect on the battlefield.
They cannot get out of the spot, right?
No, they can. You give them you give
them enough time, they certainly can.
>> Yeah. They just got to find the fighter
flights, uh, rebukes, whatever whatever
is kind of the tech that they've packed
for it. But, uh, purple really has a lot
of that just like tempo oriented pushes
that when you get to the the point of
the game where you're just looking for
two more win uh, two more points, that's
plenty that gets you there. That gets
you over the edge.
>> And let's keep in mind, you know, to
circle back to early on, Gail got off to
a very fast start. It, you know, if if
you're a point short there, maybe it
looks very, very different, but that
early game advantage put Villionaire
into a very defensive spot. Uh Gail
Winds was not under that much pressure
to get the game over with um because
Villionaire wasn't really at at risk of
scoring nine themselves and so got to
set up a hand that was capable of
pushing through the last points.
>> Yeah, really really well done as we are
going to just have a Yasuo activation.
and windswept. Hillock really good at
abusing this Yasuo activation when you
have a unit that's ready can move it in,
get that first point, then go conquer
over onto the other battlefield, which
for this game is oblisk for Yi, which is
why we got so many runes right out the
gates. Um, but that hillic paying
dividends, giving ganking to these units
for Gale.
>> Yeah, and again, the recipe here from
Gail side is just try to score as much
as you can early on in the game. get it
to get it to the point where Villionaire
just has to play basically pure defense
and then you have a couple of movement
tricks, well, a couple ways to push
things out to kind of squeeze out those
last points.
So, when I was talking to Gail earlier,
he was saying this Aurora match up is
one that he wanted to see. A lot of the
misfortunes are some of the decks that
he's also very happy to see because he
is on this kind of more aggressive build
of Yaso trying to push in, get those
points, but also has the top end to deal
with it. And Rebuke as a sideboard
option. I think this is one of the other
reasons that Gail is so happy to see
this kind of matchup because it's such a
blowout into these big units
>> and billionaire doesn't really have a
choice. I mean, maybe you say you just
play and say go and hope to hold it up
or whatever,
>> but got to try engaging with the
battlefield. He's a score need to try to
kill stuff or whatever. So, you really
don't have a choice. It's what this
Yasua deck does. It kind of constrains
the timeline of the game. You don't have
a choice but to play into those tricks.
And that was a devastating tempo setback
for Villionaire.
>> Yeah. And now Gail gets to send it up to
four. He's halfway there to just finding
the win on this game. Gets to gank over
with Hillock and then pseudo gank by
moving home and using the Yasua
Unforgiven to send uh the wielder of
water into this windswept Hill and get
that extra point there.
Now over to Villionaire. Looks like the
runes are available for Aurora, but is
that too little too late? Is that too
slow? Do you need to just start pushing
in with either a dead bloom or the Yi
again from hand?
>> Yeah, I mean you you just
only you got to do something that can
engage with the battlefield. That's a
requirement and there's no guarantee
that Aurora does that. You Oh no.
>> Oh my god. So once again, we've got Dead
Bloom, but rebuke number two, Electric
Booaloo comes through and pushes that
thing right on back. Blow.
>> Yeah. I mean, this is and this is Gail
on Hillock. This is going up to six. And
now the clock is just it's not ticking.
It is It is The clock is exploding at
this point. You've got one turn left to
try and put everything together.
>> And you want to say there's a saving
grace on Gail's, you know, only on four
runes, but realistically it's it's six
to zero. You've got to the point where
you're set up for that double conquer
win and yeah, you may be on four this
turn, but if you can play something in
the back row and then you got a Yasu
remorseful on the next turn, you're you
can set up to find that double conquer
once again. You've got all the time in
the world.
>> Yeah. I mean, if if Villionaire is only
going to play a card a turn and you have
some card in your hand that it maybe
it's a little clunky, maybe it costs a
lot of power, whatever, but it basically
says nullify one play this turn.
Eventually, you just run out of time.
>> Yeah. And I just got a glimpse. Gail's
got a fight or flight in hand. So, while
that's not quite a rebuke at this point,
at six points, might as well be.
>> Yep. And I mean, it is, you know,
something that you're sort of priced
into structurally.
>> And here it comes. Oh, it's Oh, it's
brutal.
>> When you are playing with Aurora, you do
not get to play with cheap units and
sometimes you just fall behind and can't
catch up.
>> Okay, Defy is there.
>> That's huge.
>> We might still be playing a game. We
might still be playing a game for a
little bit longer.
Looks like Gail didn't snap off a Defy
to the Defy in response here, so he must
not have it.
>> But he does have two pumps. Does that
actually get over? Yeah, that's
a trade.
>> Yeah. Yeah,
>> that's trade. That's not bad. You take
that.
>> Okay,
>> though. Zonius is going to get cracked
here. So, still overall, I would say
that's a win for Villionaire. At least
the small win. Absolutely. Yeah,
>> that is the step one here. Right.
>> Little bit of space bought.
>> Okay.
>> Now to claw this back though, it is
going to take a lot out of the side of
this master y deck, but it does start
with dead bloom on hillock. Yeah,
>> it's a good a good place to be. Once
you've established presence at one
battlefield, if you have Aurora or then
you can start piling and as long as you
have some stuff back to be able to
answer a battlefield that your opponent
happens to conquer, they start running
out of time. And we also know, you know,
Gail's effectively empty-handed. We
would have saw another rebuke or
movement card had it been available
because it would have been gamewinning.
So now Gail is on no cards in the hand.
So, anything they draw that's a unit has
to get played. You know about it now.
And anything that's not a unit doesn't
get the ball rolling.
>> Yeah, we finally hit attrition in this
war of attrition that ye wants to play,
but Yasu has not been uh playing along
for the most part so far in this series.
It's going to be a hidden card usually
just as Hourglass
>> has been the occasional additional tech,
but seeing as how this is Aurora, it's
not going to be something like a pocket
cub.
>> I don't know. You have one as part of
your range. They're definitely not
playing around it.
>> It's part of, you know, some of the push
and pull with hidden cards is sometimes
you play the stinky ones just to
establish your range.
>> Could be anything. They You don't know.
>> Yeah,
>> don't assume.
>> You don't You don't know me.
>> We do have Remorseful going to hit the
table now for Gailwinds. So, that is the
start of building up a back row that can
try and push and find the win in this
game. I think from here it has to be
kind of those mindslitters that we've
seen and then you got to find some
spells. So, there's there's quite a bit
that Gail needs to start calling this
back at this point. It was a huge
explosive lead, but hand dumping for
those on guards. Now, you're out of
you're out of gas. Exactly. And you
know, he it's critical here. You know,
he's at six, so he's got to be able to
kind of either conquer conquer both in
one turn, which is sounds like a real
uphill battle to me, or uh be able to
hold through on doing this from no cards
in hand with very little in the way of
resources. And remember, Villionaire's
got a full grip. I mean, the those
rebukes and such, they were very tempo
efficient. They bought Gailwinds some
time, but now that time has been paid
off and Villionaire can start just
playing this stuff.
>> Yeah, once again going to just play a fa
folk that is going to reduce down to a
single rune. So the range of effects
that Villionaire can have is now shrunk
from anything to on guard defy generally
>> is going to be that range you're playing
around from there. and Remorseful with
what looks like a discipline in hand. We
can see that kind of same line that we
saw in the previous game of that
Remorseful going into the dead bloom
spot with the discipline taking it out
and then trading with the Tasty. And
when you do at least have this Za's
hourglass at the back, you are going to
be able to to maintain that. And there
are even potential ways that you can
once again push the Yaso in uh with
Unforgiven and then take out the Ye
that's also at an eight. So there's kind
of this line to really zigzag this uh
remorseful around to both battlefields.
>> Yeah, it's possible that Gail is kind of
doing this all from empty hand, but stat
deck and discipline kind of a nice set
of cards to get going cuz it's a
combination of uh critical mass of
numbers of might and also the right
combination of tricks. So you kind of
need to string together some selection
spells here to be able to have a crack
at it. But it's possible. We saw it from
last game, too. Villionaire had a pretty
well established set of battlefields
>> and Gail Win was able to Yasua his way
out of it.
>> Yeah, I wonder if he's going to go for
this exact line or if he's got anything
better cuz there's a few more cards left
for Gail. But the way this will work is
we've got the Yasua trigger. It's going
to go ahead and take out this dead
bloom. Uh Villionaire thinking about
responding. That's clearly on his
hourglass at this point. He's trying to
see if he wants to save that dead bloom.
The followup will be a trade of
Remorseful with the Tasty Fay Folk,
which will bring Remorseful back to base
where it has been healed up, but it's
still an eight. The discipline is still
in effect
>> and it can be pushed with unforgiven
legend ability into the eight of that
Yasuo or even better a ride the wind.
That is an even better card to have
where you get to go into the ganking
battlefield of Hillock score there and
move with the eight attack trigger into
the eight of Master Yhoned.
>> And I can I would have to assume at this
point if Villionaire had a way to break
up this sequence of spells, we would
have seen it by now.
>> Yeah, the question becomes on guard, but
as you said, that might have been seen
previously on the Fay folk. There's a
consideration where you let that through
and you wait for the Master Yi, but
there's the hand extended. That is the 2
for Gail wins on this winning in with
his Yasuo. So, we'll be having a Yasuo
in our top 64.
>> Awesome stuff there. And then really
solid game plan against Aurora. You
know, you can you can kind of tell we're
expecting points 2, four, and six to
kind of come naturally while you're
setting up shop. Then it comes the hard
part of where are you doing about seven
and eight? and you have enough movement
effects, the the the Yosua sequences can
actually push through units of pretty
substantial size and be able to squeeze
out those final two points. And we saw
it both games one and two.
>> Beautiful from Gail and it just shows,
hey, maybe you don't need Kane.
Remorseful has plenty of tricks for you
to work for from your champion zone.
Find some other cards that can fit in
the deck to help make that all tie
together. But we've got another match
from this round, another winning in. And
we're going to be jumping into a match
in progress. We're going to jump right
into game two of this matchup of this
Kai'Sa mirror and we'll see who can
actually come out on top and earn a spot
in that top 64. So, let's jump right in
to our second match of this round going
right into game two. Carmen versus
Shecky.
Carmen Hiego, dear friend of mine,
professional colleague in a number of
respects.
uh someone who feels very confident in
their list of Kai'Sa has done a lot of
preparation leading up to this event
coming to us from the Seattle Washington
area.
Uh finished in the top eight of the Star
City Games 10K recently.
>> Yeah,
>> very great performance there.
>> Was talking to me in between rounds
saying earlier today she had lost her
first Kaiser
of all time. Wow. Did she say who she
lost to?
>> I didn't get a name.
>> All right.
>> Only the story.
>> That's all right. She was uh she
actually kind of popular repopularized
the um the rear guard as a two drop for
the the Kaiso deck. I think a lot of
players were really low on that card.
And then we saw Carmen with her her full
three copies uh at Vegas and just
showcasing how aggressive you can get
with that card and how that accelerate
can really combo with a time warp as
well especially. and a lot of players
really enjoyed that rear guard
afterwards.
>> Although I do not know the particulars
of Carmen's list, I know she is
generally bearish on time warp in the
deck.
>> Nice. Well, that's a lot of players have
started to come off it coming into this
event.
>> I think there's a perception among
certain players that there's the time
warp is already kind of selecting for
games that you were likely to win
anyway.
and the opportunity cost of having a 10
cost spell
where you know the deck is not light on
uh power costs and recycling your your
champion does uh or your legend rather
does mitigate some of it not all of it.
It's not trivial to get there and the
cost of having a card in your hand you
can't do anything with uh it's pretty
high.
>> Yeah. And just to take stock of where we
are in this series, uh Shecky up one
zero against Carmen going into game two.
See what the battlefields are when they
flip this as they're just going through
start of game procedures.
But yeah, I mean, as you said, Carmen
said that she lost her first Kaisamir,
now down a game in another Kaisamir.
This one for that day two for that top
64.
>> Yes.
Now, I believe some number of the X and
twos will make it, but obviously you
don't want to
>> you don't want to leave it to chance.
>> X1 and one is a very solid record that
sees you into the top 64.
Carmen would have to sweat it out if she
picks up a second loss.
>> Yeah, not exactly a losing out, but
right
>> certainly a win in it. Yeah,
>> as we do have the battlefields for this
game too. Star tip peak for Shecky going
to be looking for those extra runes on
hold. Usually this battlefield used to
counteract some of the Aurora try and
help you kind of keep up uh with your
runes in those. And on the other side,
Carmen taking a much different approach
with the arena's greatest trying to just
win as fast as possible and being on the
play for Arena's greatest. very big
advantage I would say in the mirror
>> especially if your opponent's not
anticipating it right set up for
something of a slower game and suddenly
they're playing a seven there's like a
lot of cascading consequences that can
come from that sort of thing
right mulligan's coming through two to
the bottom for Carmen
same forky I saw a falling star and what
looked like a void seeker in the hand of
Carmen both great cards in the mirror uh
void seeker going to help you deal with
the opposing Kai'Sa and then of Of
course, falling star is just how you
keep cleaning up the small stuff, not
letting the points come through for
Shecky. Very important to just keep the
board clear. Create your own board.
That's that's the mirror in a nutshell.
As simple as I can put it.
>> But, you know, Carmen's plan, especially
going first here, is those removal
spells are great. All that's predicated
on having something to get the ball
rolling. You need to have your your
critical mass because if you're saying
go just saying there removal spells, um,
that is not a winning recipe. You got to
get you got to start establishing some
presence, have an opportunity for some
of your tricks to manifest and uh use
your removal spells to keep your
opponent from being able to engage in
the battlefield.
>> Yeah. And it was great earlier, you
know, we're talking about the Leon match
up versus the the Kais talking about the
fours and sevens and that kind of comes
into play again in the Kaisen mirror.
There's the Noxus hopefuls uh coming in
at that four break point that are very
important in this mirror being able to
try and establish those wide boards of
fours that become difficult to manage.
And then you know watcher it's a seven
tech. It it does a lot of things but
that body becomes quite difficult to
deal with once it actually kind of hits
the board outside of your own watcher.
It creates a lot of trouble in that late
game. So we are kind of still looking at
those fours and sevens.
>> Yeah. So the the anti-magic numbers are
threes and sixes. Yes.
>> That is a maximum exposure to falling
star, maximum exposure to singularity.
You can kind of actually approach the
other way where it's just like yeah load
up on once. you want to just pick a
bunch of recruits and that's not going
to be very that's going to be strong
against falling hard and singularity.
But if you do want to engage with more
>> uh middle of the road mid-range units,
you want to avoid threes and sixes
unless they have some built-in immunity
to falling star or singularity.
>> Just kicking things off, Carmen does get
the patty porro into the star tip peak.
However, Raven Bloom student is kind of
the better two for the early stages of
the game. Uh if you have something like
the stupify, you can just use Kai'Sa to
pay the cost on the porro. Really gets
you ahead when sending this in. And
we'll see uh what Shecky's followup to
uh presenting the trade with this
student. And in fact, it looked like he
passed focus over to Carmen. So maybe
some willingness from Carmen to just
accept this, but we are going to see the
Void Seeker come through.
>> Yeah, I well the Carmen saying go is
awfully suspicious, right? So that there
she's signaling I've got a hand that can
play back at you if you want to come get
it. So Shaggi is kind of taking the
offering the path of least resistance,
which is say, "Yeah, I'll trade. That's
fine."
>> Yeah. And with that follow-up, he gets
to kind of bait out this void seeker and
then actually accelerate Kaiser
Survivor, which is not the most common
thing to happen out of the Kaisedex, but
in the mirror, I actually see it a lot
more just because claiming that point in
that card can be so much more valuable
in the mirror when it's not promised.
You could just get falling starred if
you leave her at the back. Well, there's
also just a there's only so much so many
windows uh to get it there where you're
not worried about something like
stupify. Um a hex tech ray would involve
the you know two cards essentially. Uh
and a lot of the other tricks are only
working on offense. So that's a pretty
solid window to just kind of get your
value there.
>> Yeah. And there's exactly that falling
star from Carmen that she held on to in
the mulligan. It does get to answer the
Kai'Sa. But sometimes in the mirror
that's not the happiest you are when you
have to falling star the Kai'Sa if you
can't deal with it with unit combat and
you don't get to hold on to the falling
star to deal with the wider boards later
on where that does feel like the the
happy place in the mirror when you get
to deal with two units.
>> Yeah.
>> Or using it to create some sort of
leverage, right? Like if you're breaking
something up and then you got to conquer
a battlefield you otherwise wouldn't
have, that's great. Uh Carmen does have
uh the rear art here to be able to take
a point, but you know, run starting to
run low on resources at three points
right now. Uh Shaki with a handful of
cheap interaction.
>> Yeah, just going to be a Ray. Easy
enough. Guard goes down.
>> Car's got to let that go. And now we
start to see the hopeful hit the board.
And still just plenty of answers in
Jackie's hand. See the falling star, see
a retreat. I wasn't sure about his
interaction at action speed that he has.
I I'm kind of missing a couple of pieces
of the picture here for as Carmen tries
to get a couple more points on this
turn.
Three runes up threatening Void Seeker,
threatening Ray.
Lot in the range at three.
>> Yeah, and I like that that line there
from Carmen. A nice way to play around
Void Seeker is just not commit anything
to any of the battlefields that turn.
So, she does develop board. She does use
all of her energy. And if Shaggy was
just sitting there on Void Seeker hoping
to clip uh Kai'Sa or something else, uh
that energy just got burned off.
>> Sometimes the most powerful thing you
can do is just pass. This time it is
going to be Falling Star going to answer
the Kai'Sa before she's able to get a
conquer. But of course, Carmen not
spending a rune to accelerate. So kind
of zero sum in this spot as the rear
guard, but the hopeful will move in onto
the start.
Second survivor going to come in from
Chucky. Seen a lot of decks go to just
one for the champ zone, but I think the
most common I've seen nowadays is the
second copy. Yeah, no more than two.
It is a card that's on pretty pronounced
diminishing returns. It's very, very
rare that the second copy is anywhere
near as good for you as the first copy
is. So, makes a little sense to
deemphasize it just a little bit,
especially because you're always
starting with one.
>> Back over to Carmen on eight runes now.
Looking at the sentry, just saying,
"Okay, well, if you want to raid my
sentry, go for it." Going to go up to
the four points here
>> on eight. There's a lot of options you
can have that can be a watcher turn, but
we're kind of far from a watcher. And
just going to say, you know what, this
board is good enough to rain.
>> And I think sometimes just taking the
two for one on your rain is in fact
quite good enough, especially with two
fours, which can be tricky to deal with.
And Rain gets to deal with it easily.
>> And particularly now that you've
established some level of like you do
have a battlefield right now, so it
isn't just treading water. It does put
some burden. It's not asking a whole
lot, but at least Check is under some
obligation to push back on that BA
battlefield the next turn. Then you
start getting into a race where maybe
your accelerate units like you're just a
little bit more efficient. It seems very
likely that Check is going to have an
advantage in a long game. These
exchanges have generally been pretty
profitable. So Carman's got to kind of
shorten the length here a little bit and
at least try to maneuver it into a spot
where the right sequence of Accelerate
units can uh uh clear it out before
Shaki can deploy all his cards.
>> Completely agree and I think having the
point lead is so massive in the mirror,
you know, first to six usually wins the
mirror. Now there are a lot of edge
cases, plenty of them, but that is like
uh one heristic you can look at. Getting
first to six in the mirror is so
important and it often leads to that
victory. And currently Carmen is ahead
in that race and has a good suite of
accelerate in the hand with uh a
thousand tailed watcher and I believe I
saw Darius as well. So lot of
optionality as this game continues as we
did have that retreat to save the Kai'Sa
>> and it might not look you know like the
most
biggest inflection point in the game
necessarily. It is critical that Czech
does not allow Carmen to score this
whole point. Now, there's going to be a
lot of ways to break that up, but going
from four to five here, even you got to
use a spell, the death rattle triggers,
draw a card does not matter. The point's
way too important here.
>> Yeah, because then if you let that point
through, it's a single accelerate that
comes in and gets you to that six. And
that six is all important, especially as
we get towards the end stages. And you
know, Carmen is on these these uh these
rear guards. So, rear guard plus watcher
is just nightmare once they've gotten to
the six points. Y
>> redevelopment from Checky,
>> but only two runes available. Maybe go
time for Carmen on some of the
accelerates. Now two is a little bit
scary with the popularity of smokec
screen coming back in this tournament to
try and answer the sets, the yeast and
actually the Annies. all of them kind of
having good and a lot of Kai'Sa players
realizing you know what it actually is
kind of nice in the mirror sometimes and
now it adds to that range where before
it was so common for it to be out of the
list
>> well- as you're talking about sort of
the shape of these games and you know
it's about accelerate punk outs and once
someone gets to four once they get to
the six they're very likely to get to
eight all that sort of stuff sometimes
where these lists can get themselves
into problems is just too much of their
cards only play on their own turn and
you can get into spots where you have a
lot of cards in hand, you have
ostensibly the right stuff, but you just
don't have enough interaction on your
opponent's turns and they're able to
squeeze out those points. I mean, if you
look at if Shecky loses this game, it is
because of that, because of just not
having enough play on Carmen's turns.
Every exchange in this game has been
ostensibly profitable for Shecky or
almost all of them. But it's still just
the race to what it is. And if you are
not able to play back on your opponent's
turn, then you can get into a lot of
trouble. And sometimes you play some of
the less efficient or more narrow stuff
just to have more playback on your
opponent's turn.
>> Yeah. And while the smoke screen could
be a blowout there, right, pushing the
Darius below the Kaiser, the Ray does
still offer up that trade and denies
Carmen those points. not only the five
from the hold, but the five from the
conquer as well and brings back parody
in the matchup, which allows Chucky to
start to turn things around, start to
gain a point advantage when he already
kind of had a card advantage earlier on.
And Karma's not going to let that
happen.
>> Yep. I mean, again, it's that's not the
uh the most attractive
hexac necessarily. It's just keeping
someone off a point is that's just uh
the most important concern by quite a
bit.
>> Yeah. Full cost hopeful just going to be
the play and interaction kept up for
Sheeki now. Bunch of runes available. It
looks like five ready to fire back on
whatever Carmen wants to do. That's
going to have those void seekers in the
range if you want to try and push this
hopeful for the point. And you do then
have to consider from Karman's side, do
we push into whatever interaction check
he's holding up or do I have enough
cards that I can just full develop?
>> Yeah,
>> we'll say flinch.
Flinch. He will. Void Seeker is going to
be able to just deal with that. Hopeful
draw a new card. But Carmen now having a
lot more information on what possibly
could be left for Sheeki. Three runes
available. Yeah. And this is not a
matchup I don't think that rewards you
very much for setting up. There's a lot
of removal that can hit the base. And
again, so much pressure is on just
scoring those points that I understand
abstractly. Maybe if there's a void
secret here, I kind of want to hold off.
But I I think the the riskreward
proposition is just too good to try to
go for it.
>> Honestly, this is the use case of these
rear guards that I I love to see. When
you get to these late game standills,
that accelerate is huge.
>> Yes,
>> that is a point that no other shoe drop
is scoring for Carmen in this spot.
Also, watching this game, I I can I hope
the the viewer at home who's maybe a
little surprised by this has an
appreciation why some of the expert
Kaisa players are souring on time warp
in the mirror.
>> This is so not about that at all. No
one's ever been in in a position where
they could possibly play it.
There's Carmen just the full development
now walking into unfortunately, you
know, having to worry about a Kathy Rain
coming from the other side now.
>> Y
>> but not much room to try and play around
it.
>> But it even something like that which
would be granted not good for Carmen.
I'm not saying that
>> it still doesn't break up the game plan
of here's an accelerate thing, take a
point and just figure it out down the
line.
stupified just for the card for
Sheekchi.
Uh but it also will set up this falling
star goes onto the hopeful. We are going
to have the Darius come down second
card. Make sure he can get the
accelerate. But that falling star has
been sitting in hand for a while. And
it's finally having the spot where it's
going to allow for a full board clear.
>> And I think the way that Carmen's
setting up the strategy and how do you
play around falling star, right? To some
extent you can't do it. It's just going
to be good. But I think the way that
Carmen plays around it is by making each
unit that she plays so individually
threatening that you do not have the
luxury of waiting for the second juicy
target. You just kind of have to cash it
in when you can. Yeah. Question here.
Does Carmen have a retreat? Doesn't look
like it. Going to just have to let that
go. Gets an extra draw. Carmen down to
only two cards. One of them, I believe,
is that Watcher, which will allow her to
get back on board, but this is Shaki
going to six, threatening to end the
game. He's also low Econ, right? only
the two cards in hand. Question is, are
those two enough to make it happen or
can Carmen actually get control with the
Thousand Tailed Watcher?
>> And the way that Carmen sort of set up
here strategically and tactically, I
would I think there's a possibility that
Retreat is not even in her deck anymore.
>> Yeah. Could be game one side out or
maybe not even in the deck at all.
Curious. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
If you are just I am I'm going to try to
be as efficient as possible. I'm gonna
accept exchanges that are maybe not good
on the surface just in the the race to
points.
Retreat's kind of the opposite of that
experience. So
Carmen never wants to have a card in her
hand that's super fidgety. Just stuff
that always works.
>> Rain
just deal with everything. Say you don't
have two accelerates which likely I mean
two cards in hand
just a numbers game probably doesn't
retreat that increases the likelihood as
you've just put one back
>> rain pass is tough here from Carmen not
even having a development
>> to go on the back of that
>> and Carmen looks like she's aware the
writing is on the wall there.
Maybe there's a Phantom Watcher in
Carmen's hand. Maybe I was seeing things
that weren't there.
Sometimes you get a glimpse of a card,
you think you know what it is, but
Patty Porro's second card would be
Darius, but not having the double
accelerate. So, just going to go for the
pass. Keep up interaction.
>> Yeah.
Good patience from Shecky recognizing
you can't lose right here,
>> right? Yeah, very disciplined play, but
you know, there are sequences of cards
here,
you know, stupify plus void. I can it
would be straining a little bit just
because the Darius would go up to seven
in that world. But still airing on the
side of caution here knowing that as you
mentioned Carmen is not threatening to
win the game here
is just the Darius.
And now with the Porro you get to
threaten to win the game with your
Darius. You don't need another
accelerate. You push Porro in. Can you
push the Darius on the other side and if
Carmen doesn't immediately have an
answer in these two cards, that'll be
enough. But Carman's just going to put a
porro try and say, "Hey, you cannot
conquer this side. You can trade that
Darius I know you have in hand into this
board. You can't end the game unless
you've got a little bit more cleave in
the hand for Sheeki."
And that is, you know, card number two
that can just be played for the purposes
of Darius
>> Conquer from the Pouty Porro.
I think that last card is Watcher, but I
might have just completely missed it.
And if I did, maybe there's some kind of
interaction that can save this spot. But
this is Darius Cleave 10 going into
seven to push Sheeki into the top 64 on
Kai'Sa. And Han Carman only her second
ever loss in that mirror
and the hand extends. That's just going
to do it. Shecky moving on to the top 60
for one of our Kaisers who will make it.
Carmen not guaranteed out yet. Could
have very good breakers. X and two
doesn't mean you're gone. Just only a
limited amount of those X and twos are
going to make it.
>> Yeah, it's going to be a tough squeeze.
Now Carmen's in better shape than most
because I believe she was 5 and one the
last time that we talked. And that's
certainly going to be on the better end
of those X and two tiebreers, but we'll
still have to win round number one nine
to even have a shot at it. And uh past
that, it's just fingers crossed. I mean,
nothing you can do about it at this
point other than try to win your round.
Hopefully things shake out the right
way. And we'll see if we're watching her
tomorrow.
>> And I love that being able to watch
these Kaiser mirrors where we are kind
of at these top teams. This is the
masterclass of the mirror. These players
have likely won multiple mirrors today
to even get to that point. and the fact
that it was kind of even two different
flavors. Shecky a much more measured
approach, a lot slower, the kind of deck
that you would think maybe does actually
even have the time warps where on the
other side, Carmen a lot more fast, a
lot more aggressive, and we see it
nearly get there, but it does flame out
towards the end as Chucky did have just
kind of more card advantage as we got to
that later stage. And you call it early
on the later that game went, the more
advantagey was.
>> Yeah. I mean, I I like that Carmen's
approach to the matchup is just sort of
saying this deck plays defense very
poorly, so why try to defend? And also,
this deck is not very good at holding in
the mirror. So, if I could just kind of,
you know, pick up my points where I can
and then have some accelerate units on
the back end. A lot of people are not
going to be able to hang with that even
if they are drawing their best cards.
That game plan also very naturally plays
around things like Falling Star and
Singularity because you're not really
trying to commit a lot of big stuff onto
the table in the first place.
Unfortunately, uh Chucky on the other
side had a lot of really really cheap
interaction and was able to stay
steptoep with Carmen for the most part.
It wasn't like he was sitting back on a
bunch of six and sevens and eights and
expecting them to play catch-up. He was
also kind of advancing the board. And
then with my one energy left over, I'm
playing back in combat. I have some sort
of removal spell. And if you are able to
keep pace in terms of the tenor of the
game and the speed of it, eventually
your superior card quality is going to
come through and eventually shut the
door.
>> All right. Well, I want to set the stage
for round nine. As we're getting towards
that, we have any any player who came in
undefeated in this last round, they
they've probably IDed the last two.
They're going to make it through into
the top 64. Anyone that comes into this
ninth round at uh 7 and 1, they can ID
the last round. They're going to make it
in. There are a certain amount of
players at 71 and or sorry uh 61 and one
going into this round. This becomes
guaranteed win in for all of those
players. So those are the matches we're
going to try and find. Some amount of
X2s can find a win in this last round
and they will sneak in as well. But
these X1 and that we're going to have
that is a guaranteed win in that we'll
be watching. We are going to jump to a
dev interview. After that, we'll come
back with that round nine and we will
get to kind of see that culmination,
that winin for a lot of these players as
they try and fight their way into that
top 64. Don't go anywhere.
[Music]
All right, I'm here with Frank Scar, a
game designer on Riftbound. And Frank, I
got to ask you, you know, being at an
event of this magnitude on a game that
you got to work on, I mean, how does
that feel?
>> Uh, yeah, Cass, it feels really awesome.
Honestly, super special. It's so amazing
to just see kind of all these seats
filled, everybody having a great time.
Um, I've been walking around the event
talking to people, seeing like cosplays
and everyone just seems really excited.
Um, you know, in my past I attended a
ton of these events as a player and
seeing being kind of on this side of the
fence is like really surreal, you know,
especially when we were like here
yesterday seeing the hall get set up and
it's just really touching and it's the
amount of like work that went in from
the whole team seeing it kind of like
come to culmination is really really
cool.
>> All right. Well, and we've got the
second set on the way, Spirit Forge, and
there's a lot of uh new kind of keywords
and mechanics coming in. We've got, you
know, weapon master, we've got uh
repeat, we've got the like attachable
gear, and I wanted to ask you what uh
maybe some of the challenges were of
trying to introduce a bunch of new
keywords and mechanics.
>> Okay. Uh, so yeah, I would say probably
the biggest challenge is, you know,
obviously we want each set to be kind of
special in its own way, kind of shake up
the game, give people something new and
exciting to like latch on to, but at the
same time, you know, we don't want to
put too much complexity in the game too
quickly. Still a new game, people are
still kind of learning the base
mechanics. So, it's really like managing
that push and pull of like how do we
make this set new and exciting without
taking too much away from what we
already have or overloading players with
too many mechanics too quickly. Um, and
also Spirit Forge kind of had a unique
challenge of a lot of it is focused
around equipment. You know, two of those
keywords with equipment and weapon
master are very equipment focused. So,
we kind of went to repeat to be like a
spell keyword to give, you know, maybe
some not everyone's going to love
equipment and but repeat will give them
something else to try if that's not
their thing.
>> That that that's really cool. And I
mean, for people looking to try
something exciting in Spirit Forge, what
were maybe some of the legends that you
are the most excited to put in the hands
of the players? Yeah, probably the one
that I am most excited to see folks pick
up is uh Ranata. I think the, you know,
one of our other big mechanics for the
set is gold. I think gold is like really
cool. Gives players kind of new ways to
like mess with their power costs outside
of like stuff like seals or just
recycling runes. And the legend when you
know you go online and they start adding
energy too, it kind of like we wanted to
do something a little more like comboy,
a little crazy. That's something that
maybe isn't there as much in Origins.
And it was probably the one that we were
like most afraid of. You know, like can
we break this? What's like the craziest?
Can you time warp early and stuff like
that? And you know, we we had builds of
Ranatada that we felt pretty confident
in, but I'm excited to see what players
do cuz their decks are definitely going
to be better than ours. And um also just
lover's signature spell. Uh we uh played
it for a long time. Hostile takeover,
you know, you got to take control of an
opponent's unit for a while. And the
thing that I really loved is we added
Hidden On pretty late. And at first it
was like, "Oh, this spell is so
powerful. It's so expensive. we can't
put hidden on this, but since it's like,
you know, battlefield restricted, the
context of the hidden is pretty
different. And I think it's just like
it's really cool to get that exciting
moment of, wow, this like expensive
powerful card is hidden, but it plays
completely different. And I I don't
know. I just think it's going to be cool
to see what players do with Ranatada.
>> Yeah, I love that idea. It's like it
takes a spell that goes from stealing a
battlefield and conquering it to now
it's like this whole tool that's very
niche and specific. So, I think that
that makes a lot of sense. Well, you
know, that's that's Spirit Forge. That's
very exciting. That's coming out. But we
are at an Origins event here for the
Houston regional uh or regional
qualifier. Uh Frank, what what legends
from Origins are the ones that you want
to see on the broadcast? I mean, you're
going to be casting some games. Who are
you really hoping that you get a chance
to talk about?
>> So, my my favorite Origins uh legend is
definitely Teemo. And you know, it's
funny because I I hate Teemo in League
of Legends. You know, like I'm a top
laner. I play like Darius, Gwen, all
these like auto attack champions that
Teemo just gets to mow down. But I love
him in Riftbound, which is part of what
I think is cool because like I get to
love him here, even though I hate him
there. Um, and yeah, I just enjoy the
hidden game plan. I think it's really
cool. There's a lot of skill expression
there on like what are you going to hide
when, when are you going to like hide
your fight or flight versus hold it to
to play in a combat. I also really love
the Teemo decks that play Nocturn. So, I
hope we get to see some of those because
I think like the the Nocturn sweats are
the most fun and cool things going on.
>> All right, thanks so much, Frank, for
doing this interview, giving us a little
insight into the dev process for Spirit
Forge. And now we're going to send it
over back to the desk for more of the
Houston regional qualifiers.
>> Chengren, it's six to four and I'm
holding both battlefields.
>> So I have to conquer both and hold on to
them to win the game.
>> Yeah, that's impossible.
Your Draven doesn't stand a chance
against my Azir and his mighty sand
soldier army. That's 10 total night,
buddy.
>> We'll see about that. I attack with
Draven.
>> Puny. Pay one power and give him plus
two.
>> Ooh, scary. Not.
>> That's not all. I pay one and play blood
rush then give Draven plus two. I pay
one, play blood rush and give Draven
plus two. You
>> don't have to repeat yourself. I heard
you the first time.
>> I'm using our new repeat mechanic.
>> Oh well, it's still not enough to
conquer.
>> With my remaining runes, I'm going to
support Draven
with the long sword.
[Music]
Uh-oh.
>> Man, I'm good. With my 12 my to your 10,
I will conquer this battlefield and wipe
your sand soldiers off the board.
>> Whoa, not so fast.
I wonder what this thing does.
I'll grant this quick draw equipment,
Sterex gauge, to the one and only
Emperor of the Sands, Azir. That gives
him three additional might. You do not
follow the map, but you must witness,
which gives me 13 total might, one more
than yours. Your attack is defeated.
>> No.
>> I guess there's only one move left. I
invoke rule 650.
>> Riftbound rule 650. A player may concede
at any time.
>> GG.
>> Close game. Hi everyone, Chang and Dave
from the Riftbound team here. We hope
you've been having a blast with the
origin set.
>> We've been seeing a ton of theory
crafting starting from the initial card
reveals and the team is super energized
by the amount of excitement that you
rift bounders have shown for our game.
>> As we continue on our rift on journey,
we wanted to introduce everyone to our
second set, spirit forged. Being spirit
forged, weapons aren't just tools.
They're extensions of your might and
soul. The forged aspect is the steel you
wield, while the spear represents the
Ionia spirit blossom, which has lifted
the veil between the mortal and spirit
realms and made its way home in some of
the champions and art for our new set.
Spirit forge takes origins and builds
upon it in every way with more ways to
play each domain, 12 new legends,
equipment that lets you enhance your
units in new ways, and a new gear token
type, gold, which provides a new path to
power. You won't believe some of the
cool stuff we have coming your way. Not
to mention 12 incredible Spirit Blossom
overnumber cards like these.
>> Dave and Changen aren't allowed to show
you these cards yet.
>> Huh. All right. Well, here's something
we can tell you about. Equipment.
>> Take a look at Trinity Force. Equipable
for the low cost of a single power. It
grants your unit plus two might and also
gives you an additional victory point
when you hold a battlefield with it
equipped. Tons of damage. Uh, actually
it's just plus two might and a victory
point.
>> All right. All right. Moving on. We've
also got equipment that's a little
tricky to play, like guardian angel, a
card that prevents its unit from dying
one time. But equipment is only as good
as the unit that holds it. Well, that's
not exactly true, as it can enhance any
unit or champion you play. But it does
help to know how you use the equipment.
Enter weapon master, one of our new
keywords that allows units to equip
something for free when played. Take a
look at Lucian Merciless. He can conquer
again if he wins the fight. And with the
right equipment in his hands, he
definitely will.
>> Mastery of equipment is definitely
strong, but I prefer speed. Quick draw
is our other new keyword. With quick
draw, you can plate equipment from your
hand onto a unit as a reaction, like on
this card, long sword. Quick draw makes
equipment an important part of the
chain.
>> The chain? Is that one of our new
weapons?
>> Gotcha. The chain is the sequence where
players respond to each other with
activated abilities or reaction spells
until both are done. It is not a
physical thing. Dave,
>> who is saying that? We actually don't
know.
>> There is something I do know all about.
Our new champion, legend, Civer and
Ranata Classic. These two champions are
all about gold. They create it and you
get to spend it.
>> Spending gold gets you a power resource
of any domain. letting you play more
powerful cards.
>> One of my favorite new champions is
Draven Vanquisher, who generates gold
when he conquers. Time to cash in on all
that adoration.
>> And one of my favorite new champions is
Draven Vanquisher, who generates gold
when he conquers. Time to cash in on all
that adoration.
>> Uh, Dave, you okay? Why? Why are you
repeating me?
>> Sorry, I was just excited for the final
mechanic reveal. Repeat. With repeat,
you can play a spell twice if you can
pay its cost a second time. Spells like
feral strength are good, but if you have
the runes, we don't have to settle for
good. We can have great.
>> All this talk about repeat is making me
think that our last game needs a repeat,
too.
>> Wait, what do you mean?
>> Chengren, it's six to four and I'm
holding both battlefields.
>> So, I have to conquer both and hold on
to them to win the game.
>> That's right. It's impossible. Wait, why
does this feel familiar?
>> Don't worry about it.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
[Music]
Heat. N.
Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
[Music]
Nat. Heat.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Welcome back to the Houston Regional
Qualifiers. I'm Kasanova joined by
Patrick Sullivan. We did have a little
repair for round nine, so we got a
little bit of time to fill. And uh
Patrick, I figured we could talk a
little bit about Spear Forge as that's
coming on the horizon. It is out in
China and it's coming out at the uh kind
of start of the new year uh going into
2026.
>> So this was the uh first set that I had
any amount of work on and I don't want
to overstate the case. Essentially, I
was brought in towards the end of the
process here, learned the game, played,
gave some feedback. This is so I got a
little bit of this, but for the most
part, this is before my time. Want to be
clear about that.
>> Yeah. So, we got some fresh eyes as we
take a look at the kind of one of the
first legends from their blade dancer.
Really, the uh the cover art of Spirit
Forge is going to be Aurelia. And this
says, "When you choose a friendly unit,
you may exhaust me and pay one uh power
to ready it. When you conquer, you may
pay one energy to ready me." And uh the
fun one that I immediately saw flooding
Twitter for this is white flame
protector target self and then be able
to have that kind of 16 uh accelerate
costing three power at that eight
energy.
>> So just in terms of just professional
due diligence, my own preferences here,
I want to be clear. I don't think it's
uh wise for me to be talking about power
level. I think the players want to
discover that themselves. I will offer
this, however,
for sure. This was Brian Kibler's
favorite legend. I did not see him play
a different deck for the week that I was
there other than this one. And if you
like messing around with stat
modification, reing stuff, moving
around, maybe you're into ganking,
probably going to have a good time with
this one.
>> Yeah, I think at the very least, she
looks really cool, really fun. If you
like Yasu already, this is some more
movement. Let's let's go ahead and move
on to the next one. We've got fire below
the mountain. This is or the or legend.
This is uh you know Kaiso for gear as
people have been saying, right? You've
got this reaction to add one power that
you can use only to play gear or to use
gear abilities like equipping a gear or
for instance I mean just in his example
it's not in the colors but like baited
hook has a cost of one power. You'd be
able to use that for for this.
>> Yes. As uh as implied by the text box
here, Orin is likely to do quite a bit
with gear and gear related abilities.
And you might find this
disproportionately useful should you be
playing with that class of card.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, I I would think so.
>> I think let's next that was that's all
we need. You know what? You're right,
Patrick. That was perfect and we don't
need anymore. That's we we'll move on.
We're not a glass. This is the chem
baroness. When you were an ally, hold,
you may exhaust me to play a gold gear
token exhausted. When your score is
within three points of the victory
score, your gold add an additional
energy. Gold is that new kind of gear
token that comes in that can add a
power. It's like a one-time seal. Uh and
uh this has been, you know, a really
cool idea where you get to generate this
gold and then maybe play some things
with higher power costs uh and not
dramp, still continue to kind of
increase that energy,
>> right? and you're you're going to, you
know, see a variety of costs where maybe
it's much heavier on power than energy.
Also worth noting that the gold token is
it is a oneshot seal in some respects.
It's actually slightly better than that
because it can make power of any. It's
not bound by whatever the whatever the
uh domain of the seal is. Uh this one's
quite a bit of fun in my opinion. Um I I
do like messing around with the gold
stuff because it does give a very
different context for certain cards that
you might be like, "Oh, that's just a
lot of recycling." But if you go down
the gold route, now you got this route
to make it a little bit easier. And then
if you get within those three victory
points now,
>> the the combinations of cars that you
can start thinking about because there's
a lot of elements of the game that are
sort of bound by it's pretty hard to get
past 12 energy. There are ways to do it
or whatever, but a lot of combinations
of cards that you think of, you're like,
"Well, well, that costs eight and that
costs six." You can't really do that.
The stuff that allows you to like
imagine going to 13, 14, 15 pretty
reliably really opens up a new dimension
in gameplay and deck building that we
haven't really seen up until.
>> All right. Well, we'll see if she can
break the math. But that's enough of
that for Spirit Forge. That's coming out
soon enough. We still have Origins to
talk about. We still have the Houston
Regional qualifier to finish up day one
of. So, let's go ahead and jump in to
round nine. These are win and you get
the victory here. You are going to day
two. You are making that top 64 and
having a chance to try and fight to
become the champion, earn that
qualification to the regional. And we
once again have a Yasuo on a win and in
looking like it's going up against
Teemo.
Sorry, correction. It is going to be a
Kaiisa from majority here going up
against Teemo. Just having some issues
here with the graphic. We'll get that
corrected soon enough.
>> Yeah. And you would have to imagine at
this point with with Ichan 7 here at six
and two uh that this person has beaten
Kai'Sa once or twice at least over the
course of this event.
>> And so we will be jumping into this game
one
Teemo versus Kai'Sa
chance on the Teemo. You know a very
sought after best of but also just
because Teemo is a very solid deck.
Really really good. has some results,
right? The top eight at Vegas from
Prismaticism. Uh also in China, kind of
the third best performing deck outside
of the Kai'Sa and the Yei. And so some
players coming through and having some
success on the Swift Scout here as well.
>> Yeah, I think it might it's possible it
has just the highest ceiling of any
deck. Your best draws or if your
opponent, you know, help them if they
don't have a play on turn number one. uh
you this deck could actually pitch a
shut out some amount of the time.
Ceiling is very high. That said, if it
doesn't get one of those overwhelming
hidden starts. Um you know the the a lot
of the cards play their best when you
are holding and controlling battlefields
and sort of getting off that snowball
advantage early on. If you don't get it
early, a lot of your cards are pretty
inefficient, but if you're able to get
on top of the game, sometimes you never
let go.
>> Yeah. One of the uh kind of uh
underrated aspects that you do get to
have out of the Teemo list is you always
have a uh a two drop on turn one because
you do have just this uh this Teemo in
your champion zone. You can play this
the scout out. Um and uh it does allow
you to at least be able to try and get
some action in the early stages of the
game. Now it is going to be Zon Warren
from Teemo with the scrap heaps. yet
another purple deck utilizing this
strategy and we've seen it be so
successful over the course of this first
day of tournament play while on the
other side reavers row from the Kaisen.
Usually the reaver's row signifies a
more aggressive Kai'Sa build and
actually just trying to go for even
accelerating the Kaisen pushing her in
though in this case just going to be the
four runes just going to be playing her
back row.
But this does mean that the the window
is open here for Teemo here to take a
battlefield and start locking at least
one up a little bit.
>> Yeah. So, because it is open, as you
said, right, the
scout Teemo can just move into the
Reaver's Row, get the point, and if
there is something that you can replace
it with, you can then bounce it with
your Swift Scout ability and then try
and replay it as a hidden. But when I'm
looking at this hand, I'm not seeing a
lot of units. There's a Mundo.
>> Mhm.
>> But outside of that, I didn't see
anything like an ember monk. that
inverted timelines. While it can be
really nice to fuel a Mundo if it has to
ditch your Mundo as well, that's a
little bit less exciting of a prospect.
Might just be deployed straight away
though because this hand is not doing
enough for eye chance. So just going to
go for that discard draw five because of
the scrap heap, but also just giving a
reby over to majority.
now actually finding some hidden that
can be used to play it with the Teemo or
even just playing a tide turner
trying to potentially rehide the Teemo.
Pick it up and then hide it. But that
can't work with the tie turner on the
same turn. So just going to pass, keep
up some action, maybe even just the
retreat, bring the Teemo back the
oldfashioned way.
>> Yep. I mean, it's not like majority is
going to be establishing some
battlefield that's unassailable here.
So, at this point, and I Chance still
has the flexibility of kind of just
keeping the resources intact, trying to
play a tempo efficient game
on the Reavers though, considering if he
just wants to move the Teemo back with
that or even can just go for the retreat
straight away.
There's a lot of value in the ramp
>> and also just that's a card that's a
little bit fidgety, right? It's it's not
a guarantee that two turns from now it's
going to be particularly valuable. So
just nice to kind of get one of the more
fickle enablers out of your hand first
and then have smoother, less situational
cards to work with in the future.
>> Yeah. And for majority side, you're
looking at a teamo with nothing on the
bench, nothing on the battlefields. Easy
just development turn. Kaiso on reavers
row
>> kind of. This is your happy place when
you're playing the Kaiso.
>> Was forced to do something for I chance.
And it is just going to be a sprite. Try
and go into the Z warren and be able to
use utilize these scrap heaps. get a
bunch of different options. There's two
scrap heaps in hand, so needs to really
pressure these through.
>> This is still not really moving the ball
forward a little bit. This is a nice
This is nice, you know, smooth out the
hand a little bit, draw some cards. Um,
but it's going to be hard for I Chance
to really establish some sort of stable
position somewhere to start deploying
uh various hidden cards or to be able to
interact with one of the battlefields at
all here really.
Yeah, there's a new Mundo in hand. So,
at least the late game is insured.
You've got the the big guy that you need
to be able to kind of ride on the back
of to try and actually win out against
the Kai'Sa. Very difficult for her to
deal with. And this is a Warren game, so
you'll kind of have all the fuel that
you need. Can always hide the Teemo to
respond to the temporary trigger.
However, majority might still just be
able to press in onto the Warren with
this much might on the back here going
up to four points already.
>> Yeah,
I mean, in theory, there is an incentive
just kind of let it go for this turn
because it would force eye chance to do
whatever is going on down there with the
hidden card and you're going to lose the
temporary token also. But
maybe this is just too juicy to pass up.
>> Yeah, as there is just going to be
Darius comes down. There's just so much
might the majority has access to.
And I think you might as well start
barreling through. But there's also the
consideration, as you said, right? Like
you're going to have to reveal this
hidden card in response to the temporary
trigger. The the sprite's going away.
You can just continue to stack this back
row. I I still think that the there's
something to be said for you bar you
just barrel in. There's no way the
hidden card's going to matter all that
much. And uh one benefit is it becomes
so much harder the following turn for a
chance to break up your hold and do
anything with these hidden cards.
>> Yeah. So this is seven into seven
action over to Eye Chance. Can put a
sprite there.
>> Okay.
And that will allow for a hold. But once
again, it's holding with a temporary
unit and just kind of presenting the
question of do you want to deal with
this Darius? And majority says, you know
what? I don't even want to let the
Darius go down. Just going to bring it
back to the hand. Instead of trading
with the Teemo and one sprite and then
pushing in a hopeful over the top, this
says, I want to keep the material and
I'm at four, so I'm on point gains for
the game. You can have these sprites.
They're all going to go away.
>> And it's not a card that's easy to use
profitably against Teemo in the first
place. It's not like they play a whole
ton of target removal.
>> Yeah, really singularity is what you're
watching out for,
>> right? My intuition there, my instinct
from majority side was just to barrel in
with everything. All the units feel very
replacement level to me, but I can
appreciate some level of just let's
tease this out a little bit. It's low
opportunity cost. There's plenty of
hidden cards down there where it
wouldn't really even matter if I did
this in the first place. And you know,
every single turn you're going to be
presenting another attack that's going
to require multiple resources to do
anything about.
>> There's also a consideration to with
this much might getting put on the back.
Can you go over a Mundo?
>> Can you actually can we just get to the
point where it's like, you know what?
Yeah, your Mundo's pretty big, but I got
all this
>> right.
>> N chance even considering that prospect
right now has the eight runes. can just
drop the Mundo and say I'm going to
hold, but not gonna have much to follow
it up as far as the hiddens are
concerned.
You can pick up the Teemo and you can
put him back down using uh actual power
>> if you want. But other than that, it
it's just like a hidden of a of a tide
turner and it looks like I chance is
just going to maybe keep the Mundo at
home.
All right,
>> I like the idea here,
>> right? I mean, the the problem is that
loading up into to one battlefield is
just, you know, majority gets to
scadaddle over the other one and uh how
are you getting over there? So, I I do
think that I chance wants to keep some
level of flexibility depending on which
battlefield majority decides to engage
with. There is a pretty powerful uh
response coming back. Yeah, I also like,
you know, Mundo at home, tide turner in
the battlefield hidden. So if majority
takes an unprofitable attack in or tries
to to greet out, just send in something
small, deal with the team, deal with
whatever hidden, you can swap the Mundo
and kind of pick up a free kill,
>> right? Yeah. is interesting to see what
majority wants to do here because I
think there is an argument for you have
just kind of enough sort of random units
floating around here that you have the
flexibility to sort of I think you can
use an attack that's unlikely to be
successful just to tease out what the
hidden card is and then respond with
your more valuable things down the road.
>> Yeah, you got to learn.
>> Yeah,
>> you have to the the the poking and the
proddding, the learning attack.
friend of mine refers to it as
clarifying the game state. You have a
you know you got something over here.
It's not doing a whole lot. It it forces
the issue regardless on the hidden card
because you know I chance would lose
control of the battlefield. It would
just go away anyway. So if you think
you've got enough wiggle room to work
with, you can just see what's going on
first before you start committing some
of your more valuable resources.
>> This is where we actually saw some
Kaiser players teching in. bring here
thunderstorm
>> to force Teemo to flip up the hidden
really simplify it.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. But this is going to be an
Athenian rain coming down. This will
also kind of work because you can put
one target on the Teemo unless majority
actually just has enough damage to push
through the Mundo.
And we saw this earlier in the day of
Aka having Exaxis to push through a
Mundo. It was knock pass into
prismaticism where we saw exactly this
rain into falling star to deal with the
Mundo
and he is just going to swap the tide
turner out. Mundo's still going to go
down but the tide turner no longer just
going to disappear for free. and a
really nice uh you know if you if you
put the read on there for tie turner
doing it in such a way that there's you
know uh engaging with the Mundo with no
risk of putting something in the trash
is also very nice.
So now majority just gets to go up to
six for free including that conquer with
the Kaisa survivor gets that drawn card
and it's on the reaver's row so you just
always have the ability to back off.
Yeah,
>> these are the spots for Teemo that the
comeback against Kai'Sa feels nearly
impossible. It's it's once your Mundo's
been dealt with and you don't really
have that many answers, there's too much
board state, six points, these are the
spots where it's too far gone.
>> Yeah. And all of your cards are these
like kind of nickel and dime incremental
kind of exchanges. You can't even
establish them in the first place. And
even if you could, they wouldn't really
be a broad answer to what's going on
right now.
>> Yeah, if it came down to unit combat, I
chance had all the tools to pivot the
Mundo. Ride the wind, had the tide
turner, found a fighter flight there.
That's everything you need to just kind
of move him around the battlefield and
pivot around. Make sure you're dealing
with whatever units Kai is putting out.
But it's not enough this time as that
rain falling star combination is just
enough damage to deal with the good
doctor and send I chance down a game
going into the second game of this
winning in majority one game away from
making it to that top 64.
>> Yeah. Well hopefully
>> hopefully I would hope
>> the winner the winner here is going to
have a sweat regardless. Even if you
feel like your tiebreers, you don't know
until you know. You don't know how many
of the executes you're going to be
completing against.
But certainly step one regardless is
winning this one.
>> Losing out.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. We don't know if it's a win in. We
do know if it's a losing.
>> Certainly a losing out.
>> Ray on to the student.
High chance thumbming a retreat be able
to deal with this, keep more material
and ramp up. Singularity in hand. We
talked about how this can be a good
removal tool in the matchup being able
to deal with something like a hopeful
and a Kaisa. Very, very powerful, very
potent and buying a lot of space for
this deck as instead it looks like it is
just going to be a couple of spells cast
to get the Raven Bloom out of range
>> of this Ray and save that retreat for
later.
Not the easiest card, by the way, to uh
use profitably in this matchup just
because I Chance does not have a whole
lot of ways to make it about combat
inside of the battlefield. It's really
just arbitrarily controlling and then
deploying. So, being able to catch in
the supervis
out of it, it's very nice.
>> Find some new options as well. Was
looking for a second hidden to go
alongside the Teemo at the battle tree.
Hoping for a consult the pass. Found a
fight or flight. Didn't feel really good
to hide it in this spot.
>> Rather keep the modularity of having it
in hand being able to be played at
either battlefield
and save it for later as another Ray
going to come down. Going to have to try
and deal with this once again. This time
may just have to reveal the Teemo and
finally deploy that retreat to keep the
Raven Bloom around.
Now it's big for Teemo to find the early
win or the early conquer there.
We'll see what's going on with this
shift as we come back to cameras. should
be getting right back into that match
soon enough hopefully. But we'll talk a
little bit about that battlefield
structure that we've got. Right. Teemo
on the play has the battle tree. That's
two uh hidden can go there instead of
just the usual one. Normally you can
only hide a single card on a
battlefield. Battle tree opens that up
to hide a second which becomes a very
good battlefield for Teemo to hold. And
being on the play, you get to come out
first. You're up a single point. So in
theory, Teemo can just hold one
battlefield the entire game and find a
win because the Kai'Sa can never get
ahead on points.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. And on the other side, it's the
void gate which is an incredibly hostile
battlefield for the Teemo to have to try
and play towards because of that plus
one damage to all of Kai'Sa's spells. So
what we're seeing from the early stages
are I chance moving into that battle
tree trying to set up kind of this
permanent hold and hopefully not have to
play around the void gate too much. But
for majority, you do just kind of have
to make this happen. You have to force
the issue and push I chance off this
tree.
>> Yes, you you So it's not Yes, you can
hold it and you can hide two cards
there. Holding forever is not a trivial
thing to do. You now you get a really
big front-loaded advantage, which is
when you hide the two cards there, it
already assumes you're controlling the
battlefield in the first place. That's a
lot to get through. But as time goes on,
typically you can kind of build up
something that is capable of attacking
through it because you're still capped
at the two hidden cards. But it is a
pretty substantial advantage to just
have that battlefield really hard to
engage with for at least two or three
turns while you're setting up a way to
go around it.
>> Yeah. Often times what you'll see is you
hold it for a few turns, you get this
kind of point lead. Finally, you'll get
pushed off, but then you you've got
enough that you can retake and then
reestablish that hold to try and win.
and try your best to not interface with
the very hostile uh battlefield as much
as you can. And sometimes you're still
going to have to maybe look for a ride
the win towards the end of the game or
some kind of trick that's going to help
you win at the very last stages.
>> Yeah. Or another way to try to handle it
is just to again clarify the game state,
tease it out. If you get to a spot where
it's a pretty low opportunity cost to uh
present an attack that at least says if
you let this happen, you will lose the
battlefield and then therefore you're
hidden cards. So you're obligated to
play whatever you have down there. Now,
you don't want to go too far down that
road because the worst thing that you
can have have happen is you get blown
out in combat and your opponent goes,
"All right, rehide two cards down here.
Try again next turn." So you can kind of
do it the two ways. One is just a sit
wait. Your opponent's not going to add
very much to it and then you can try to
go over top with a bunch of stuff or if
you think there's a low opportunity cost
way to tease out some of it, then you
can do it then. But you you don't get
really two big shots at it. You get one
big shot. So you want to make sure that
you're you can play over the top of
whatever the range is of the two hidden
cards. And this Ember Monk is the card
that actually gets the most value out of
the Bandal tree because it gets plus two
might whenever you reveal a card from
hidden. Now you got twice the hidden now
instead of just being kind of this six,
this constant six uh on defense that you
have to worry about and you can kind of
calculate now. Yes, you know it's eight,
but eight is a significant difference.
Having that plus two breaks a lot of the
different break points that you were
normally looking at this Darius could
come in and trade with an ember monk
even if a hidden is flipped. you can
say, you know what, I got to deal with
the ember monk. Now at 8, that doesn't
get to happen.
>> And very interesting there to just to to
pull off the battlefield that was being
held there. I think majority is trying
to set this up where he will have the
resources to be able to tease out an
attack next turn. And even even as
trivial as a one might unit is in that
sequence, it is part potentially part of
the distribution of being able to uh
push through or at least see what's
going on with the hidden cards.
>> Yeah. And near as majority is trying to
set up for that big push that
singularity gets to come out and deal
with the setup, deal with the Darius and
the Vi. And while on other battlefields
that Darius may have been deployed to
run directly into the Ember Monk, just
take the trade, this time you're not
allowed to do that. And the payoff comes
through in the form of the singularity.
>> Yeah. And I think that singularity is
clearly a very strong card generally
speaking. I think it might be at its
best in Teemo because this is so
frequently the shape of the game. One
battlefield is set up. There's a lot
going on there. If you try to sort of
incrementally go through it with
slightly more than what you need that
against what's face up, you're just
going to get blown out. Majority is
aware of this. And so you kind of have
to peel back your base a little bit and
set up something where you have multiple
permutations of attacks, multiple things
that are larger than the one thing
that's face up there to be able to slog
through all the hidden cards. And if
you're just sort of sitting there in
stasis not doing anything, singularity
is going to be really really good a lot
of time as we just saw.
>> Yeah. And now it comes down to majority
to have an answer even though he was
establishing what should have been the
answer. This is some factf finding
missions coming out of the void seeker.
Just going to deal four damage to the
ember monk. Of course, something will be
revealed from hidden, but that will give
majority at least information and a new
card to go with the four energy
remaining to see if there's anything you
can start to send in to attempt to go
for a trade. But you need four damage,
not two to deal with the zber monk as
there is an additional hidden.
>> And and this is no critique of majority.
This is this is just where it got
forced. can see why he was trying to set
up a very different structure a few
turns ago. Cuz this is the nightmare,
right? You send in here, there's another
hidden card that pops up that's
disruptive to combat or somehow save
something. You fail to get the
battlefield. You lose a lot of resources
along the way. And then Chance just gets
to go, okay, hide two more cards, try
again. It's only going to get harder
from here.
>> Yeah, this feels like a cleave. You send
the two in so that you'll just trade
with the monk if this doesn't get
revealed. Uh, and then if it is revealed
to be consult the past, you have the
cleave to at least try and trade. And if
it's a fight or flight, well, that's
fine. You just let this happen.
>> Yeah, it's whatever he's going to do
with it is going to happen. It's nothing
to be done.
>> Maybe he pushes your thing. Maybe he
just saves the whatever he perceives to
be the highest value unit of his own.
But at least the burden is on chance to
make a decision first and then you can
just sort of proceed from there.
>> Yeah. The unfortunate thing is because
this is a combat, if the fighter flight
pushes away the yortal, you don't get
the chance to then come in and cleave
the uh Watchful Sentry instead and still
be able to trade even with that
additional plus two. Um, and so instead,
we do end up seeing just to push back on
the Ember Monk. Uh, the Yortle will just
go down to the Teemo. Uh, and now just a
double hopeful drop for Majority. So,
the entire hand pretty much being units
this time around.
>> Yeah. And you know, again, this is
majority was trying to avoid this sort
of setup at all costs. It the
singularity forced his hand. There was
no longer an opportunity to really wait.
They had to try his best to plow
through. But now it's we we can go back
in and hide again and try to to break
through. This is only getting harder.
>> Yeah. And what a rip off the top to just
find another singularity as majority
develops two more fours in the back row.
that's just going to deal with those and
not many cards left for majority to try
and turn things around as the Emer Monk
can just run back in. You can pick up
the Teemo. You can hide it with the
Ember Monk to continue to have that
increased value. And Ember Monk running
onto Voidgate is rough. It's actually
quite scary to be in that environment.
It's very hostile. It does open up Ray
to now threatening the Ember Monk and
forcing the reveal. That four break
point becoming very important. Uh, but
because he's at six to two, I think I
chance recognizing I have Mundo in hand
and I can go up to six by moving into
the void gate instead of waiting. This
does put a lot of pressure on my
opponent.
>> And also, if majority was sitting on a
damage based spell, there's a very good
chance you would just saw it the
previous turn anyway.
>> Back over to majority. Full grip of
runes, but not a lot of options.
Kai'Sa survivor available to try and dig
for more if you want to accelerate that
in, but it's not really putting uh
>> too much on the scales going up against
I chance,
>> right?
>> The hidden Teemo face up 10 on the void
gate.
Only two cards and a single rune. So
realistically the range is stupify
but only two cards for majority and you
can look for an additional draw. Going
to start with just going for a smoke
screen.
>> Okay,
>> not even full value. Only gets three
here cuz it's before the reveal of
hidden.
So now sending in the trade to force the
team reveal.
Just going to draw an additional card.
No action yet. Rain, we'll clean this
up.
>> Okay,
>> looks like that was the find off the top
of the deck.
>> Yeah, you would have probably opened
differently for something else. Um,
maybe not.
>> Yeah, I guess you kind of want to deal
with the Teemo, right?
>> So, there's there's there's reason that
you would do it in this way. This does
require the flip of the Teemo by sending
in the sentry after the smoke screen. It
does open up uh
>> maybe the only way that you actually
just get eye chance to reveal
everything. So you can rain it all, but
going down to a single card for majority
as this Mundo is likely to hit the board
now, that's going to be really tough to
deal with.
Yeah, so many resources just expended
already getting up to this point.
Mundo has to wait at home. I chance will
have the conquer and then look for the
hold. We'll have to get rid of three of
these cards from the trash. Not a lot of
ways to really fill up the trash. This
Mundo won't be unobtainable,
but currently it looks like well plus
eight plus even more plus 9 15 on the
Mundo.
>> Unobtainable is strong, but there's a
there's a wide range in between easy to
deal with.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. This is 15. It'll go down to 12
next turn.
Putting eight might on the board for
majority is a good start though and
finding a way to deal with the Mundo.
Watcher is going to get there. But oh, I
thought that was third singularity. That
scared the hell out of me. No, it's just
he's going through the trash. He's going
through the trash.
>> So, uh, interesting there. Majority did
have an opportunity to just accelerate
the Kai'Sa and take a card. I think
actually very wise not to. Um, this
Mundo is going to have to just go into
some sort of battlefield anyway.
uh the Kai'Sa would simply die. And so
your Kai'Sa hanging back there
threatening whatever is more valuable
than drawing a card. Even though I think
a lot of level one intuition is just
like ah you got a rune laying around,
you're out of cards. Like obviously you
just take the card there. I think that
uh sort of deal is likely to be
available to majority next turn anyway.
>> Whoa.
>> Oh, okay. I think this is interesting
with majority only being on one card.
I'm not sure I like this. I think uh
giving the Kai'Sa some action maybe not
the best, but you are making this Mundo
massive once again. However, moving on
to the void gate. I don't know how many
copies of Rain are in majority's deck.
You just gave him four more cards.
Cathine Rain does a hell of a lot. Oh,
never mind. It's a ride the win.
>> That'll just get you there.
>> Anything that generates a spray,
anything that moves like there are it's
not it's definitely not zero risk, but
there is plenty of hits there to end the
game and he found one.
>> Yeah, he did. He found that ride, the
win to go with the Mundo, able to just
run into the void gate, send it over.
That's going to bring us to a game
three. Both these players fighting for
their lives in the tournament. First
game looked dominant for Kaisa. Second
game, the reverse. And for our third
game, we have Aspirin's Climb and Star
Tip Peak. Both of which kind of favoring
a long game. And I think Teemo likes to
see this
>> settle in.
So aspirins for Teemo. We're playing
nine and majority with the start tip
peak. The hold being able to get you
that additional rune. If Teemo can get a
foothold there, that can become a
nightmare very fast for the Kai'Sa.
>> Yes.
Interesting
from Ichan spending the rune to put the
Teemo in hand just to obuscate which
hidden he could be putting down instead
of just playing it from the champ zone
as normal. Also extra also interesting
there from majority there just um uh
assuing just playing Kai'Sa out of the
champion zone
>> for leaving up two here signaling either
my Kai'Sa is more valuable than just
putting it out there and having get
exposed to something or having some sort
of interaction.
So it will be the Ray valuing the
attempt at a hold to try and get this
rune. But the sprite is going to come
down. And unless there is another Ray
here, that is just going to be a conquer
for Eye Chance. Denying the hold.
You can still look to respond to this
temporary trigger. Look for a hold of
your own.
Jordy will have to deal with this if he
wants to deny the rune.
Can always just look to accelerate
Kai'Sa, but you still have to be worried
about Teemo. Though, I will say because
there was the Teemo discarded off of the
traveling merchant trigger. I think
you're a little less wary of Scout.
However, you do want to be careful that
if there are main deck versions of the
Scout that you don't get completely
blown out by it. Another thing you got
to just be mindful of here too when
you're talking about a play like Kai'Sa
just advancing that way is um trying to
reduce a little bit of liability against
singularity
you know just dropping Kai'Sa and a two
let's say now you're really leaning into
it and I think that majority has shown a
certain level of wanting to not you know
as much as possible reduce reduce the
risk profile of that card game two win
such a way that he couldn't really avoid
it but there were turns intervening
where he was clearly trying to just not
leave too high value targets on the
table. Ultimately couldn't be avoided
but majority is definitely giving that
some primacy here.
>> Not going to be a hold just to consult
the past as the hidden next to that
sprite just to get two more cards in the
hand. A lot of top end for eye chance in
the grip. Double Watcher, Mundo,
Singularity
going to have to find time to play all
of these big bombs, but they are
difficult for Kai'Sa to deal with over
the course of a game. Yeah,
a lot of what you kind of want to do is
just in spots like this is try to have
some whatever your biggest chunkiest
most productive play is. It's often good
to just get that out of the way now with
an eye towards setting up two or three
turn cards in the following turns.
So, all other things being equal here.
Yeah, I just I love this.
>> Yeah, I love this. Here's just a just a
big old body. No,
>> no accelerate. No, it's just it's the
clunkiest thing in my hand. It's still
going to be useful the next turn. The
game's not really going in a way where
the accelerate is going to be that
valuable. You're not, you know, majority
is going out of his way to make sure
things are not lingering on the
battlefield. So, just get this down.
This is going to do something next turn.
turn is going to require some sort of
response and try to get into a spot
where you can be playing two or three
high impact cards in the same turn.
>> Yeah. And he's got another one. So even
if the watcher effect is something he
feels like he needs for later in the
game, you can still play one now. Have
this seven might body. We talked about
fours and sevens in the match up. Seven
might body now and you still have one
for later.
>> Darius going to move into the start to
peak push majority up to four points.
Student going to come back to bring the
Darius home.
>> Yes. Don't want to leave that lingering.
>> Not going to allow for any free pickoffs
by the Thousand Tailed Watcher though.
Singularity now opened up again. Darius
and Kaisa, two juicy options.
>> It's hard hard to avoid it entirely, but
anything that you leave lingering on a
battlefield would just get swallowed up.
So, pull it all back. Singularity is
still going to be good here, but you
know the the real crux the real what you
would really love to do is singularity
and follow up with a second or third
productive thing. The hidden cards allow
you to do that. But that's why I I think
it was worth just playing the thousand
tail watcher last turn the most
efficient thing to do strictly from the
lens of that turn. I hope not. I hope
you have something better to do than 77
generic vanilla. However, it's good
enough to force some action from
majority and now you get to follow up
with multiple cards, multiple points of
interaction.
>> Yeah. What I'm what I'm looking at here
with eye chance though, lot of cards in
the hand, nothing to hide. So, nothing
to kind of go alongside this seven to
defend the peak. There is action in the
form of a stupify and a ride the wind.
and ride the wind can create some really
awkward scenarios for your opponent on
their turn, especially when you try and
go in with something big to this peak
and suddenly the Watcher's not there
anymore. And in fact, it's at the
aspirin's climb looking for a conquer.
>> And it's interesting, too. I wonder if
if I chance sort of deemphasize the the
hidden stuff a little bit. It's not like
it's particularly easy to be holding
against Kai'Sa. They are very good at
winning those fights in the middle. And
if majority is sort of willing to give
up equity in some of these combats to
try to set up shop and play a little bit
slower to have the ability to plow
through this theoretical sequence of
hidden cards. Maybe it's just better to
play a more efficient just nuts and
bolts removal and unit game and not
worry so much about the hidden stuff.
>> Yeah. And I mean we see that with the
choice of the traveling merchant to get
rid of the Teemo, right?
>> And there's no other hidden card in the
hand that you can actually utilize that.
There was a consult the pass that did
come out in into play, but that that's
it, right? And there was this was a big
grip of cards
>> and consult the pass is probably the top
of the list of just like the most game
state agnostic hidden card you can ask
for. You just hide it and it doesn't
matter if you lose control of the
battlefield. It's a card that you It's
not great to play for full retail, but
it's not situational at least. You can
always just do it.
>> Yeah. And if you get the chance to pay
one energy draw, too, you just take it.
It's it's good pretty much no matter as
you said game state agnostic as it is
going to be the raven blue moving in. I
chance has to consider is now the time
to deploy the ride the wind to try and
stop the conquer while majority has so
many runes available or do you wait and
see if there's a better opportunity or
do you not even cast it because it's
very expensive to have singularity and
then spend more power on a ride the wind
after the fact.
>> There's another another issue with the
ride to win here is I mean you would be
matching up with a Raven Bloom student.
There's no guarantee that you just win
that combat. It's one thing if you know
for sure, yeah, I'm just swallowing this
thing up. I'm taking my point.
>> There's the possibility that you
actually lose in combat or trade. And I
just had to feel at this point like
>> you can get more out of a ride the wind
than just a nebulous maybe it works,
maybe it doesn't sort of trade.
>> Yeah. So that is going to be the first
hold on start peak. An extra rune for
Ichance's trouble. definitely gonna love
that with this handful of Mundo watchers
and all the big stuff, but majority has
pushed up to five points. Still a point
deficit. IC chance a bit behind
and is there enough time to deploy all
of these big things, these big threats
when you need a lot of the little stuff
to help kind of bridge the gap some more
the hidden as you talked about easy to
kind of find and and actually uh make
the board state a lot more clear from
majority but at this point you don't
have a lot of the little things to even
play with this Fox and deal with some of
the small threats.
>> Yeah.
Trash looking a little thin for Mundo.
Not a whole lot going on there. I mean,
the hidden cards also subsidize that
quite a bit. And if they've been sort of
peeled back here by eye chance,
you can't feel good about the
possibility of your, you know, sprite
being able to win a combat with this
Raven Bloom student, but it's also just
such a huge and unwieldy investment to
say, I'll accelerate
another one of the sevens.
So, there's a bunch of options here.
None of them clearly the best. None of
them even clearly likely to work. And
that's why I think you saw I chance
almost almost started the turn with a
supery saying like whatever's in my hand
is not what I'm trying to do this turn.
A a fresh draw step is uh quite valuable
to me right now.
>> And we are going to see eight runes. I
mean that's that's Mundo or could be the
other watcher accelerated try and push
off this Raven Bloom. just have two
sevens on the battlefields and hope that
that can do enough.
>> Yeah,
>> I think it's the watch or no. Okay,
Mundo. I thought the trash was looking a
little thin to go for the Mundo.
>> Yeah,
>> is going to be the choice,
>> right? I but I guess there there's still
the if you appreciated the possibility
that last turn if you had moved in and
fought the Raven Bloom student you could
have lost well you still have to respect
the possibility going into your turn. So
this might just be all right this turn
I'm going to establish a football hold
in this battlefield. I think it's
unlikely my opponent's going to be able
to conquer it because they just don't
have a whole lot on the way back.
Assuming that it goes that way, I have a
lot more resources to work with the
following turn to break up the f the
other battlefield. And it's not like
anything else that that majority has
back here materially changes the
outcome. It's just a flurry of spells
making the Raven Bloom student so large
that it can win against something
substantially better. So, if you were
willing to play around it on Majority's
last turn, you should probably still be
willing to play around it on your turn.
And yeah, this Mundo isn't pretty, but I
think I Chance is trying to say I I
respect the possibility that this Raven
Bloom can get super big or there's
enough removal spells that maybe my my
Watcher just gets clipped and next turn
I'll have a much better shot of actually
making some inroads against it.
>> And while it's not pretty, it's still an
11 for this turn.
>> Yeah,
>> it will start to shred its might
relatively quickly. It's not a large
trash pile, but we did also see that
invert timelines in hand. And suddenly
this Mundo can grow rather large if you
want to dump the hand. However, there's
a lot of valuable cards in this hand
that you're probably wanting to play
with. So unlikely to show up, but still
it is a spot where you can kind of
increase the might of this Mundo quite
easily. And to go back from a couple
turns ago, you know, we're talking about
you want to just kind of have your you
want to try to get your big chunky turns
out of the way as much as possible. The
the spots where I chance is actually
going to turn the game around are going
to involve pulling multiple cards in a
turn. So you don't want to go halfway on
that. You want to sandbag as much cheap
stuff as possible to try to really do it
all in one turn. And so if you get in
the spot where it's I can play this
three cost card or this four cost card
and this one cost card, but it's not
appreciably better than just playing the
Mundo, play the Mundo. Set yourself have
that option back. Especially if you're
talking about maybe drawing four cards,
you want to be able to go one cost, two
cost, two cost, draw and maybe hit a
third or fourth or fifth substitive
thing.
>> All right, we're going to start a flurry
of spells from Majority Falling Star.
Six damage onto Mundo. I saw a second
one. It's going to come through. Six
more will kill Mundo.
As we said, this is just an 11. So,
double star. That's 12 damage.
Mundo does get to go down.
Oh, okay. Three at Mundo, three at
Watcher. So, this leads me to believe
there is Thousand Tailed Watcher, seven
runes immediately. That would deal with
the Mundo and sets you up to remove
>> that watcher as well. Or cleave. Is this
just enough damage?
>> Double cleave.
It's eight. Mundo's on three life. On
the other side, there's four. Yeah,
>> I'm going to assume has this is a really
rough attack if it's short.
>> No, it's it's it and it's not short. He
he is going to have enough damage to
push in on this swing. And with no runes
available for Eye Chance, you know, this
is safe.
Look like they're just determining
damage now.
Unless I'm really bad at math. I think
he's I think he's over.
>> Well, if you do all this and your
point's short, you lose. So hopefully
>> I'm going to trust that majority here
has has done the math.
>> Yeah. No, it's it's good.
>> It's sound. I
>> Right.
>> I did it like three times and I was like
I look, it's late.
>> I try to not do too much math on on
stream. I think uh you're just asking
for trouble. But
>> Absolutely. Yeah. But I felt like there
was, you know, as you said, if you go
for that and you you didn't count right
there, we're we're in trouble.
>> Yeah,
>> we're in big trouble. But majority does
break through. Both the Watcher and the
Mundo gets the conquer up to seven. Able
to maintain a Raven Bloom in the back
row
though. Ich does have the runes and we
know there's another Thousand Tail
Watcher. So the game is certainly not
ending right here. There's no way this
Sentry is just holding on.
Doesn't feel like majority has many
cards. I'm not sure if it's one or if
that's a stack, but I if it's a stack,
it's it's only two, three cards at max.
>> I I I mean,
>> looks like one.
>> Majority fired off, you know.
>> Yeah,
>> multiple falling stars and multiple
cleaves last turn.
>> Four cards last turn. Yeah,
>> I think we're looking at one card. Gets
a draw. Gets another draw off the
sentry.
>> Three cards in a Raven Bloom can be
plenty to finish off the game, but it
all starts with what is found
from the sentry
with the accelerated watcher running
through.
Only a single rune available for eye
chance that will represent a stupify.
This watcher is an eight.
>> Yes.
>> However, there's still the possibility
of majority just avoiding that
battlefield for the time being and
trying to set something else up in the
back row.
>> Void seeker start.
>> Yeah,
>> four damage onto the Watcher will pump
the Raven Bloom up to three currently.
Raven Bloom would trade into Watcher. We
know that Stupify is there.
Smoke screen that's going to push
through. Deal with the Watcher at
reaction speed.
Yeah, remember that four damage is still
locked in at this point because there
has not been a combat.
>> So, reducing the might below the amount
of damage counters on the Watcher that
will kill the Watcher. This is something
you can do. You can play it in either
order. You can reduce the might and then
deal the damage or you can deal the
damage then reduce the might. As long as
the damage is greater than the might
value, unit will get trashed. And the
Raven Bloom will move in just to draw a
card. Oh no, we're on Aspirin's clan,
>> right?
>> We'll just go up to eight.
One point away. Could look for the hold
with the Raven Bloom. We'll see what
action is found for Eye Chance. We know
the ride the winds are there. So very
likely has a way to deal with this first
Raven Bloom. But still a mountain to
climb.
Start with the monk
riding the wind.
Oh, that is massive. No answer available
to this.
as that is four damage into the ember
monk. I'm looking at the hand.
There's no recourse. Yes, there is a
raven bloom and another ride the wind,
but only three runes.
That might be majority
giving himself a shot on this win and
end to try and get in through breakers
and cutting this aspirin climb short for
eye chance as it is going to be just a
stupified draw card. One more look. Tide
Turner is not going to do it. Void
Seeker comes down. Majority draws a
card. One or two runes left, but that
will just be this Raven Bloom holding
for the win for Majority.
>> Wow. I mean, that was unbelievable play
there. And uh a lot of credit you got to
give there to the sequencing because
that could have just been double void,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz you had to have drawn it on drawn it
off the draw there. You could have just
said, "All right, we got to just keep
going back. We got I got to find more
stuff to do. We got to find more stuff
to do. The fact that that void seeker
was insurance against that play from the
following turn where a minus might trick
would not have worked. Really brilliant
sequencing. A lot of discipline.
>> Yeah, really well done for Majority and
that is going to give him that best
chance to try and make it in. Right,
that 7-2 record can be good enough. Some
amount of those 72s will sneak into that
top 64. So, he's looking for that. But
we do have one more match in this final
round. We're going to jump straight into
game three of Tingfang versus Pretend
Penguin. That is going to be Kai'Sa
versus Set. This is a true win in 61 in
one. This is guaranteed. If you win
this, you are in. If you lose this, you
are out.
>> Yeah. As opposed to the previous match
where we're still going to have to wait
to see if if if majority has done enough
to make the second day. This one's
really straightforward. After eight
rounds and two games, it's this for it
all. And Tingfang is a player who had
made the the top eight of Vegas as well.
We've had a lot of success out of the
players who did top eight that event and
top eight in Atlanta as well. We've seen
a lot of these players having success
once again here in Houston showing that
consistency. Tingfang did have a really
unique Kaiso list at Vegas that included
a three of the Fury seals and was
playing a little bit slower with those
seals. A much more controlled game. I'm
curious if Tingfang is on a similar list
this time around or if he's changed it
up.
and pretend Penguin off to a pretty
rough start here in game number three on
the draw. Nothing to do on the first
turn.
>> Yeah, and it's real tough when you're on
the draw because you've got those two
drops, but also in your range, you may
have some three drops even if it's just
a first mate turn one, which is not
ideal. You want to use it for the ready
effect, but just getting a body down is
so important
>> just to be able to play back on your
second turn a little bit here.
>> Looking at the battlefield start to peak
for Tingfang in this final game. Similar
to majority, right? Having that trying
to look for the hold to get the extra
rune and set holding on to Monastery for
game three. This I feel like is set's
best battlefield. It's kind of
one-sided. If you've got the Sithria,
you're able to kind of generate so many
extra cards, but no early drop, no
Sithria, no way to abuse the Monastery
Piranha.
>> Yeah. Then once it once you kind of get
that that shot set up of of buffs and
large units and moving things back, it's
very very hard to manage it with with
removal or even combat because there's
so much value coming back for just the
the cost of one power to be able to
recall something and fire back in the
next turn. However, when you don't have
much established, that cost becomes
huge. So, pretend Penguin's basically
going to have to try to set up at least
one buffed unit large enough to make
inroads at one of the battlefields. And
there from from there, you can at least
start making it a very high opportunity
cost to engage in that one.
>> Yeah, finally finding that Cyria. So,
you can at least use that uh as the
engine this set deck loves to have. not
only for uh drawing cards on monastery
but also fueling the call to glories uh
for free. Some of these decks even
playing Wallup, we saw a lot in China.
Have not seen it so much uh in the west,
but there are still plenty of cards that
are going to be used with that. And we
see one now with the call to glory.
[Music]
King Fang going to score the hold.
Double Kai'Sa on board. Kai'Sa still in
the champ zone. We talked about how
usually two was what we were seeing out
of most of most Kaisers in the
tournament. Tingfang deciding he wants
the third. And to me that may lead even
further towards the fact that he was on
those seals before. This gives more draw
and the seals allow that accelerate to
come through without dramping you. It
may lead to believe that he is still
playing these red seals. Yeah.
Smoke
screen. Seal the to play the pay the
deflect cost or Kai'Sa either way.
>> Move survivor in.
>> Yeah.
>> Easy enough for the conquer. the boss
going to be activated to keep the Fiora
around
>> as Tingfang at five full control of the
game. But pretend Penguin with a good
back rank now to at least try to
recontest. The point lead though is
starting to extend way beyond comfort
level. Yeah.
>> For Pretend Penguin. it it it you are
approaching the spot where even if you
are able to sort of start to get a
foothold in at least one battlefield,
it's going to be hard to hold both for
four turns, which is kind of what you're
starting to look at
>> into a deck that runs things like
Thousand Tailed Watcher, runs Zathian
Reigns.
>> So many ways to manage these
battlefields.
We talk about how hard it is to prevent
Kai'Sa from conquering
Once again, we find a player in that
spot where you have to.
>> That's your only chance is to stop the
Kai'Sa from being able to find the
conquers
right now just wanting to deal with some
of the material
that is on the board without losing
anything of your own. I I get ideally
against Kaiser, you kind of get in the
spot where you're able to pick up the
majority of your points through just
conquering and having the flexibility to
pull out. That's why the Annie deck has
such a strong match up against it.
Typically, once you fall this far
behind, you just sort of definitionally
have to try to hold. One, because you
need to catch up in points, and two,
because you cannot allow the battlefield
to just be trivally conquered.
Unfortunately,
as you mentioned, with all the
accelerate units and things like
Singularity, it's just very challenging
to hold, you know, points one through
six. That's that's a hard way to do it
here.
>> Yeah. When you grind a game out and you
just need the last one, that's already
hard enough, but sometimes you can get
there. But, as you're saying, the whole
game
>> Yeah.
>> a full comeback
We got a showstopper for the kingpin.
Classically very good against Kaisa
being able to showstopper the kingpin.
Get the buff. He goes up to seven but
seven going into four. That does open up
that three break point and array will
offer the trade. Of course, boss is
there to protect but unyielding,
>> okay,
>> is an answer. It's a good sequence.
>> Help find a foothold
against Ting Fang.
>> Not going to pay the buff for the draw
it looks like. Keeping that buff on
Cyria in the back.
>> Yeah, I mean at this point it's not
about the card economy. It's the numbers
matter a lot.
and also just the ability to recall
should it go that way.
Looks like this game three has gone to
time as we noticing now that two in the
middle that is going to be the turn
count.
We're going to start with the stupify
onto Fiora. Tingfang with the point
lead. This also will matter for the time
being at five. But it does feel like
this game could end before those five
turns are up.
Darius second card played.
Try and push Tingfang towards six points
to set up for one final push to end the
game.
Kaisa into the three from Fiora.
That's just going to be accepted by
Penguin.
>> Six points for Ting Fang. Extra card
drawn.
>> Yeah, I think Tingf Fang very probably
assumed that attack was good. Uh but you
want to probe it out first and leave
Darius for a more profitable combat over
the other battlefield.
>> Yeah. And there you go. Seven on Darius.
Stupify once again going to make the
attack profitable for now. Seven into
six.
>> Yeah. I mean, if you couldn't stop the
first one, I'm assuming you can't stop
the second one. So, we're just recalling
here.
>> Boss activated up to seven for Ting
Fang.
Just has to hold one side to win. Only
one rune to help defend. Only five
runes, three cards for pretend Penguin
to push over the five and the four.
>> I was asking a ton to say nothing of the
turret situation.
Kingpin already goes over the top of
Kai'Sa just baseline five into four.
Recall going to be deployed. So no more
action from Ting Fang, but he will have
an accelerate at a moment's notice out
of hand and an extra rune to work with
on this next turn.
Now the Darius,
can Sithria break through? I'm going to
assume yes. with her being pushed in.
That looks like a primal strength.
>> Okay,
>> plus seven. That'll make it happen.
>> 10 penguin up to four. Tingfang at
seven. No units on the board. Will have
to have everything come from hand, but
there is a Kai'Sa. So, at least one
Accelerate ready to go.
Looking for maybe a Darius to pair with
it. That would be able to push over the
top.
Start with the spell falling star
unyielding to answer.
It's going to be hard for pretend
penguin from this spot even if they get
out of this turn to maintain the
recalling of the buffed units here back
to base because just getting so lean on
runes.
Hard to imagine how he can
simultaneously be recalling stuff and
play things substanted enough to keep up
in the game.
>> Watcher is the followup.
Falling Star would have been able to
push everything through. Watcher can
still deny one side, draw an additional
card, deal with the kingpin
>> as there's no buff available for him. It
is just a Sithri on board, just a card
in hand for pretend penguin to try and
deal with this. going to the final turn
of turns as he goes up to six points.
>> Ting is threatening the win here anyway.
So, we're not talking about something
very much determined by time.
>> It's not. It looks like there's no
answer for Pretend Penguin. Extends the
fist bump. Ting Fang top eights in Vegas
is going to make the top 64 of the
Houston regional qualifier. Continuing
on this building of a legacy at the
start of a brand new game. Yeah, it's so
cool to be able to get on the ground
floor of something and uh you know a
tournament like in Vegas, it's you don't
really know for sure just what is the
level of scrutiny that's on it. How well
do players even know about it compared
to something like Houston, right? Where
this is like our first really big riot
event. There's 13 to 1400 people in
there. But one way that you can kind of
establish yourself is just doing it
twice in a row. Exactly. At that point,
it's like no one can handwave
>> the this tournament right here or the
one that came before it. So hopefully he
can get a good night's sleep. It's going
to be It was a long day today. It's
going to be a long day tomorrow, but at
71 and1, he'll be among the 64
competitors that'll be joining us on
Sunday.
>> Yeah. And joining the ranks of any of
the other Kais that made it through. It
was 33% of the room. We expect a decent
conversion on the Kai'Sa. Still, we saw
a lot of them at the top tables
throughout the day. Dingfang one of
those players kind of carrying the torch
of the best deck in format. if that can
actually prove to be the case.
>> Well, I I think we saw a lot of
vulnerabilities for Kaisaw on camera as
well. And not just there's one champion,
there's one card, there's what we saw a
mixture of people going very, very fast
and very much underneath and disengaging
from the interaction. We saw some people
go way over the top, establish a
football hold, and then just dominating
combat with tricks. And even among the
Kais decks, we saw a variety of builds.
I mean, we we saw players that are very
skilled, very well established, have
very different approaches to how they
constructed the deck, very different
approaches for how they were playing on
winning the mirror match. And so,
there's still a lot of room for
permutation and innovation. Kais is
certainly the most popular deck. I would
be shocked if it wasn't the most played
deck in the second day just by raw
numbers. But inside of that, there is
clearly no consensus of this is the way
the deck is built and if you are trying
to beat it, here are the different ways
you can go about doing it. We saw on
display today and I expect that see more
of that tomorrow morning.
>> Yeah. And it's been really fun to see
that continue from the tournaments in
China. It was different Kaisalists
throughout the entire run. Even though
yes, Kaiso won so many times, it was
with different variations. And we
continue to just see that evolve over
and over again depending on what decks
you think are the problems. Do you think
Annie is the problem? So then bring the
vile moss and bring some more void
seekers and try and answer there. Do you
think Yi is still the problem? Do you
have to go big enough? Are the mega
still coming around? So having all these
different answers and what we're seeing
so far is yes, the Annie is a problem.
Yes, Annie is making it towards these
top tables. Yes, Yei is a problem still
making it towards the top tables. But
also there's some rogue decks and you
have to be ready to be on your toes to
deal with them. And also the rogue decks
here mean entirely different play
patterns. It's not just like ah there's
a card here. It's like different
champion, different legend, different
signature spell. So even if you get in
your reps playing against whatever you
think the three best decks are going
into a particular weekend and you know
that it's going to be really rare that
those three decks constitute the
entirety of your nine rounds. And so you
still need to spend your time getting in
rips in against the stuff that's a
little bit more on the margins because
it's again it's not just oh they've got
a a slightly different for drop or
whatever. They have an entirely
different collection of cards. So you
still have to get in all that practice
against the entire spectrum of the metag
game. Even if you pinpoint the two or
three decks that it's you know this is
going to be the majority of the room.
This is what I'm gunning against. You
can't just have blind spots on your
radar.
>> All right. Okay. Well, what I'm hearing
is we do in fact have standing. So,
let's go ahead and take a look at that
as we're heading into tomorrow. Take a
look at some of the names we saw
throughout the day, right? Shecky we saw
win that Kaiser against Carmen makes it
in as the second seed. We see Allen's
EQ. Trick Patel. We both saw both of
them on stream. A Kaisa from Allen.
Trick piloting that. Annie doing really
well. I recognize Samans. I saw them go
7-0. She went 7-0 playing uh Aurora
Misfortune throughout the day. So,
really cool to see a lot of these
players popping off. Aliadrazi. we also
had on stream playing Aurora MF. So, a
lot of these decks coming through.
>> Yeah. Uh Ali, someone that I also know
pretty well um through other card games
and someone who loves to brew, loves
combo decks, loves going way over the
top, something big and dramatic. No
surprise to see him playing Aurora and
doing well with it.
>> Yeah, and you know, of course, I
mentioned Alan Zuba, that's Legends of
Room Terra world champion showing up big
in another Riot card game. Uh Trick
Patel, twotime national champion in
flesh and blood, but also a huge magic
career coming in and saying, "You know
what? I've got another card game that I
want to dig my teeth into and try and do
the best." And he's made it to that day
two. As we get to the next round of
players, sold out. This has been a uh
very popular Annie player for a long
time. Really pushing the Annie meta
since the very beginning. and the fact
that he gets to sneak in to that top 64
piloting that Annie deck. But right
above him is Floring Christian Logan
Malak X on Volully Bear going 71 and one
probably locking up his Voly Bear best
of card
>> as well as still pushing even further
right is not even just falling out at
the end but actually making the top 64.
Yeah, I mean I was doing a little
gunslinging with Volibear and I can't
speak to the quality of the deck, but
the one thing I'll tell you about
Volibear, really good once it's in play.
So, awesome. Awesome.
>> All right, as we keep going through some
of the names, we've got Megan, who's
been another player who's been really
pushing some of the early riftbound
stuff. I talked to him earlier. He's on
the Teemo to join another Teemo on the
other side. Prismaticism still fighting
over that best of card and pushing to
get maybe Teemo into the top eight. We
just saw Ting Fang make it in off of,
you know, that really great top eight in
Vegas. And now another day two and Push
P. I want to call this one out. First
ever seasonal champion in Legends of
Rotera. The very first one was won by
Push P and now he is back for another
Riot title.
>> It's really great that you and I come
from like slightly different backgrounds
here. I want to give a shout out to our
seven and two at the top of the seven
and twos there. Jonathan Job, uh, owner
of Kfabave Car Games out in Salt Lake
City, Utah. Houston native in town here
battling event. Someone again that I've
known for a very long time. And, uh,
again, top of the piles of the seven and
twos there and will be playing tomorrow.
>> And sneaking in at the bottom of the
pile of 7-2, George G, Chongqing
Regional Open Champion, flew to China,
played all the regionals and actually
won one. does squeeze in back in the US
at Houston at 64th to slide in. Shout
out to Randy flying in from France 7
and2 playing that Kai'Sa as well. And we
saw Nal Pass earlier Alan Woo massive uh
player really really well done early on
able to squeeze in at that 72 as well.
>> I think I saw a name there on one of the
previous pages of a Magic Pro who I
believe would have flown in from Poland
had he played in this event. So already
a global event, a global game. Um, you
know, the reception here has been
incredible. It's been so much fun just
being around the hall. And, you know, I
I knew that the event sold out very
quickly, obviously being on the the Riot
side. I didn't have a sense of how much
of that is the local Houston area versus
the United States more broadly versus
all over. But there are there are
players who came in from multiple
continents here that'll be battling
tomorrow or opportunity to get that cash
prize, maybe be the top finisher with
their champion and with their legend.
And I'm very excited for single
elimination. I mean, imagine just the
you win your last round, you're 71 and
one and it's I'm exhausted, right? And
it's just I'm fried. It's been
stressful. I've been playing for 14
hours. It's like, "All right, go get
some sleep." And you're coming back
tomorrow for single elimination play.
>> Do or die.
>> Do or die every single round to find out
who's going to be the winner of this
tournament.
>> Yeah. And we're still We're still
rolling dice coming in. Everybody's
coming in. It's just like you were
playing in the Swiss rounds. But now
there's back against the wall. You got
nothing left.
>> Those records have nothing to do with
what is going on in day two. 7-2, 9
and0. Same record. It's the 64 people
that'll be playing single elimination
rounds tomorrow. Obviously, every win
along the way matters a lot for those
prize payouts. And so, as whatever level
of fried, shot, exhausted you are, you
got to shake that off, get some sleep,
because tomorrow is going to be even
harder than today.
>> All right. Well, we're a little fried
ourselves, and we want to get some rest
coming into tomorrow so we can make sure
to provide you that quality coverage.
So, please make sure to tune in tomorrow
once again for that top 64 here at the
Houston Regional Qualifier. We can't
wait to see you tomorrow where we get to
crown our very first champion here in
the West. So, we hope that you'll come
back and we get to see you for it all.
We'll see you tomorrow. Let's go.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.